ON NATURAL RESOURCES AND WATER
TOGETHER. AND I'VE A FEW
HOUSEKEEPING. MEASURES FIRST.
WHICH IS THAT IN RESPONSE TO
THE CODE NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND
TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS IN AND HEAR THE
SOCIAL DISTANCING AND FACE
COVERING GUIDELINES. AND
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE IS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. WE
ARE HOLDING PARK COMMITTEE
HEARINGS HERE IN THE CAPITAL
WITH SOME OF OUR MEMBERS
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY. I DO
NOT SEE SENATOR LIMóN ON THE
SCREEN I KNOW SHE- INTENDS TO
PARTICIPATE REMOTELY. SO I
WOULD KNOWLEDGE HER AT THE TIME
THAT THAT SHE ARRIVES SENATOR
STERN. WILL BE PRESENTING HIS
BILL AND VOTING AT THE END
TODAY. AND AS A REMINDER OF FOR
SENATORS. AND OF PEOPLE THAT
WILL BE ON THE PHONE PLEASE
MUTE YOUR PHONES OR COMPUTERS
WILL GREATLY AID IN ANY.
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK IF YOU WISH
TO ROBBIE RECOGNIZE USED TO
RAISE YOUR HAND FEATURE IN THE
PROGRAM- WHEN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED A POP UP WINDOW WILL
APPEAR ASKING IF YOU LIKE TO ON
MUTE. PLEASE SELECT ON MUTE
BEFORE SPEAKING OF OUR I. T.
PERSONNEL WILL PUT YOU BACK ON
YOU WHEN YOU WERE DONE. ONCE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK UP PLEASE
MAKE SURE THAT YOU CAN BE SEEN
ON THE SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME
AND THEN BE READY TO PRESS THE
COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW PUBLIC
ACCESS WITH ADMITTED MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING ROOMS
TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCE REQUIREMENTS ALLOW. IT
IS THIS ROOM ENTERED HIS ROOM
TWENTY EIGHTY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. IT'LL BE DISPLAYED ON
THE SCREEN I WILL ANNOUNCE IT
NOW. TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER
IS EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE
ONE SIX THREE SIX FOUR IN THE
ACCESS CODE IS SIX FIVE FOUR.
1-097-654-2897 THE NUMBER AGAIN
IS. EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO NINE
ONE SIX THREE SIX FOUR. YOU CAN
GET DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON
HOW THE TELECONFERENCES TO
MARKS. ON THE SENATE AND OR THE
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN WE
MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT TO BE
PROMPTED BY MODERATOR TO DIAL
ONE THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION. OPPRESSES ONLY ONE
TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN
OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE
NUMBER THIS CAN BE A SHORT
WHITE. ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR
LINE NUMBER YOU'LL WAIT IN THE
QUEUE FOR THE MODERATOR TO CALL
THAT PHONE NUMBER. AT THE TIME
YOU'LL BE ON MUTED YOU'RE READY
TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE-
MAINTAINED TO CALL DURING THE
HEARING CISCO. ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHOSE DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED
FROM THE REMOTE MEETING
SERVICER HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS
MUTED. THE WALL EVERY EFFORTS
BEEN MADE TO STREAMLINE THE
PROCESS AND CONDUCT OUR
HEARINGS IN THIS CLOSE TO THE
SAME MANNERS CUSTOMARY. THERE
MAY BE SOME LIGHT TIMES FOR
PARTICIPANTS WHEN ADJUSTING TO
THE NEW USE PLEASE BE PATIENT-
I AM CHERRY THE MEETING TODAY
ARE IN BLUE OF GERMAN STERN WHO
WILL PARTICIPATE- IN PROTESTS
IN PRESENTING THIS BILL AND
VOTING WE HAVE TWELVE BILLS ON
TODAY'S AGENDA THREE OF WHICH
ARE PROPOSED FOR CONSENT. BY
THE END WE JUST HAD A QUORUM
WALK IN THE ROOM SO LET ME ASK
TO HAVE THE- SECRETARY TO
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. LAYERED
HERE THIRTY JOE. HERE JONES
HERE OUR- ALLEN HERE EGGMAN.
BIG HERE GROW. GROUP HERE
HERTZBERG. HUESO NO MONNING.
AND. WE HAVE A QUORUM AND THEN
WE THREE I ON FOR FIVE ITEM
FONG FIVE ITEM SEVEN FIVE ITEM
ELEVEN DOES ANYBODY WISHREMOVE
SOMETHING FROM CONSENT. IS
THERE A MOTION TO APPROVE THE
CONSENT. OUR MOTION BY A GROVE
WITH THE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. BLARED HI THERE I'D
JONES JONES I HAVE ALLEN HI
EIGHT. EGGMAN ON A GROW. ROUV
HI HEARD HUESO LONG STORY.
PATTERSON OF VOTES TO PASS
BEFORE HOLD THE ROLE OPEN- FOR
OUR ABSENT MEMBERS WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE TO THE- FIRST ITEM OUR
AUTHOR. IT IS S. B. ONE A BY SO
PAD CAN COAST RESOURCE INTO
LEVEL- MAN PRO TEM WELCOME TO
THE COMMITTEE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND CO- I APPRECIATE
THE COURTESY OF BEING ABLE TO
GO FIRST. I AM HERE TO PRESENT
SB ONE AND NOT MISTER CHAIRMAN
COLLEAGUES I WILL BEGIN BY
ACCEPTING AS AUTHORS AMENDMENTS
THE TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS
RECOMMENDED IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS. COLLEAGUES WE'VE ALL
EXPERIENCED THE DEVASTATING
EFFECTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE FROM
DISASTERS LIKE MASSIVE
WILDFIRES WERE WE'VE LOST
HUNDREDS OF LIVES SAME PROPERTY
DESTROYED AND SUFFERED BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS IN TAXPAYER COST TO
LONG PERIODS OF SEVERE DROUGHT.
WHICH HAS AFFECTED ALSO OUR
STATE'S ABILITY TO GROW FOOD.
I'M A CHANGES ALSO ACUTELY
AFFECTING CALIFORNIA'S COAST
AND MORE SUBTLE IN DAMAGING
WAYS THROUGH SEA LEVEL RISE.
TURNING TO THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE CALIFORNIA
COULD EXPERIENCE THE LEVEL RISE
OF HALF A FOOT IN THE NEXT
DECADE AND UP TO SEVEN FEET BY
THE END OF THE CENTURY. ATIKA
EVENTS LIKE COASTAL STORMS AND
KING TIDES WILL AMPLIFY THESE
EFFECTS. THESE CHANGES COULD
VERY WELL INAND DAY LOW LYING
COASTAL AREAS AND EVEN INLAND
AREAS. WREAKING HAVOC ON BOTH
PRIVATE AND PUBLIC FACILITIES
FOR EXAMPLE IN MY DISTRICT THE
DEL MAR BELUS ARE ERODING AWAY
A MAJOR REAL LINE IT'S THE
SECOND BUSIEST RAIL LINE IN THE
COUNTRY RUNS THROUGH THESE PLUS
AND WITHOUT SIGNIFICANT REPAIR
AND ATTENTION TO THE STATE THE
ATTENTION. THE STATE IS IN
DANGER OF NOT BEING ABLE TO
MOVE PEOPLE AND GOODS
EFFICIENTLY OR EFFECTIVELY.
STATE GOVERNMENT AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ARE ONLY. EARLY
STAGES OF PLANNING FOR AND
ANTICIPATING SEA LEVEL RISE THE
LONGER WE WAIT THE MORE COSTLY
THE DAMAGE WILL BE IN FACT THE
L. A. RECOMMENDS MORE FUNDING
GREATER STATE REGIONAL AND
LOCAL COLLABORATION AND BETTER
INFORMED PLANNING AND LAND USE
DECISIONS TO ADDRESS SEA LEVEL
RISE. SB ONE ESTABLISHES A
STRUCTURE TO IMPLEMENT THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS SPECIFICALLY
THE BILL REQUIRES NEW PLANNING
IMPLEMENTATION AND PUBLIC
AGENCY COORDINATION
REQUIREMENTS TO ADDRESS THE
IMPACTS OF SEA LEVEL RISE FOR
THE FIRST TIME IN CALIFORNIA
LAW. FURTHERMORE SB ONE
REQUIRES THE COASTAL COMMISSION
TO ADOPT AND PERIODICALLY
UPDATE STANDARDS FOR USE IN
LOCAL AND REGIONAL COASTAL
PLANNING IN ORDER TO MORE
EFFECTIVELY IDENTIFY ASSESS AND
MITIGATE SEA LEVEL RISE. SB ONE
ALSO ESTABLISHES A NEW CROSS
GOVERNMENT COLLABORATIVE TO
ENSURE THE IMPACTS OF SEA LEVEL
RISE ARE ANTICIPATED AND
ADDRESSED BEYOND SIMPLY
ENVIRONMENTAL DEPARTMENTS BUT
ALSO BY OUR TRANSPORTATION AND
OUR INFRASTRUCTURE AGENCIES AND
FINALLY. A PROVIDES NEW FUNDING
CONTINGENT UPON APPROPRIATION
IN THE ANNUAL BUDGET FOR STATE
REGIONAL AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
TO PLAN. FOR AND MITIGATE FOR
SEA LEVEL RISE. IN ADDRESSING
SEA LEVEL RISE WE CANNOT FORGET
ABOUT ADDRESSING OUR MOST
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AND
THAT'S WHY THE BILL EXPANDS THE
EXISTING CAL EPA ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE GRANT PROGRAM. TO
ENSURE THAT DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES MOST IMPACTED FROM
SEA LEVEL RISE HAVE A VOICE IN
THE ACTIONS GOVERNMENT TAKES TO
ADDRESS THE CHALLENGES.
SEALABLE RISES A PROBLEM I'VE
SEEN TAKE ROOT IN MY
COMMUNITIES AND THOSE OF MANY
SENATORS ACROSS THE STATE. AND
FINALLY I WANT TO DISABUSE YOU
OF THE NOTION THAT THIS IS A
FIRST WORLD PROBLEM FOR WEALTHY
COASTAL ENCLAVES LIKE
POTENTIALLY MALIBU ARE LAHORE
YEAH. IN REALITY SEALEVEL RISE
WILL DO MOST HARM IN THOSE
COMMUNITIES THAT CAN LEAST
AFFORD TO ADDRESS IT.
COMMUNITIES LIKE IMPERIAL BEACH
AND CHULA VISTA IN MY REGION.
OF PORT WHY NINI AND MARINA IN
OUR CENTRAL COAST AND MIL
PAETUS AND CRESCENT CITY IN THE
NORTHERN PART OF OUR STATE. SB
ONE IS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
CALIFORNIA TO TAKE A
COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH TO SEA
LEVEL RISE. HAPPY TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS MISTER CHAIRMAN I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK I HAVE
ONE MAJOR WITNESS IN SUPPORT.
SERUM IS ADDED WHO IS A COASTAL
COMMISSIONER. AND AN EXPERT ON
SEA LEVEL RISE- OF WE ARE GOING
TO MOVE TO HER AS A WITNESS IN
SUPPORT BUT LET ME ANNOUNCE. NO
PLEASE COME FORWARD. BUT LET ME
ANNOUNCE THAT APPARENTLY THE
PHONE NUMBER WASN'T CORRECT ON
THE SCREEN. SO FAR IF YOU WISH
TO ARE USED TO TELECONFERENCE
BECAUSE WILL BE TAKING
WITNESSES AFTER OF THIS
PRESENTATION THE CORRECT
NUMBER. IS. 844-291-6364. EIGHT
FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE SIX
THREE SIX FOUR. AND THE CODE
IS- SIX FIVE FOUR TWO EIGHT
NINE SEVEN COMMISSIONER WELCOME
TO THE- WHAT WHATEVER WORKS.
THANK YOU A GOOD MORNING
COMMITTEE MEMBERS- MY NAME IS
TERRY I'M INSIDE IT AND I'M
HONORED TO BE HERE TODAY IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB ONE- AS
THE PRESIDENT MENTIONED I'VE
STUDIED THE IMPACT OF SEA LEVEL
RISE ON SHORELINE AREAS. AND
ADVOCATED FOR NEEDED POLICY
REFORMS FOR FIFTEEN YEARS. I
ALSO HAVE THE PRIVILEGE OF
SERVING ON THE CALIFORNIA
COASTAL COMMISSION. BY NOW THE
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE MANY
OF WHOM HAVE AUTHORED KEY
RELATED BILLS ON THE TOPIC ARE
FAMILIAR WITH THE REACH OF SEA
LEVEL RISE. WE KNOW THAT
IMPACTS WILL NOT HAPPEN SLOWLY
AND GRADUALLY AS THE FAR OFF
TIME HORIZONS OF TWENTY FIFTY
AND TWENTY ONE HUNDRED MIGHT
IMPLY. BUT INSIDE IN AND YET
PREDICTED EMERGENCIES
ASSOCIATED WITH EXTREME WEATHER
AND ULTRA HIGH TIDE EVENTS. I
WANT TO SPEAK TODAY ABOUT SEA
LEVEL RISE IMPACTS TO
UNDERSERVED OMMUNITIES AND
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR IN
CALIFORNIA. MANY OF WHOM HAVE
BEEN EXCLUDED FROM COASTAL
AREAS THROUGH STATE SANCTIONED
EMINENT DOMAIN. RELEGATED TO
AREAS VULNERABLE TO FLOODING
THROUGH REDLINING AND FEDERAL
HOUSING PROJECTS AND WHO LIVE
IN LARGELY PARK POOR AREAS. SEA
LEVEL RISE AND STATE ACTIONS OR
IN ACTIONS WILL PERPETUATE
INEQUITIES AND DISPARITIES THAT
ALREADY EXIST IF WE DO NOT MOVE
FORWARD WITH COMPREHENSIVE
REFORMS LIKE THAT IN SB ONE.
LOWER INCOME RESIDENTS AND
THOSE WHO LIVE IN RENTAL UNITS
IN PLACES LIKE TO LIVE IS TO
IMPORT WHY NIIMI ARE MORE
LIKELY TO BE DISPLACED BY
FLOODING AS COMPARED TO
PROPERTY OWNERS BECAUSE THEY
LACKED THE FUNDS TO REBUILD.
AND HAVE LESS CONTROL OVER
THEIR SAFETY. IN PLACES LIKE
MARIN CITY IN ARCADIA RESIDENTS
MAY NOT BE ABLE TO MAKE IT TO
WORK OR CENTRAL SERVICES WHEN
ROADS FLOOD. AND IN AREAS
VULNERABLE TO SEA LEVEL RISE
LIKE SAN PEDRO AND LONG BEACH
SINCE THE WALLS WILL FURTHER
REDUCE ACCESS TO COASTAL
RECREATION AREAS. FOR LOWER
INCOME RESIDENTS LIVING L. AND
MAY ACCESS THE BEACH RARELY AND
BYPASS BIKING OR WALKING. THEY
CANNOT CREWS TO THE NEXT BEACH
WHEN THE REGULAR SPOT IS
FLOODED- RENDERED UNSAFE FOR
USE. SB ONE WILL CREATE A
FRAMEWORK FOR TAKING ACTION
BEFORE IT IS TOO LATE. SB ONE
AN AXE THE FIRST COMPREHENSIVE
SEA LEVEL RISE PROGRAM IN STATE
GOVERNMENT AND ESTABLISHES
FUNDING FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
AND COMMUNITIES. TO PLAN FOR
SEA LEVEL RISE. WOULD MAKE UP
TO ONE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
AVAILABLE FOR ADAPTATION
PREPAREDNESS WORK AND
EXPLICITLY I'D C. LEVEL RISE TO
THE EPA ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
GRANTS PROGRAM. SENDING
CRITICALLY NEEDED FUNDS TO
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
ADDITIONALLY THE TECHNICAL
AMENDMENT- GRACIOUSLY ACCEPTED
BY THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE WILL
ALLOW FUNDS TO BE DISTRIBUTED
THROUGH EXISTING CHANNELS
ALLOWING US TO EXPEDITE THE
DISTRIBUTION OF FUNDS. EVERY
YEAR THAT WE DO NOT TAKE ACTION
TO PREPARE STATE FOR SEA LEVEL
RISE. MEANS A SET OF
OPPORTUNITIES AND CHOICES LOST
AND WE KNOW THAT THESE LOSSES
WILL BE FELT MOST SHARPLY BY
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES. WE
ALSO KNOW THAT ONE DOLLAR SPENT
NOW ON PREPARING NASS WILL SAVE
A SIX DOLLARS ON FUTURE
EMERGENCY RESPONSE. I URGE THIS
COMMITTEE TO PASS THIS
IMPORTANT BILL AND TO LEARN
YOUR VOICES TO SUPPORT THIS
CRITICAL REFORM THIS SESSION.
THE COMMISSION STRONGLY
SUPPORTS THIS BELT AND LOOKS
FORWARD TO CONTINUED WORK WITH
THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE INCLUDING
ON ADDITIONAL CLARIFYING
TECHNICAL MOMENTS. THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH- NOW
WE WILL MOVE TO OUR- WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT AND TO THAT WAS THE
LEAD WITNESS SO ANY FURTHER
ONES ARE. EXCUSE ME ARE JUST A
ME TOO SO JUST YOUR NAME AND
YOUR ORGANIZATION AND SUPPORT.
SO IS THERE A SECOND PHONE.
OKAY WALDRON WE'LL GO FIRST TO-
JENNIFER SAVAGE FROM THE
SURFRIDER FOUNDATION WHO IS
ALSO IN SUPPORT. AND- AND THAT
IS THROUGH THE TELECONFERENCE
ON. A LITTLE BIT MORE. HEY THAT
IT'S POLICY NOW FOR THE
SURPRISE COUNTY. JOINING CHIANG
MEMBER. TODAY IN SUPPORT OF S.
ONE I THANK YOU ALL RIGHT THE
CALIFORNIA PEOPLE AN OCEAN
RIGHT NOW ABOUT THE NEW STUDIES
AND THE STATE- WITH EACH YEAR
WITH EVERYBODY THE MESSAGE IS
THE SAME IF WE CANNOT TAKE WITH
AXE WE WILL THAT THE- HEALTH
LIKE. BUT THEN THAT ECONOMY AND
ALLOW THEM I AM CONFINED IN
WELL TO. IMPACT TERMS AND
MILLIONS OF CAL THAT AND THIS
TO WORK THREE EIGHT AND OTHER
THANK YOU AND THAT I TRIED YOUR
BY. GET PEOPLE COT IN THE
ENVIRONMENT AND VERY IDENTITY
DEPEND ON HAVING HELP BECAUSE
COULD THE ACCEPTABLE TO ALL THE
LONGER WE FORGO INVESTING IN
THE PLANNING GOVERNANCE AND
TECHNICAL ADAPTATIONS NECESSARY
TO RESPOND TO RISING SEAS THE
MORE EXPENSIVE ADAPTATION WILL
BECOME WE NEED SB ONE NOW THE
BILL TACKLES EVEN IT SHOULD ON
THE FRONT NINE YOU CAN. IT THE
CUSTOMER MANAGEMENT IMPROPER
INTEGRATE THE LEVEL RIGHT
BECAUSE REDEVELOPMENT
PERMITTING SB ONE PROVIDES THAT
THE NEEDED WALKED FROM BEACH
AND TRY GOT AND YOU CAN YOU
BASED EXPERT AT AT T. POUND. SB
MIGHT ORGANIZE IT A GOVERNMENT
APPROACH TO THE LEVEL RIGHT BY
A STANDING AND BILL ON THE
TRENDLINE THE ACT SIGN BY SEVEN
THE AGENCIES CONNECTION. SB
WOULD GIVE A SHOT FADING ART
TEACHER BUILDING ON ACCESS WITH
THE REQUIRED TO DEAL LINE
BUSTING OUT THE COMPANY INTO
THE- IN SHORT THE BILL WITH
ENSURE K. NOT JUST AND
DEMOCRATS THE R. COACH IS
PROTECTED LIKE THE TREASURE IT
YET. TO WITH YOUR ORGANIZATION
IN SUPPORT. IS THERE ANYBODY IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY SIMILARLY
WISHES TO GO IN SUPPORT. SEEING
NO ONE THEN MODERATOR WE WILL
MOVE TO THE TELECONFERENCE
CENTER AND THIS IS THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR PEOPLE TO STATE
THEIR NAME AND ORGANIZATION AND
THAT THEY ARE IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR. AND OTTOMAN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF SB ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. AN OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE
YOU WITH YOUR LINE NUMBER AND
PLACE YOU BACK INTO Q. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB ONE PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO NOW. THE MESSAGE CARE
LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE ABOUT TEN
PARTICIPANTS IN Q. OKAY THANK
YOU MR MODERATOR LET'S GO.
THANK YOU MISTER LAMBERT TWENTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS RECALL
MONSTER DID NOT- WITH THE TRUST
FOR PUBLIC LAND AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. BY NUMBER
NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS JUSTIN ARE WITH THE SO
CALLED OUT OF YOUR SHIP GROUP
AND WE SUPPORT THE OBJECT OF
THE BILL OF OUR POSITION ON THE
BILL TO SUPPORT A COMMENDED FOR
THE REASONS OUTLINED OUR LETTER
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. NEXT PERSON MR MARIN.
LIE NUMBER EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOUR
BRAIN AND ALSO WHAT'S YOUR COME
CALL VOLUMES. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. Y. NUMBER THIRTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR KIM DELFINO REPRESENTING
DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE AND THE
CINEMA LAND TRUST AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. LINE
NUMBER THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MR TURN SENATORS LUCAS
FRERICHS ON BEHALF OF THE
NATURE CONSERVANCY IN SUPPORT
OF THE ONE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
Y. NUMBER THIRTY FOUR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI ONE
OF THE MEAT ON A WITHOUT AMONG
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. BLIND NUMBER TWENTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING NATALIE NOT
GOING TO HAVE A COMMUNITY
NATURE CONNECTION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. BY NUMBER
FORTY ONE THE LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
SUSAN JORDAN THE CALIFORNIA
COASTAL PROTECTION THAT WORK IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. BLIND NUMBER
FORTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NUMBER
FORTY TWO MAYBE YOU'RE ON MUTE.
GOOD MORNING CAN YOU HEAR ME.
YES WE CAN HEAR YOU. KENICHIRO
ON BEHALF O NEXT IN CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THE LINE NUMBER
TWENTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NUMBER
TWENTY FOUR MAYBE ARMY. HELLO
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WE CAN HEAR
YOU. OUR BUSINESS CAITLYN
COLUSA POLICY MANAGER
CALIFORNIA KEEPER ALLIANCE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AT
THE TIME OF THIS YEAR WE HAVE
NO ONE ELSE IN Q. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WILL BE BACK TO YOU
IN A SECOND. MODERATOR OF THIS
WOULD BE THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
ANYBODY TO CALL AND LET ME NOTE
THAT- WE HAVE BEEN JOINED
REMOTELY BY SENATOR LEóN AND
SENATOR MON IS TO HAVE A STAFF
MEMBER PRESENT WITH YOU. A
DEAL. AND WHO IS THAT. THAT IS
THE END NAY LOPEZ OKAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WELCOME TO THE
COMMITTEE- THEN THIS WOULD BE
THE OPPORTUNITY FOR WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION TO FILE NUMBER
ONE SB ONE IS THERE ANYBODY
PRESENT IN THIS HEARING ROOM
WISHES TO OPPOSE. IS THERE
ANYBODY IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
THAT WISHES TO OPPOSE.
MODERATOR THIS WOULD BE THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR ANYBODY IN THE
TELECONFERENCE SYSTEM TO OFFER
OPPOSITION IN WHICH AND THIS
WILL BE NAME AN ORGANIZATION IF
THERE IS. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF SB ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. AN OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE
YOU WITH YOUR LINE NUMBER AND
PLACE YOU BACK INTO Q. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB ONE PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO NOW.
MESSAGE HERE WE HAVE ONE
PARTICIPANT IN Q. GREAT-
WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE YOUR
NAME AND YOUR ORGANIZATION IN
OPPOSITION. ONE FORTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SORRY SB TWO CLICK FOR THIS IS
S. B. ONE. PARDON ME PARDON ME
MY ERROR MY ERROR I WONDERED
WHO WAS GOING TO OPPOSED TO PRO
TEMPS BILL. OKAY MODERATORS
THERE ANYBODY ELSE THIS BILL
STATUS NO ONE ELSE MEDICARE
RATES ARE THEN WILL BRING THE
MATTER BEFORE THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS COMMENTS AND ACTIONS.
CENTER EGGMAN THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I JUST WHEN I THINK THE
LIKE TO MOVE THIS BILL AND
THINK THE PRO TEM FOR HER WORK
ON THIS THOSE OF US WHO LIVE IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY DON'T WANT
TO BE ON THE COAST FRONT. AND
SO WE APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE NOT AND
ESPECIALLY LOOKING AFTER THE
SMALL COMMUNITIES WHO OTHERWISE
DON'T HAVE THE RESOURCES TO
PLAN FOR THESE THINGS. OUR WILL
NOT THE MOTION TYSON EGGMAN
FURTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS.
YES MISTER JONES THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. NUMBER TIM I HEAR
YOU AND I HAVE BEEN ON THE SAME
SIDE ON SEVERAL PROJECTS IN SAN
DIEGO THAT HAVE BEEN FOR THAT
WE'VE TRIED TO SUPPORT AND GET.
DONE AND- THE BECAUSE THE
COMMISSION HAS FRUSTRATED A LOT
OF THOSE PARTS NOT ALL OF THEM
BUT SOME OF THEM AND- MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT THIS BILL
CREATES AN ADDITIONAL.
BUREAUCRACY A NEW GOVERNMENT
PRIVACY WITH IN THE COASTAL
COMMISSION- ARE YOU NOT
CONSIDERED I'M CONCERNED AND I
GUESS THE QUESTION ARE YOU NOT
CONCERNED THAT THAT'S GOING TO
FURTHER FRUSTRATE GOOD PROJECTS
WHEN THEY COMMON AND WANT TO
GET PATH A BUILT IN AD OR
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE STATE.
THANK THANK YOU FOR THE FIVE.
TESTING THANK M. THANK YOU
SENATOR FOR THE QUESTION I OF
COURSE LIKE YOU COME OUT A
LOCAL GOVERNMENT WHERE WE SEE
PROJECTS- AND OF COURSE WE'VE
HAD A HISTORY OF- BOTH LOVE A
AND- MAYBE DISSATISFACTION WITH
SOME RULINGS OF THE COASTAL
COMMISSION WHETHER IT'S AN
ENFORCEMENT ISSUE THAT'S BEEN
REPORTED OR WHETHER IT'S A
DEVELOPMENT- I HAVE CERTAINLY
WORKED WITH THE COMMISSION AS A
CITY COUNCIL MEMBER ON PROJECTS
IN IN SAN DIEGO AS YOU HAVE-
I'M NOT I REALLY THINK THAT WE
HAVE THE ABILITY- TO WEIGH IN
AND FRANKLY- THE LOCAL COASTAL
PLANS ALREADY ADDRESS A NUMBER
OF THESE ISSUES THE REAL FOCUS
OF THIS BILL. IS BRING IN OTHER
ENTITIES ON BOARD TO WORK WITH
THE COASTAL COMMISSION AND NOT
JUST THE E. P. A. AS I STATED
IN MY THAT THE ENVIRONMENTAL
EPA AGENCIES BUT TRANSPORTATION
AND ON OTHERS BECAUSE WE'VE GOT
TO BROADEN THE PERSPECTIVE OF
WHAT'S GOING ON THAT'S IMPACT
IN OUR COMMUNITIES AND SO I
THINK WE'RE ALWAYS HEALTHY TO
BE SKEPTICL OF HOW ANY AGENCY
WORKS AND ALL OF US WHETHER WE
SUPPORTED AGENCY OR NOT IN
PHILOSOPHY OR PRINCIPLE HAVE
THE RESPONSIBILITY TO MAKE
SURE. THAT IT'S STAND
ACCOUNTABLE TO THE PEOPLE IN
THE PUBLIC AND THE COASTAL
COMMISSION AS HAD THE HISTORIC
DESIGNATION OF HAVING TO
PROTECT THE COASTLINE WHICH HAS
BEEN NO SMALL FEAT- SO I AM NOT
BUT I BUT I UNDERSTAND WHERE
YOU'RE COMING FROM AND I THINK
IT WILL BE UP AND COMING UP ON
ALL OF US TO HAVE. THAT
COMMUNICATION. THANK YOU.
FATHER KIRK. MISTER WEISS.
BERRYHILL FIRST OF ALL I WANNA
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THIS VERY IMPORTANT MEASURE
FORWARD I STARTED WORKING WITH
THE COASTAL COMMISSION BACK IN
TWO THOUSAND. NINE
APPROXIMATELY ON THIS ISSUE- ON
ON A PLANNING STRATEGY ON HOW
TO COMBAT SEA LEVEL RISE AND
IT'S BEEN. I DON'T QUITE A TIME
OF WORK SO I THINK IT'S
ABSOLUTELY APPROPRIATE. TO
CARRY ON AND CARRY FORWARD WITH
THAT WITH THE MEASURE SUCH AS
THIS AND I JUST WANTED TO ADD
ON. I THINK ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT OFTEN IS NOT CONSIDERED.
IN THIS IN THIS CONVERSATION IS
HOW MUCH. OF WATER THAT
NATURALLY AND USED YOU KNOW
NATURALLY JUST OVER THE YEARS
HAS BEEN SEQUESTERED IN INOWROC
OFFERS AND ARE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HOW ARE ARE. THE
STATE'S RESERVES OF WATER KNOCK
FIRST HAS BEEN GREATLY DEPLETED
WHERE WOULD SOME AREAS WE'VE
SEEN THIRTY FIVE FEET OF. FIRST
AND THAT ALSO IS PART OF THE
EQUATION OF- OF MAKING SURE
THAT I MEAN NOT ONLY DOES THAT
WATER SERVE THE PURPOSES OF
AGRICULTURE AND HUMAN USE BUT
IT ALSO HELPS TO COMBAT CIVIL
SEALEVEL RISE SO WHEREVER WE
CAN- YOU KNOW PUT SOME
RESOURCES INTO RESTORING
ESTABLISHING THAT ALSO. PART OF
THE STRATEGY I THINK THAT
SHOULD BE LOOKED AT THAT. AS
MUCH AS POSSIBLE I'VE AS MANY
OF YOU KNOW I'VE BEEN WORKING
VERY HARD TO RESTORING THE
SALTON SEA AND WE'VE SEEN THAT-
THAT LAKE GO BACK- IN. IT IN A
SEA LEVEL IT ITS OWN LEVEL HAS
BEEN GREATLY DEPLETED AND IF WE
USE THAT ALSO AS A STORAGE
WATER COULD HELP. THE
ENVIRONMENT AND- IN FIFTY
DIFFERENT WAYS TO REVENUE
MANAGER HERE FOR THE LAST TEN
YEARS. BUT THAT ALSO CAN HELP
COMBAT SEA LEVEL RISE NETWORK
WHERE WE LOOK AT ANY- LAKES.
WITH NATURAL LAKES RESERVOIRS.
AQUIFER'S ALL THAT SHOULD BE
INCLUDED AS PART THE STRATEGY-
IN AND ALSO ENCOURAGE THAT IN
OTHER PARTS OF THE WORLD WHERE
WE HAVE HAVE THE DEAD SEA THE-
OVERALL SEE ACROSS THE WORLD WE
SEE. AN ENORMOUS- EMPTYING OF
AQUIFER'S AND WATER BODIES THAT
USED TO ONCE BE VIBRANT BODIES
ARE NOW COMPLETELY DECIMATED
BECAUSE OF HUMAN USE NOT HAS TO
BE PART OF PART OF CALIFORNIANS
ADVOCACY CROSS TO WORLD CHEN
COURAGE THAT THANK YOU. OF
MATTER PRO TERM FOR YOUR
ENORMOUS WORK IN YOUR COUNTRY
YOUR COMMITMENT TO CALIFORNIA'S
COASTLINE THIS IS A WONDERFUL
BILL AND I'D LOVE TO BE ADDED.
AS A CO AUTHOR IF THAT'S
POSSIBLE. THANK YOU. FURTHER
OUR COMMENTS ARE QUESTIONS. IN
I WOULD LIKE TO MAKE SOME
COMMENTS THIS IS THE ONE I HAVE
BILLS OTHER THAN OF COURSE MY
OWN. I FEEL PASSIONATE ABOUT IT
IT IS HARD AS IT IS TO BELIEVE.
IT IS FORTY YEARS AGO THIS
NOVEMBER THAT I WAS FIRST
ELECTED TO CITY OFFICE AND THE
FIRST TWO YEARS OF A COASTAL
TOWN WE HAD A PRESIDENTIALLY
DECLARED DISASTER FOR EROSION.
AND WE HAD A ROUGH TIME AND THE
STATE AT THE TIME REQUIRED. A
MAJOR BEACH AREA IN OUR CITY
AND IT WAS UP TO THE CITY TO
PASS THE DESIGN AND WE DID
SOMETHING THAT ALIENATED A KEY
CONSTITUENCY GROUP IN SANTA
CRUZ OF THE SURFERS BECAUSE WE
WANTED THE ROAD TO BE A HUNDRED
AND FIFTY FEET BACK. WE ENDED
UP DOING IT AND THEN THE FORTY
YEARS SINCE THEN NOW THERE'S
BEEN SIGNIFICANT EROSION. IN
SOME OF THE PLACES EXACTLY. AS
WE PREDICTED AND THEN WHEN I
WAS IN THE LEGISLATURE
200-022-2000 EIGHT THERE WERE
JUST TWO OF US IN ENTIRE SIX
YEARS TO DO THE BILL IN ANY WAY
ON SEA LEVEL RISE AND IT WAS
DESIGNED. OF THE BILL THAT DIED
IN THE SENATE AT THE TIME WAS
DESIGNED TO ASK LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO PLANNED FOR
SEA LEVEL RISE AND HALF THE
CONSTITUENCY GROUP SAID. WE
WON'T SUPPORT IT UNLESS THERE'S
A BASELINE IN THE BILL AND THE
OTHER HALF SAID WHAT SUPPORT IF
THERE IS A BASS LINE AND THE
BILL. SO THAT IS WHAT KILLED
THE BILL AND THEN LO AND
BEHOLD. I END UP BEING
RESOURCES SECRETARY IN CHARGE
OF THE SCIENCE THAT ACTUALLY
PROVIDED THE BASELINE FOR
PLANNING. AND. THE SCIENCE WE
APPROVED. ON THE DAY. THAT AND
FOR THE- OCEAN PROTECT COUNCIL
WHICH NINE TO BILL ON THE DAY
THE SUIT. HIT FROM. JAPAN AND
IT REALLY. DESTROYED TWO
HARBORS IN CALIFORNIA ONE WAS
IN MY DISTRICT AND THIS WAS
WHEN THE TIDE WAS OUT BEFORE
SEALEVEL RISE. AND AS I SAID AT
THE TIME C. AUTHORIZES NOT LIKE
A BATHTUB SLOWLY FILLING UP. IT
IS ACTUALLY THE EXTREME OF THAT
IT IS THE TWO YEAR OLD CANNON
BALLING INTO THE BATH TUB AND
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT HAPPENED
WITH THAT TSUNAMI AND THAT'S
EXACTLY WHAT WE HAVE TO PLAN
FOR. AND WE DID GUIDANCE TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS BASED ON THE
SCIENCE WE FUNDED UPDATES AND
LOCAL COASTAL PLAN SO THAT
PEOPLE COULD START TO PLAN FOR
SEA LEVEL RISE. AND AS SENATOR
EGGMAN SAID. THE BETWEEN A TEN
YEAR FLOOD IN THE DELTA. AND A
HUNDRED YEAR FLOOD IN THE DELTA
IS ONE FOOT OF SEA LEVEL RISE
SO THIS IS NOT JUST A COASTAL
ISSUE. AND SO THE QUESTION IS
AS THERE'S BEEN THIS
PROGRESSION IN THE SCIENCE AND
IN THE PLANNING WHAT ARE THE
NEXT STEPS WHAT THE NEXT STEPS
ARE THIS BILL. IT REALLY SETS
IT UP IT SAYS THAT WE REALLY
HAVE TO COLLABORATE UP AND DOWN
THE COAST BECAUSE IT INVOLVES
EVERY BRANCH OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. IT INVOLVES ALL
THESE DIFFERENT FUNDING SOURCES
AND THIS BILL SETS THE
FRAMEWORK FOR MOVING AHEAD AND
MAKING THOSE DECISIONS AND SO.
I'M GOING TO BE PROUD TO
SUPPORT IT I HOPE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME I COULD BE A
CO AUTHOR. AND I ALSO NOTED FOR
THE RECORD THAT- YOU HAVE
AGREED TO ADD SENATOR STERN AS
A PRINCIPAL CO AUTHOR. YES AND
IF YES MISTER CHAIRMAN OF
COURSE AND ALSO I'M AWARE THAT
US SENATOR HERTZBERG WOULD LIKE
TO BE ADDED SO BETWEEN THIS
COMMITTEE AND APPROACH TO MAKE
SURE ALL OF THE- RELEVANT
MEMBERS WHO WANT TO BE ADDED
WILL BE ADDED. THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER COMMENTS. ARE YOU WANT
TO COMMENT SENATOR STERN OKAY
GO AHEAD. MADAM SORRY COULDN'T
BE FOR THE PRESENTATION OF
ABUNDANCE OF CAUTION I'VE-
DEFERRED TO ARE SENATE SOURCE
OF WISDOM ON ALL THIS AND SHARE
AT THIS AT THIS POINT THANK YOU
FOR THE INSIGHT AND I WAS GOING
TO FORMALLY HAS TO BE SIGNED ON
BUT I JUST APPRECIATE THE
MEASURE- AND WE'RE GONNA BE
HEARING SB FORTY FIVE RIGHT ON
THE HEELS OF THIS MEASURE I
THINK THOSE ARE WELL PAIRED
THOSE THOSE IT GROUP
INITIATIVES THE PRICE TAG IS
ENORMOUS. I SAY IT'S A T. NOT A
B. THOSE ARE SCARY NUMBERS WHEN
YOU LOOK AT ENTIRE TRAIN SYSTEM
FALLING INTO THE WATER ALL THE
REPAIRS IN YOUR AREA HOURS- SO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
HERE AND THINKING BIG BECAUSE
INCREMENTALISM WON'T DEAL WITH
SOMETHING AS BIG AS THE TIDES-
THANKS WELL YOU'LL BACK THANKS
THANK YOU SEEING NO FURTHER
COMMENTS- A TIME YOU. CLOSE
THANK YOU- I WOULD. APPRECIATE
SO MUCH THE COMMENTS AND
CERTAINLY. MISTER CHAIRMAN- IN
THE- THE SEA LEVEL RISE HAS
RISEN ABOUT EIGHT TO NINE
INCHES SINCE EIGHTEEN EIGHTY. A
THIRD OF THAT IN THE LAST TWO
AND A HALF DECADES THAT YOU
MADE REFERENCE TO. AND I WOULD
JUST I WOULD JUST ADD I
APPRECIATE ALL OF THE
INCREDIBLE SUPPORT THAT I HEARD
ON THE PHONE. TELECONFERENCE
FROM A LOT OF OUR FRIENDS IN
BUT I JUST ALSO WANT TO CLOSE
WITH THIS. IN MY OWN COMMUNITY
IN SAN DIEGO THE IMPACT TO OUR
MILITARY INSTALLATIONS WHICH
ARE SIGNIFICANT WE ARE-
OBVIOUSLY THE LARGEST MILITARY
INSTALLATION- IN THE WORLD- IN
CALIFORNIA AND IN SAN DIEGO
COUNTY. OUR WASTE WATER
TREATMENT PLANT OUR CONVENTION
CENTER THE AIRPORT THE RAIL
LINE THAT HAS BEEN MENTIONED.
AND MY COMMUNITY IS SIMILAR TO
MANY COMMUNITIES UP AND DOWN
THE ELEVEN HUNDRED MILES OF
COASTLINE. SO THINK ABOUT ALL
OF THOSE TYPES OF FACILITIES.
THAT WOULD BE- IN TERMS OF. OUR
ECONOMIC IMPACT I WANT TO MAKE
A COMMENT ABOUT OUR ECONOMIC
IMPACT. THE OCEANS ECONOMY
INCLUDING TOURISM RECREATION
AND MARINE TRANSPORTATION IS
VALUED AT FORTY FOUR BILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR TO OUR ECONOMY.
SO THERE ARE MANY REASONS TO DO
THIS AND TO BE PREPARED AND I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
ATTENTION I KNOW YOU'VE GOT A
LOT ON THE PLATE TODAY.
CERTAINLY WANT TO ADD ALL OF
THE CO AUTHORS BETWEEN NOW IN
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE-
THAT WOULD LIKE TO BE ADDED. I
WOULD URGE AN AYE VOTE THANK
YOU THANK YOU AND JUST BEFORE
WE MOVE TO A VOTE WE'VE ALSO
HAD A REQUEST FROM SENATOR
LAMAR. TO BE ADDED AS CO
AUTHOR. I SAW ESTAMOS. FACTORED
PLEASED THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED BUT FIRST
AMEND AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY- WELL THIS IS ON SB
ONE- LAYERED BY WEIRD HI JONES
UNFORTUNATELY NO. PHONES NO
ALLEN ALLEN HI EGGMAN. EGGMAN
HI GROWTH. GROVE NO HERTZBERG
VOICE SO HUESO ON A LEóN. HI
LIMóN I STERN ALL RIGHT STERN
HI IT HAS A EIGHT THANK YOU ARE
THAT HAS ENOUGH VOTES TO GET
ALCOHOL THE ROLE OPEN UNTIL-
YES TELL ALL THE MEMBERS ARE
HERE THANK YOU VERY MUCH MATTER
PRO TEM JUST BEFORE WE MOVED
MISTER PORTANTINO AND WANT TO
GET IN PLACE WE ALSO HAVE TO
ADOPT THE COMMITTEE RULES TODAY
SO IS THERE A MOTION TO ADOPT
THE COMMITTEE ROLES. MOTION
MOVED BY HUESO ANY DISCUSSION.
THEN WHAT THE SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE DIRECTION OF THE
COMMITTEE RULES LAYERED HI
THERE AND I'D JONES JONES ON A
ALLEN ALLEN HI EGGMAN EGGMAN HI
GROWTH PROVED HI HERTZBERG
HUESO. WHO IS SO ON A LONG. HI
THERE ICE. STIR HI DENNIS
ENOUGH FOR TO GET OUT BUT WILL
HOLD THE ROLE OPEN UNTIL
EVERYBODY IS HERE WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE TO FILE ITEM TO. S. B.
FOR FORTY FIVE WITH SENATOR
PORTANTINO- UMBANDA WELCOME TO
THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS TODAY I'M
PRESENTING SP FORTY FIVE- BUT I
WANT TO GIVE A SPECIAL SHOUT
OUT TO US SENATORS ALLEN AND
STERN WHO LED THIS CHARGE LAST
YEAR AND WHO ARE- JOINT AUTHORS
WITH A NUMBER OF OTHER SENATORS
SO THANK YOU. FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE- FROM
THE OREGON BORDER TO OUR
SOUTHERN BORDER WITH MEXICO
CALIFORNIA'S ALREADY
EXPERIENCING THE IMPACTS OF
CLIMATE CHANGE WE JUST HEARD.
THE PRO TEM DETAIL SOME OF
THOSE IMPACTS FOR US WE NOW
HAVE AN ETERNAL FIRE SEASON WE
USED TO TALK ABOUT. FIRE SEASON
BEING A CERTAIN CONFINED TO A
CERTAIN NUMBER OF MONTHS AND
COURSE NOW IT'S- TWELVE MONTHS
LONG. WATER SHORTAGES AND
INCREASED DROUGHT MORE SEVERE
FLOODING AND OTHER DISASTROUS
WEATHER EVENTS AND AN
ESCALATING NUMBER OF EXTREME
HEAT DAYS. THAT PUT OUR
RESIDENTS AND OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE AT RISK. THESE
EVENTS ARE ALREADY COSTING
CALIFORNIA BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
EVERY YEAR THAT'S BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS EVERY YEAR IMPACT DUE
TO CLIMATE CHANGE. WE MUST TAKE
BOLD ACTION NOW TO FIND
SOLUTIONS TO REDUCE THESE
EFFECTS TO ADAPT OUR CHANGE TO
OUR CHANGING CLIMATE. DEVELOP
CLIMATE RESILIENCY AND MITIGATE
CLIMATE DISASTERS THAT WILL
SURELY BE AHEAD OF US IF WE SIT
ON OUR HANDS AND DO NOTHING.
TODAY I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
FOR SB FORTY FIVE THE WILDFIRE
SAFE DRINKING WATER DROUGHT
PREPARATION AND FLOOD
PROTECTION BOND ACTIVE TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. WHICH WILL PUT A
BALLOT MEASURE BEFORE
CALIFORNIA VOTERS TO FIND THE
SOLUTIONS WE DESPERATELY NEED
TO PROTECT CALIFORNIA FROM
FURTHER RAVAGES OF CLIMATE
CHANGE. WILDFIRES ARE A COMMON
OCCURRENCE IN CALIFORNIA BUT
NOT WHAT NOT LIKE WHAT WE'VE
BEGUN TO EXPERIENCE PROLONGED
DROUGHT AND INCREASED
TEMPERATURES. HAVE KILLED OFF
MILLIONS OF TREES IN THE LAST
DECADE ALONE LEAVING YOU SWATCH
OF HIGHLY COMBUSTIBLE TENDER.
RECORD SETTING FIRES IN TWENTY
TWENTY. TOPPED RECORD SETTING
FIRES IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
WHICH TOP RECORD SETTING FIRES
JUST A FEW YEARS PRIOR. MORE
THAN FOUR POINT TWO MILLION
ACRES BURNED IN TWENTY TWENTY
AND THEN THE LAST FOUR YEARS
CALIFORNIA FIRES HAVE KILLED A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY FOUR PEOPLE
DESTROYED FORTY FOUR THOUSAND
STRUCTURES. AND POLLUTED AIR
FOR MILLIONS. WORSE STILL. THE
WILDFIRE CLIMATE FEEDBACK LOOP
IS DEVASTATING CLIMATE CHANGE
TRIGGERS MORE MASSIVE AND MORE
FREQUENT WILDFIRES ANY EXTRA
FIRES DON'T MILLIONS MORE TONS
OF GREENHOUSE GAS INTO THE
ATMOSPHERE. AND WIPE OUT CARBON
SEQUESTERED FARCE DWARFING THE
PROGRESS CALIFORNIA'S MADE
REDUCING EMISSIONS FROM
VEHICLES AND THE ENERGY SECTOR.
SEVERE DROUGHT COUPLED WITH
SOME OF THE HOTTEST YEARS EVER
RECORDED MEANS WITH
PRECIPITATION DOES WHEN
PRECIPITATION DOES FALL IT
COMES DOWN AS RAIN AND RUSHES
TO THE OCEANS INSTEAD OF
LINGERING AT SNOW PACK IN OUR
MAJESTIC SIERRA'S. THIS ISN'T
JUST A PROBLEM FOR SKIERS
HISTORICALLY MUCH OF STATES
FRESH DRINKING MUCH OF THE
STATE'S FRESH DRINKING WATER
COMES FROM THE SLOW TRICKLE OF
MELTING SNOW. OUR STATE PLANS
ASSUME THIS BEAUTIFUL LIFE
FORCE WILL MAKE ITS WAY BACK
INTO OUR ACTUAL FILTERS FOR
YEAR ROUND FRESH WATER THAT
HOLDS US OVER INTO DRY YEARS.
BUT IF THAT SNOW ISN'T THERE
YEAR AFTER YEAR WE HAVE NO WAY
TO ADEQUATELY WOULD CHARGE OUR
GROUNDWATER BASINS. SEALEVEL
RISE AGAIN WE JUST HEARD OF-
ABOUT THAT SEA LEVEL RISE IN
RESULT IN COASTAL FLOODING IS
ALREADY RUNNING CALIFORNIA'S
COASTLINE AND IS EXPECTED TO
THREATEN NEARLY HALF A MILLION
RESIDENTS. A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
BILLION DOLLARS IN PROPERTY AND
THIRTY FIVE. HUNDRED MILES OF
ROADS WITHIN THE NEXT EIGHTY
YEARS WITHOUT ADAPTIVE MEASURES
IN PLACE. IN ADDITION. TO MORE
DROUGHT AND INCREASING SEA
LEVELS CLIMATE CHANGE ALSO
BRINGS US. MORE CONCENTRATED
RAINSTORMS FROM ATMOSPHERIC
RIVERS INSTEAD OF STEADIER
LIGHTER RAIN VASTLY INCREASING
THE FLOOD RISK FOR CALIFORNIA'S
GROWING RURAL AND URBAN
COMMUNITIES THE STATE CURRENTLY
HAS SOME FIVE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY FIVE BILLION DOLLARS
WORTH OF BUILDINGS SUSCEPTIBLE
TO FLOODING. AND 20% OF THE
STATE'S POPULATION ALREADY
LIVES IN FLOOD PRONE AREAS AND
THESE FIGURES EXCLUDE ESSENTIAL
PUBLIC INFRASTRUCTURE LIKE
ROADS AIRPORTS AND SEAPORTS.
THE STATE IS INVESTING LESS
THAN HALF OF WHAT IT IS NEEDED
TO PROPERLY ADDRESS THE GROWING
FLOOD RISK FROM THESE MORE
INTENSE WEATHER EVENTS THE COST
TO REPAIR EXISTING LEVY IN
DEFENSE OF FLOOD CONTROL
INFRASTRUCTURE ALONE. IS
EXPECTED TO BE THIRTY FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS PROPER
INVESTMENT IN FLOOD
INFRASTRUCTURE CAN PROTECT
BUILDINGS AND AGRICULTURAL
WHILE SIMULTANEOUSLY PRESERVING
ECOSYSTEMS AND WILDLIFE HABITAT.
WE NEED PROJECTS INCLUDING THE
NORTH YUBA RIVER FOREST
RESTORATION PROJECT THAT IS
REMOVING DEBRIS AND INVASIVE
SPECIES AND RESTORING MEADOWS
TO REDUCE THE RISK OF
DEVASTATING FIRES WHILE
IMPROVING FLOOD CONTROL AND
WATERSHED HEALTH. SB FORTY FIVE
PROPOSES A GENERAL OBLIGATION
BOND TO INJECT MUCH NEEDED
REVENUE TO ADDRESS THESE
IMPACTS THE MEASURE PROPOSES
FUNDS TO REDUCE FIRE RISK AND
RESTORE AREAS THAT ARE ALREADY
DAMAGED RESTORED PROTECT
IMPACTED WETLANDS WATERSHEDS IN
WATERWAYS. REDUCE IMPACTS ON
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS
POPULATIONS AND IMPROVE THE
RESILIENCY OF OUR WATER
SUPPLIES AND AGRICULTURAL LANDS
ON THE PHONE ON THE PHONE TODAY
I HAVE A JOE EDMISTON WITH THAT
MOUNTAINS RECREATION AND
CONSERVATION AUTHORITY. AND.
PETE MINELLA
CALIFORNIA-DRIVERS-PAY-UNDERFUNDED-STATE-PATROL-PENSION
MISSED AND HE IS ON THE PHONE
LINE OUR BELIEF. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN- AND
MEMBERSHIP- FIRST OF ALL. I
WANT TO EXPLAIN- OF THE ROLE
THAT WE PLAY HERE IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA BY MOUNTAINS
RECREATION CONSERVATION
AUTHORITY UNFORTUNATELY WE CALL
WITH MRCA. AND WE REPRESENT-
BROWN SEVENTY FIVE A LITTLE BIT
MORE THAN SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND
ACRES ARE SPLIT BETWEEN EIGHT
DIFFERENT PUBLIC AGENCIES IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. AND ALL OF
THOSE AND THAT SPREAD FROM THE
SHEER UPON A RANGE- DOWN TO THE-
BOUNDARIES UPON OUR CHILDREN
BOUNDARY L. A. COUNTY A HARD UP
AGAINST ORANGE COUNTY SOCIAL IS
A HUGE AREA. AND WE HAVE ONE
THING IN COMMON THE DETERMINE
AND BARRIERS THE- STREAM DANGER
OF FIRE FIVE YEARS AGO YOU
COULD SAY WELL YOU STILL HAVE
TO MAKE A LITTLE BIT OF THE
CASE WORK BUT AFTER WOLSELEY.
AND THEN THE DANGERS THAT WE
ARE FACED- THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE
HAVE BEEN KILLED. ISN'T A
PERSON I THINK IN CALIFORNIA
WHO WOULD DENY. THE URGENT
NECESSITY OF DOING SOMETHING
THE QUESTIONNAIRES YEARS S. B.
FORTY FIVE THE RIGHT WAY OF
GOING. AND UNEQUIVOCALLY
RICHARD SHERMAN IT HERE'S- YOUR
HAS A BALANCE BETWEEN WHAT
LOCAL AGENCIES CAN DO ARM I
KNOW THAT WE ARE. PARTICIPATED
WITH YOU WERE. DR GERM HIM AND
PREVIEW AND CURRENT. AND WITH
FIRST YOU KNOW REPORT. RUSSIAN
OR ALLEN CHARGES. WE HAVE
WORKING IN YOUR DISTRICTS I
THINK YOU KNOW THE WORK CAN BE
DONE THIS IS AN EXAMPLE OF HOW
LOCAL AGENCIES AND REGIONAL
AGENCIES AND CAN WORK WITH THE
STATE. AND MISS- BILL IS
PERFECTLY BALANCED I THINK
BETWEEN THE STATE AND LOCAL AND
REGIONAL VENDORS IN CARRYING
OUT THIS WORK. SHOW YOUR SERVE
REAL PLEASURE BECOMING TOO WERE
UP. BEFORE YOU AND TO THINK
AGAIN CHARTER PORTANTINO FOR
HIS LEADERSHIP. IN THIS VITAL
MEASURE. THANK YOU FOR MUCH AND
THEN- I DON'T HAVE THE NAME IS
A SENATE REPORT TEEN WHAT'S THE
NAME OF YOUR SECOND WITNESS WHO
WAS ALSO ON THE PHONE. EIGHT AM
AN HOUR. ON THE HOUR SO
MODERATOR- WE CAN GET. A
MINIMUM OF. THEY ARE NOT ON THE
PHONE LINE. THEY'RE NOT ON THE
LINE. OKAY THEN- MALL HARLEM TO
SPEAK IF THEY DO SHOW UP- THIS
WOULD BE THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
PEOPLE TO SPEAK. IN SUPPORT IT
WOULD BE NAME AN ORGANIZATION
IN SUPPORT OF GO TO THIS ROOM
FIRST WELCOME. IF YOU SEE
MISTER CHAIR- MARC SMITH ON
BEHALF OF A VARIETY OF CLIENTS.
THE CALIFORNIA COASTAL
CONSERVATION ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA. BRESLIN WATER
DISTRICT NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
GUIDES AND SPORTSMEN PATTERSON
YOUR GEISHA DISTRICT THE
NATIONAL MARINE MANUFACTURERS
ASSOCIATION AND ORIGINS COUNCIL
ALL IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL BUT
ALSO REQUESTING AMENDMENTS AS
WE KNOW IT'S A WORK IN PROGRESS
THANK YOU CAN THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ANYONE ELSE IN THIS ROOM
AND SUPPORT. THEN WE'LL GO TO
ROOM TWENTY FORTY ANYBODY IN
SUPPORT THERE. SAYING NO ONE
WILL GO TO THE TELECONFERENCE
CENTER MODERATOR- POINT SUPPORT
NAME AN ORGANIZATION. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
TO SUPPORT OF SB FORTY FIVE
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. IT
WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER PLACE YOU BACK INTO Q.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB FORTY FIVE
COULD PRESS ONE BUTTON ZERO NOW.
IN ONE MOMENT MISTER CHAIR. WE
HAVE ABOUT THIRTY TWO
PARTICIPANTS IN Q. OKAY LET ME
REMIND EVERYONE THAT IT IS NAME
AND ORGANIZATION AND SUPPORT.
OKAY MODERATOR LET'S ROLL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR LINE
NUMBER THIRTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN BIRDS ADAM
UNITS ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WATER
AGENCIES WE HAVE A SUPPORT IT
COMMENDED POSITION ON SB FORTY
FIVE YOU CAN COURAGE
ADDITIONAL. FUNDING FOR WATER
RESILIENCE THANK YOU THANK YOU
YOU ARE AT THE OUTER LIMITS OF-
THE NAME AND ORGANIZATION AND
POSITION MODERATOR NEXT PERSON.
THE MESSAGE AT LINEBACKER TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING CARE NUMBER MOSTLY
ROMERO AT THE CALIFORNIA
CONSERVATION VOTERS. SUPPORTED
IN CONTACT SB FORTY FIVE AND
APPRECIATE THE OFFICE EFFORT
WITH THE POOREST. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. MODERATOR NEXT
SPEAKER. LINE NUMBER FORTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN GO
AHEAD. RIGHT GOOD MORNING JUST
ALL DEPARTMENT BUDGETS AND WE
HAVE TO CALIBRATE OUR ALLIANCE
IN SUPPORT OF FORTY FIVE THANKS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MODERATOR
NEXT SPEAKER. BY NUMBER FORTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING JEANNIE
MINOR ON BEHALF OF SANTA
MARGARITA WATER DISTRICT AS
WELL AS TURLOCK IRRIGATION
DISTRICT AND EMPTY APPRECIATE
THAT THE MEASURE AND ARE
SUPPORTED THAT MEANT IT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MODERATOR NEXT
BECAUSE- LINE NUMBER THIRTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU CANTONA STONE
ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SOLAR AND STORAGE
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MODERATOR. BY
NUMBER FIFTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER
KAREN MEMBERS WILL BE ASKED TO
LEAVE SHOP ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF SANTA MONICA IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU MODERATOR.
BY NUMBER FIFTY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOUR
TURN MEMBERS THEIR NAME ON
BEHALF OF THE THREE MUNICIPAL
WATER DISTRICT WITH ACCORDING
TO THAT POSITION THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MODERATOR.
LINE NUMBER TWENTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS REBEL MASTRODONATO WITH
THE TRUST FOR PUBLIC LAND WE
ARE IN SUPPORT WE FOUND THAT
MINTON DECEMBER BUT WE ARE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MODERATOR. WINEMA FIFTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MATALIN COOPER FROM NIELSEN
MARKS THE MURDER ON BEHALF OF
MARIN COUNTY IMPORT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MODERATOR. LINE
NUMBER SIXTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING JUSTIN HIGHER FROM THE
SILICON VALLEY LEADERSHIP GROUP
IN OUR POSITION ON THIS BILL TO
SUPPORT A COMMENDED FOR THE
REASONS OUTLINED IN A LETTER
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. MODERATOR THE LINE
NUMBER FIFTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN VERSACE'S
BEST A LAWSUIT ON BEHALF OF
WATER REUSE CALIFORNIA MORE
SUPPORT IF AMENDED TO INCLUDE
MORE WATER FOR WATER RECYCLING
AS OUTLINED IN OUR LETTER THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MODERATOR. NUMBER FIFTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU GOOD MORNING
MISTER TURNER COMMITTEE MEMBERS
THIS IS KILEY WALKING CALLING
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA STATE
PIPE TRADES COUNCIL THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
ELECTRICAL WORKERS AND THE
WESTERN STATE COUNCIL OF SHEET
METAL WORKERS CALLING TO
EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT FOR SB
FORTY FIVE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MODERATOR. BUT I
NUMBER FORTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE CAN
DELFINO REPRESENTING THE CANAL
LAND TRUST IN SUPPORT AND
DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE AND
CALIFORNIA NEEDED. VARIETY
REPORTED AMENDED THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MODERATOR.
NUMBER TWENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. VERY MUCH
ALIGNED AND MUTE NUMBER. TWENTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY NUMBER
SIXTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS JIM LINDBERG ON BEHALF
OF A FRIEND COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION THAT CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. FORTY FIVE
THANK YOU THANK YOU MODERATOR.
MY NUMBER SIXTY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING NATALIE RHONDA HOW THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
CONSERVATION CORPS AS WELL AS
THE CALIFORNIA HABITAT
CONSERVATION PLANNING COALITION
SUPPORT AMENDED THANK YOU THANK
YOU MODERATOR. LINE NUMBER
FIFTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
THE COULD SHARE MEMBERS MANDY
LEE ON BEHALF OF THE CLEAN
POWER ALLIANCE- WHILE OUR BOARD
IS WORKING TO ADOPTED FORMAL
POSITION WE JUST WANTED TO
EXPRESS. THAT WE ARE SUPPORTIVE
OF THE BILL MOVING FORWARD
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MODERATOR.
NUMBER THIRTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE OF
THE MEAT ON THE ONE ON ONE
CALIFORNIA SUPPORT WITH
AMENDMENT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MODERATOR. LINE NUMBER TWENTY
FIVE THE LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NO BY PROVIDING WITH
CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL UTILITIES
ASSOCIATION WE HAVE THE SUPPORT
AND DEMAND POSITION THANKS SO
MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MODERATE. LINE NUMBER THIRTY
ONE THE LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU KAREN MEMBERS
ASHLEY WALKER WITH NOT THE MEN
ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY OF
MONTEREY WITH THAT THE COURT
AND AMEND POSITION THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MODERATOR.
BY NUMBER THIRTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS KATHY HELLO ON BHALF
OF METROPOLITAN WATER DISTRICT
OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND THE
STATE WATER CONTRACTORS WE HAVE
A SUPPORT AND A MAN FOR THE
REASONS OUTLINED IN OUR
RESPECTIVE WATERS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MODERATOR.
BY NUMBER FIFTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MISTER TURNER MEMBERS
DO CLEANING WITH CONSERVATION
STRATEGY GROUP ON BEHALF OF
MOUNTAINS RECREATION AND
CONSERVATION AUTHORITY THE
WHILE LOOP CONSERVANCY AND THE
OPEN SPACE TRUST AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU MODERATOR.
WE ALSO CLIMB NUMBER THIRTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
MATTHEW BAKER WITH THE PLANNING
AND CONSERVATION LEAGUE AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MODERATOR. LINE NUMBER SIXTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING- MATTEO
CROW ON BEHALF OF PLASTER
COUNTY WATER AGENCY AND THE
NORMAL WATER IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU MODERATOR. LINE
NUMBER FIFTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. CHRISTOFFEL
BALLOT REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA
YOUNG DEMOCRATS IN SUPPORT
THANKS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MODERATOR. BY NUMBER TWENTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
KASHA NEWMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF LAND
TRUSTS. OKAY CHICA LANTERN.
CALIFORNIA FOREST COUNCIL AND
THE MOJAVE DESERT LAND TRUST
ALL IN SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MODERATOR. WELL I
NUMBER FIFTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MAY BE
ALIGNED AND MUTE BLIND FIFTY
NINE. WATER GETTING SUPPORT
THANK YOU. YOU WATER LINE IN
FIFTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
YOU COULD ARE BECAUSE ARE
BEHALF OF THE CENTER DAY CALIF
WITH SUPPORT AND AMENDED
PETITION THANK YOU. YOU VERY
MUCH MODERATOR. LINE NUMBER
THIRTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS JANIE GO ON OF THE
DEFENSE FUND TROUT TROUT
UNLIMITED SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MODERATOR.
ONE SIXTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR THIS IS MARK
SPENCER MAKER ON BEHALF OF THE
BIG SHOULD LAND TRUST THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
RESOURCE CONSERVATION DISTRICT.
SANTA CLARA VALLEY OPEN SPACE
ABILITY ALL IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MODERATOR. LINE NUMBER FIFTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN SENATOR STANTON MOLINA
ON BEHALF OF THE SANTA CLARITA
VALLEY WATER AGENCY MANAGING
THE RIVER VALLEY MUNICIPAL
WATER DISTRICT IN SUPPORT OF SB
FORTY FIVE. ALSO ON BEHALF OF
YOUR CLIENT MAKES A WATER
DISTRICT WE HAVE TAKEN THE
SUPPORT OF THE MEDICATION THAT
IS CONSISTENT WITH AQUA'S
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MODERATOR.
PLAN NUMBER FORTY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MISTER TURNER
MEMBERS CAPTAIN FREEMAN WITH
THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES AND
SUPPORT ABOUT THREE FORTY FIVE
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MODERATOR. NUMBER SIXTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
SENATORS BECAUSE FERRIC SOME
HALF THE NATURE CONSERVANCY
STRONG SUPPORT ABOUT THE FORTY
FIVE THANK YOU COUNCIL MEMBER
MODERATOR. CHECK FLIGHT NUMBER
SIXTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
HOW ARE NOT THINKING CON ON
BEHALF OF THE YUBA WATER AGENCY
WITH A SUPPORT AND AMEND
POSITION CONSISTENT WITH THE
STATEWIDE DAM SAFETY COALITION
LETTER THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MODERATOR. LINE NUMBER
FIFTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
MARK AND WE WOULD CALIFORNIA
WATERFOWL ASSOCIATION WE HAVE A
SUPPORT IF AMENDED POSITION-
THAT WAS THAT IN OUR WATER
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MODERATOR. WELL I NUMBER
SEVENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS PETE
MINELLA AND I AM THE GENERAL
VICE PRESIDENT OF CAL FIRE
LOCAL TWENTY EIGHTY ONE. THIS
MORNING I SPEAK ON BEHALF OF
PRESIDENT EDWARDS AND THE SEVEN
THOUSAND MEN AND WOMEN OF CAL
FIRE. THE FIRE THE PAST FOUR
YEARS ARE A MATTER OF RECORD.
CALIFORNIA SPENT MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS WHILE AND DURING TENS
OF BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
LOSSES DUE TO DISASTERS. THAT
WOULD HAVE BEEN UNIMAGINABLE A
DECADE AGO. SB FORTY FIVE
REPRESENTS THE SMARTEST PLAN
YET. FIVE POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS IN GENERAL OBLIGATION
BONDS. THAT ARE INHERENT WITH
THIS LEGISLATION REPRESENT A
COHESIVE COLLABORATIVE AND
COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH TO
DEALING WITH MODERN DISASTERS.
IT MAKES NO SENSE TO ONLY
CONCENTRATE ON SUPPRESSION
CHECK OUT THE MAKES NO SENSE TO
GET A MARK FUNDING JUST FOR
PREVENTION. WE WILL BE
MONITORING FIVE TRILLION MUCH
NEEDED TO TRY SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION MUCH NEEDED DOLLARS TO
ENHANCE CAL FIRE CAPACITY FOR
FIRE PREVENTION. PEOPLE
MANAGEMENT EMPIRE RESPONSE.
CALIFORNIA WILL BE IN A BETTER
PLACE FOR THE INEVITABLE
BECAUSE OF THIS BOND. MONEY IS
DESIGNED TO BE CAREFULLY SPENT
ON UP ON THOSE PROJECTS THAT
MEET OUR FAMILIES AND
BUSINESSES TO CATER. CAL FIRE
LOCAL TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY ONE
PROUD TO BE ASSOCIATED WITH
SENATOR PORTANTINO'S
LEGISLATION. WE CANNOT PREDICT
THE FUTURE WE CAN SAY WITH
CERTAINTY THAT INVESTORS WILL
BE PART OF THAT FUTURE. BONTA
FINANCE PROJECT WILDLAND FIRE
PREVENTION STATE DRINKING WATER
CROWD PREPARATION AND FLOOD
PROTECTION IS INVESTMENT IN THE
FUTURE WE TALK ABOUT PROTECTING
THE NEXT GENERATION. AB FORTY
FIVE ACCOMPLISHES THAT GOAL
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK
YOU AND LET ME JUST SAY THAT-
HE WAS TEED UP TO BE- A MAIN
WITNESS AT THE BEGINNING SO FOR
THE THIRTY FIVE PEOPLE THAT
JUST DID TO ME TOO YOU WERE NOT
ROBBED. SO FAR. MODERATOR LET'S
GO BACK TO ANYONE THAT'S LEFT
FOR ME TO IN SUPPORT. OF SB
FORTY FIVE. THANK YOU THE
CAROLINA SEVENTY. LINER OPEN
PLEASE CALL. GOOD MORNING
NATALIE MAC BEHALF OF. NAY
CANNOT MAN OF THE SENATE COUNTY
AND IT BUT WE CANNOT OPEN THE
DIRECTOR IN THE CALIFORNIA
PARKS. ALL IN OF THE MEN. ADDS
OUTLINE IN THE RESPECTIVE
LETTERS THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MODERATOR. IT TIME IF
THE CHAIR WE HAVE NO ELSE IN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- AFTER
THIRTY SEVEN I'M NOT GONNA HAVE
YOU ASKED FOR MORE. SO LET'S
MOVE TO OF. WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. IS THERE ANYBODY
THAT IS IN THIS HEARING ROOM
THAT WISHES TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION AND WE'RE TO THE
POINT THAT WITH NO LEAD
WITNESSES IT WOULD JUST BE A
NAME AN ORGANIZATION. ANYBODY
IN THIS ROOM THAT'S IN
OPPOSITION. ANYONE THAT'S IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. MODERATOR
THIS WOULD BE THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR ANYBODY THROUGH THE
TELECONFERENCE HONORED TO
REGISTER OPPOSITION TO SB.
FORTY FIVE. THANK YOU MEDICARE
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB FORTY FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. AN OPERATOR WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH THEIR LINE
NUMBER IN PLACE YOU BACK INTO
Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB FORTY
FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE. ZERO NOW.
SO WHAT'S PROVED TO- WITH. THE
MESSAGE HERE WE HAVE NO ONE TO
ONE UP. THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE
WE GOING TO BRING THE MATTER
BACK BEFORE THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. SENATE
REGNANT. THANK YOU AND GOOD
MORNING CENTER PORTANTINO IT'S
NICE TO SEE YOU AND- TAKING ON
THIS BIG HUGE ISSUE- MY
QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS WILL BE.
ASSOCIATED AND AROUND THE AREA
REPRESENT THE DELTA- SO IN IN
PAST BONDS LANGUAGE HAS BEEN
INCLUDED THAT STATES THAT NO
BOND MONEY CAN BE USED FOR THE
CONSTRUCTION- OF THE CONVEYANCE
PROJECT- AS THE WATER AGENCIES
WHO WILL PROFIT FROM THAT
SHOULD BE THE ONES PAYING FOR
THAT- IN THE PAST WE'VE HAD
THAT LANGUAGE IN EVERY CHAPTER
I DON'T KNOW THAT'S APPROPRIATE
FOR THIS ONE BUT I'D CERTAINLY
CURIOUS. IF YOU WOULD BE
WILLING AND I WOULD HOPE SO TO
INCLUDE LANGUAGE LIKE THAT THAT
NO BOND FINANCING CAN BE USED
FOR THE CONSTRUCTION OF THE
CONVENIENCE AND THEN SECONDLY I
WONDERING ABOUT OUR LEVEES IN
ORDER WE CAN WE CAN KEEP HIM
OUT SEALEVEL RISE AND
MAINTAINING BUT WE KNOW THAT WE
HAVE A VAST LIBBY SYSTEM THAT
NEEDS TO BE MAINTAINED SO IF
THERE WOULD BE- FUNDING AND
THEREFORE OUR LEVEE SYSTEM AND
BEING ABLE TO GET IT UP TO
EXISTING FEDERAL STANDARDS
WHICH MOST OF OUR LEVEES DO NOT
MEET EXISTING FEDERAL STANDARDS
RIGHT NOW. AND MANY OF OUR
COMMUNITIES ARE IN THE POSITION
TO BE ABLE TO FULLY FUND THAT
THEMSELVES SO OF COURSE AROUND.
LANGUAGE THAT- AND THEN AND
I'LL ALSO ADD THAT THE LEVEES
ARE MORE THAN THE YELLOW BYPASS
PROJECT. BUT DOWN INTO THE
DELTA AND THEN BY FINAL
QUESTION AROUND THAT IS AROUND-
INVASIVE SPECIES- AND IF
THEY'LL BE MONEY FOR THAT WE
HAVE A HUGE PROBLEM. WITH THAT
NUTRIA BURTON BURROWING INTO
OUR LEVEES AND- AT. WEAKENING
THEM. AND THEN AT THE SAME TIME
WITH WITH A CLICK CLIMATE
CHANGE WE AS AS YOU KNOW HAVE
EXPERIENCE. REALLY HIGH HEAT-
BIN THEN BECAUSE- BECAUSE OF
THE NATURE OF THE DELTA. WE
HAVE AN ABUNDANCE OF- WATER
HYACINTH BACKLOGS WE HAVE AN
ABUNDANCE OF ALGAE THAT REALLY
TAKES BROUGH IN THE SUMMERTIME.
MAKING IT THAT WATER TOXIC- FOR
KIDS FOR ANIMALS FOR EVERYBODY
WHO TOUCHES IT. SO MY THREE
YEAR IT'S ALL AROUND THE DELTA.
I HAD NO COULD NO MONEY FOR
CONVENIENCE- DELIVERY SYSTEM
AND THEN THE IDEA OF- INVASIVE.
SPECIES BOTH FLORA AND FAUNA.
GREAT- SO AS FAR AS THE ONE
GOESI MET WITH THE FIVE
COUNTY- DELEGATION THEY MENTION
THE SAME CONCEPT I ASKED THEM
TO SUPPLY THE LANGUAGE AND THEN
I WOULD SEND IT TO THE
COMMITTEE- TO MAKE. IT THE
DELTA NEUTRAL- I DIDN'T SAY A
100% BECAUSE I HAD TO RUN IT
THROUGH THE THROUGH THE
COMMITTEE I'M WAITING FOR THE
COMMITTEE TO GET BACK TO ME. IF
IT IS SOMETHING STANDARD THAT'S
AND EVERYBODY I DON'T SEE AN
ISSUE WITH IT BUT I. JUST WANT
TO SEE THE LANGUAGE TO MAKE
SURE IT'S CONSISTENT WITH
WHAT'S BEEN AND PASS BONDS AND
HAVE THE STAKEHOLDERS COME
TOGETHER TO DISCUSS IT SO. IN
PRINCIPLE I'D SAY YES BUT IN
PRACTICE I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE
THAT I GOT ALL MY EYES AND- DOT
ACROSS ON MY TEASE BEFORE I SAY
ONE HUNDRED PERCENT. ON THAT
BUT YES IT'S GOING THROUGH THE
RIGHT SYSTEM. ON THE LEVEES
OBVIOUSLY WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THIS BOND IS REGIONAL AS
IT AS POSSIBLE WE HAVE A
CERTAIN FINANCIAL CONSTRAINTS
THAT WE HAVE TO STAY WITH- SO.
AGAIN WITHIN THE FINANCIAL
CONSTRAINTS THAT WE HAVE I
CERTAINLY AM OPEN TO INCLUDING
BRINGING UP THE LEVEES AS MUCH
AS POSSIBLE YOU KNOW I LIVE IN
WEST SAC AND I. WALK ON THE
LEVEES OR RIDE MY BIKE ON THE
LEVEES EVERY DAY AND SO- I
SHARE YOUR CONCERN ABOUT THE
LEVY SO. AS LONG AS IT FITS
INTO OUR FIVE FINANCIAL
CONSTRUCT I DON'T SEE ANY ISSUE.
MISTER ALAN DO YOU SEE ANY
ISSUE WITH THAT. I THE LEVEES
I'M IT'S MORE OF A FINANCE
ISSUE THAN. BEEN A FOR. ISSUE
SO WITH. RUN THAT THROUGH A-
THROUGH THE SYSTEM AND ON THE
INVASIVE SPECIES. AGAIN I. BEEN
CONCEPT AGREED THAT WE NEEDED
TO ADDRESS THAT AND IF YOU HAVE
SPECIFIC LANGUAGE YOU WANT TO
ADD. YEAH BRING IT TO US AND
I'LL CERTAINLY BRING IT BACK TO
THAT TODAY STAKEHOLDERS AND
WOULD LOVE YOUR INPUT. FURTHER
ON ANYTHING ELSE THAT COMES UP
IN TASTIC AT THIS IS THIS IS
IMPORTANT WORK AND UPGRADE IT
AND THEN LIKE I SAY IT CONCEPT
I SUPPORT ALL OF IT AND AS WE
GET THE DETAILS WORKED OUT AND-
THEN WE'LL SEE AS AS WE GO
FORWARD. ABSOLUTELY. THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR THE COMMENTS.
TURN AROUND I MEAN I HAVE TO GO
BACK AND FIND IT BUT I KNOW
THERE IS SOME MONEY IN THE BEEN
THERE FOR LEVEES ALL ALL ON. IT
WHETHER IT'S UP TO THE FEDERAL
STANDARD OR NOT THAT'S THE
PIECE I DON'T KNOW. MONEY IN
THERE BUT HOW MUCH. AND HOW
MUCH WE CAN GET. THAT'S THAT
THAT'S THE QUESTION. WELL I.
GET THE COMMENT. THE IF. ARMY
CORPS OF. APPROVES OF PRO. IN
ITS JUST QUESTION OF WHETHER.
OF FUNDS ARE IN THIS MEASURE
THAT ARE ALLOWED TO MATCH IT.
AND SO. THE ARMY CORPS OF
ENGINEERS WILL DETERMINE
WHETHER IT MEETS THE STANDARD
AND- I WOULD ALSO JUST. AS A
NEUTRAL. ON THIS ONE JUST
OFFERED THAT A LEVY BOND
MEASURE WAS DONE PROP ONE
EIGHTY IN TWO THOUSAND SIX. AND
THE AMOUNT OF IT WAS BEFORE I
RECALL ABOUT A THIRD OR HALF
FOR SOME AMOUNT OF MONEY OF
THIS TOTAL BOND SO I DON'T
THINK THERE SHOULD BE AN
EXPECTATION THAT IF THERE'S ANY
LEVY MONEY IN HERE. IT'S GOING
TO BE SIGNIFICANT TOWARD WHAT
THE NEED THIS. SENATOR ON I
WANT THANKS CALIFORNIA I MOVED
FROM OF THE BILL. WE HAVE A
MOTION IS THERE ARE THERE
FURTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS. THIS
SING NINE THAN SENATOR
PORTANTINO YOU CAN CLOSE THIS
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I VOTED I
GOT A TEXT WHAT WE WERE
DISCUSSING THAT THE LANGUAGE
THERE'S BEEN AND EVERY BOND FOR
TWENTY YEARS SO I'M NOT
ANTICIPATING AN ISSUE WITH IT I
JUST HAVEN'T SEEN THE FINAL
LANGUAGE SELF RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. BRITAIN WANTS US THE
SECRETARY TO CALL THE ROLL.
OKAY SB FORTY FIVE THE MOTION
IS TO PASS THE FIRST BE RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE LAYERED
BY LETTER TO. JONES JONES NO
ALLEN. ALLEN ALL RIGHT EGGMAN.
EGGMAN HI GROVE. GROVE NO
HERTZBERG HUESO. LOAN HI THE
MOON I STERN. WE WILL HOLD THAT
ARE OPEN UNTIL WE CAN AT THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. THANK YOU. APAR
IS MR STERN GOING TO WALK
THROUGH THAT DOOR AND PRESENT
HIS BILL. YOU'RE POINTING AT
SOMETHING. PROFORM RIGHT.
WITHIN THE NEXT NON COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THAT THIS PRESIDENT.
UNLESS THIS IS SENATOR STERN.
NO THAT'S DEFINITELY NOT
SENATOR STRUCK. BUT THAT IS
SOMEBODY THAT'S IN FRONT OF
SENATOR CALVET EURO IN LINE
AND- SO- THEN WE WILL MOVE- TO
HIRE FILE ITEM SIX SB EIGHTY
FOUR SENATOR PER TANTO OIL AND
GAS WELLS CENTER ROTANA WELCOME
TO THE COMMITTEE. AT GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRED MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE. I'D LIKE TO
START A BY A STEP IN THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS REFLECT ON
PAGES SIX AND SEVEN OF THE NOW
SIS. AND TO THINK THE COMMITTEE
STAFF AND THE CHAIR FOR WORKING
WITH ME ON THIS BILL.
COLLEAGUES IN JANUARY OF LAST
YEAR THE KERN COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS HAD A HEARING. ON
THE OIL AND GAS INDUSTRY
REGULATIONS. SUPERVISOR
SCRIVNER SAID SOMETHING DURING
THIS HEARING THAT LED ME TO
DRAFTING THIS BILL HE SAID.
CALDERON IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
OLDER WELLS AND I WANT TO SEE
MORE MONEY SENT TO US FROM
ORPHANED WELLS AND ABANDONMENT
PROGRAM. I UNDERSTAND A LOT OF
MONEY IS BEING SPENT ON COASTAL
COUNTIES ON THAT PROGRAM AND
YET AGAIN. BUT THE MONEY COMES
FROM THE KERN COUNTY
BUSINESSES. SO WE NEED MORE OF
THAT TO BE HERE. SB EIGHTY FOUR
IS NOT ABOUT OIL OR AND OR
ENVIRONMENTALISTS THIS BILL IS
ABOUT EQUITY FOR PEOPLE WHO
HAVE LONG BEEN LEFT BEHIND. IT
IS ABOUT REAL ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE. THIS IS A REPUBLICAN
ISSUE ANY DEMOCRATS ISSUE
BECAUSE IMPROVED AIR QUALITY IS
GOOD FOR EVERYONE'S HEALTH.
THIS BILL IS ABOUT THE PEOPLE
LIVING IN THE NATION'S MOST
POLLUTED REGION AND MAKING SURE
THAT THEY HAVE EQUAL ACCESS TO
REMEDIATION FUNDS AS THEY DO IN
COASTAL COMMUNITIES. WITH THAT
SAID SB EIGHTY FOUR REQUIRES
ENHANCED REPORTING RELATIVE TO
HAZARDOUS LONG TERM IDOL AN
ORPHAN WELLS. TODAY THERE ARE
POSSIBLY A HUNDRED AND SEVEN
THOUSAND ACTIVE OR IDLE OIL AND
GAS WELLS IN CALIFORNIA. THE
MAJORITY OF THE STATE'S OIL AND
GAS DEVELOPMENT AND PRODUCTION
OF CURVES AND THE SOUTHERN
CENTRAL VALLEY. IN THE
COMMUNITIES OF THIS REGION A
NUMBER OF LONG TERM IDLE AND
ABANDONED OIL WELLS THAT ARE
NOT PROPERLY DID COME
DECOMMISSIONED CONTRIBUTE TO
LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH AND
ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES. THE STATE
HAS ENACTED LEGISLATION TO
ADDRESS AND PROVIDE FUNDING FOR
THE REMEDIATION OF LONG TERM
IDOL AN ORPHAN WELLS ALONG THE
COAST AND DOES REQUIRE
OPERATORS TO PAY FEAR SUBMIT A
PLAN TO ADDRESS THEIR IDOLS.
THERE IS A LACK OF INFORMATION
ON WHERE THE MAJORITY OF THESE
WELLS ARE LOCATED IN THE STATE.
SB EIGHTY FOUR PROVIDES MUCH
NEEDED TRANSPARENCY
TRANSPARENCY AROUND ORPHAN WELL
REMEDIATION AND GIVES US A
BETTER PICTURE OF WHAT EQUITY
AND WATER REMEDIATION CAN AND
SHOULD LOOK LIKE. THANK YOU AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH OR WE
HAVE NO LISTED- LEAD WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT SO WE WILL GO TO.
BORROW WITNESSES. FOR A NAY MAN
OR- IN SUPPORT IS THERE ANYBODY
IN THIS COMMITTEE WORLD THAT
WISHES TO OFFER SUPPORT. THIRTY
ONE IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
SAYING NO ONE AT THE PODIUM
THEIR MODERATOR OF THIS WOULD
BE THE OPPORTUNITY TO HEAR NAME
AN ORGANIZATION FROM ANYONE IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. EIGHTY FOUR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB EIGHTY
FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AND
THE OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOU
WITH YOUR LINE NUMBER AND PLACE
YOU BACK INTO Q. ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
SB. EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE PRESS
ONE. ZERO NOW. ONE MOMENT THE
CHAIR. AT THIS MOMENT WE HAVE
NO ONE ELSE AND USER THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WILL MOVE TO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION AND WE
HAD. WHEN THEY SEE THE
AMENDMENTS AND PRINT THEY WILL
REMOVE THE OPPOSITION SO LET ME
OFFER THEM THE CHANCE ANYWAY
THROUGH THE CO HOST PHONE LINE
TO OFFER ANY TESTIMONY THE
FIRST ONE IS MARIN COLUMN FROM
THE SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA. HI
GOOD MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE- LAUREN COLUMN
WITH THE ERROR CODE CALIFORNIA
ARE CURRENTLY WE DO HAVE IN A
POSITION ON THE BILL. WE
APPRECIATE OF THE AUTHOR HAS
ADVISED ME THAT THE M. IN THE
MOMENT. BECAUSE THEY BELIEVE
THAT ASK THE CURRENTLY WRITING
YOU CAN SEARCH- THE- AND WE A
BIG CHUNK OF THE LOCK COULD
WITH THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS EACH
YEAR. BECAUSE ARE PROPERTY. FOR
PLUGGING IN A- THE COMMISSION.
AND REMEDIATION THANK. YOU
AGAIN WOULD LIKE TO THANK DR
AUTHOR FOR LOOK JORDAN.
EXPECTING THE COMEDIAN MAN.
PROPERTY MANAGEMENT I CAN THEM
BACK TO OUR MEMBERS.
RECOGNITION OPPOSITION. HOWEVER
I JUST LIKE TO KNOW NOW DID NOT
LIKE WILL THIS. EVEN WITH THE
IN WITH SALE TO DROP THE CALL
MARK HAS VERY. MY ABILITY TO
STATE PROJECT THE FIFTY FIVE
HUNDRED WAS ESTIMATED TO BE.
FIFTY FIVE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS AND THE
ESTIMATE TO MEDIATE ALL SEVENTY
THOUSAND IDLE AND ECONOMICALLY
MARGINAL WELL. GOOD COPIES MUCH
AT FIVE POINT EIGHT BILLION
DOLLARS TO REMEDIATE IN
CALIFORNIA IS EXPECTED TO SEE
MORE DESERTED AND IDYLLWILD
FUTURE OF THE STATE OIL
INDUSTRY CONTINUES TO DECLINE
AND MORE COMPANIES ABOUT A
BUSINESS. ATTENTION TO FURTHER
WELL DUE TO THE COMMISSION
REQUIREMENTS WILL CALL THE
STATE TAXPAYERS. WE NEED TO
FOCUS ON WHAT WE CAN DO TO FIX
THE PROBLEM ONLY FILL OUT THE
BILL DON'T FALL SHORT OF DOING
THAT. ONE LAST THING I'D LIKE
TO KNOW IS THAT OUR MEMBERS
WERE EXTREMELY UNHAPPY LAST
YEAR WE REMOVED OUR OPPOSITION
CONTENDER. AND TWELVE BUT THE
BILL WOULD LATER BE AMENDED TO
INCLUDE THE VERY LANGUAGE THAT
THE CONCERNED ABOUT. THE SAME
LANGUAGE THAT THAT ISSUED
TODAY- AND THEN WE HAD TO
RESTART OUR OPPOSITION WE DON'T
WANT A REPEAT OF WHAT HAPPENED
LAST YEAR AND WE WOULD LIKE TO
HEAR THAT SENATOR WILL REMAIN
COMMITTED TO HER DECISION TO
ACCEPT THE CALL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARE WE JOURNAL ARE.
THREE MINUTES TOTAL. THE WITH
THE- AND I THE FOR ONE FOR LEAD
OPPOSITION USED ALL THAT TIME.
BUT LET ME GIVE THE- FOR BRIAN
WICKED CENTER FOR BY ONE. TO
MAKE A BRIEF COMMENT IF HE IS
ON THE CO HOST FROM. I AM- GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE IT IS REALLY GOOD
TO SEE YOU ALL RIGHT NOW WITH
THE CENTER FOR BIOLOGICAL
DIVERSITY I'LL BE EXTREMELY
BRIEF SINCE LAUREN HAS ALREADY
COVERED IT AND WE'RE OUT OF
TIME- OF THE CENTER FOR
BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY ALSO. WILL
BE PLEASED TO REVIEW THIS BILL
AND REMOVE OUR OPPOSITION WITH
THE PROPOSED CHANGES THANK YOU
TO SENATOR CADDO AND TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR WORKING ON THOSE.
THE ONLY THING TO ADD TO ITFINE ALREADY SAID IS THAT AT
THIS POINT WE SEE CAL JIM
GETTING THROUGH ONLY THIRTY CAN
WELL SPREE YEAR OF CLOSING.
IDLE WELLS AND- ANDREW. THEM SO
GIVEN MANY WELLS WE CURRENTLY
HAVE IDLE WELLS IN THE STATE
THAT CAN TAKE US. OVER A
THOUSAND YEARS TO GET THROUGH
ALL THE WELLS IN CALIFORNIA BUT
NEED CLOSURE. AND REMEDIATION.
WE VERY MUCH WOULD LIKE TO WORK
WITH THE SENATOR WITH THE
LEGISLATURE. TO ADDRESS WHAT
KEPT AT TAHOE CAL JOHN.
XCELERATED THOSE EFFORTS AND-
AND TO SEE HOW WE CAN ACTUALLY
FIX THAT PROBLEM. IF IT IS
WITHIN THE AGENCY SO I'LL STOP
IT THERE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME TODAY THANK YOU.
OUR MODERATOR THIS WOULD BE THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR ANYBODY TO DO A
NAME. AN ORGANIZATION IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU MEDICARE
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION SB
EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. AN OPERATOR WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER AND PLACE YOU BACK INTO
THE QUEUE. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB. EIGHTY FOUR WOULD PRESS ONE
ZERO NOW. THE MESSAGE THE PLAN
WE HAVE TWO PEOPLE IN Q. OKAY
NAME AN ORGANIZATION IN
OPPOSITION. NUMBER THIRTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING CARE NUMBER
OF NORTH AMERICA CALIFORNIA
CONSERVATION VOTERS ARE
CONDITION PRIOR TO MAKING A
MOMENT AT THE MOMENT HELLO THE
MUSCLE MANDATE AND- WITH THE
BALLING FINANCIAL AMENDMENT ONE
CHECK THAT THE CARPET IS. A
PROVISION ABOUT THE SUPERVISORS
PEOPLE- AND WE'RE AND WE'VE-
BACK THAT WOULD BE. THAT WOULD
THE PROVISION IN WHICH ARE
EQUIPMENT POSITION THE FACT
THANK YOU MUCH YEAH. THANK
OTHER SPEAKER NOT THIS. ONE OF
MY THIRTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO. I WANT MEET
AMONG WITH AUDIBLE CAL. WE WILL
BE REMOVING OPPOSITE ONE THE
AMENDMENTS CALL IN TO COURT
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MODERATOR DISSECTING TO AND
QUEUE. YES IT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- THE AND NOW IT'S BACK IN
OF THE FOR OR COMMENTS. YES SIR
GROVE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR-
AND TO THE AUTHOR MISTER SADDAM
I SUPPORTED THIS BILL LAST YEAR
AND LET THE SENATE FLOOR AND
THEN YOU- TOOK SOME AMENDMENTS.
ON THE ASSEMBLY SITE THAT-
WOULD HAVE REMOVED MY SUPPORT
BECAUSE- THE BILL LAST YEAR THE
WAY IT WAS WOULD NOT ADDRESS
THE ISSUE WITH I'D WELLS WHICH
WE NEED TO ADDRESS. ESPECIALLY
IN KERN COUNTY WE OF THIS WE
PRODUCE 75% OF THE STATE'S OIL
IN. OIL AND GAS INDUSTRIES IN
KERN COUNTY WHICH YOU'RE A PART
OF- THE REPRESENTATION IN IT
THE ITEM WILL ISSUE DOES NEED
TO BE ADDRESSED BUT YOUR BILL
JUST EXACERBATES THE PROBLEM. A
ONE OF THE PROBLEMS ARE THE
MAJOR PROBLEM WE HAVE IS WE
NEED PERMITS AND TO BE ISSUED
FROM CAL JAM TO BE ABLE TO-
ADDRESS SEASIDE WELLS AND A
FAIR PRICE NEEDS TO BE PAID. I
KNOW THAT- A LOT OF OPERATORS
THAT GO INTO- FIX SEASIDE WELLS
AND APPROPRIATE- PROPERLY
DISPOSE OF THEM OR TO SEAL THE
UP. AND TO GET A PERMIT OR A
CHANGE PERMIT FROM CAL JIM IS
ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE AND IT TAKES
TIME. AND WHEN YOU HAVE A QUICK
MEANT AND EVERYTHING ON THE JOB
AND WHEN YOU GET INTO THE
GROUND AND YOU FIND A PIECE OF
METAL AND METAL WASN'T PART OF
THE PERMIT TO REMOVE YOU HAVE
TO CALL CAL JAM. GET
AUTHORIZATION THAT TAKES WEEKS
PEOPLE ARE STUCK ON THE JOB
THEY'RE PAYING PEOPLE TO NOT DO
A JOB SO THE PROBLEM IS CAL
JIM. AS FAR AS THE PERMIT
PROCESS GOES IN ORDER TO HELP-
WELLS BE CLOSED OUT- I DID WAS
TO BE CLOSED OUT PROPERLY. THE
OTHER PART THAT WE HAVE AS A-
IN QUE JIM. THAT AND- YOU KNOW
THERE ARE OPERATORS OUT THERE
THAT ARE WILLING TO TAKE ON
CERTAIN LEASES LIKE I'VE AN
OPERATOR NOW IN KERN COUNTY
THAT'S WAITED. ALMOST TWO
YEARS. TO TAKE ON A LEASE THAT
WAS ABANDONED BY A PRIOR
OPERATOR AND TO OPERATE THAT
LEASE- WELL AND WITHIN THE
BOUNDARIES IN THE
ENVIRONMENTAL. OF POLICIES
THAT- THE- CALIFORNIA. REQUIRES
A IN THIS OPERATOR IS GOING TO
EXTENT TO. OBTAIN PERMITS FROM
CAL JAM WHICH TWO YEARS IS
STILL NOT PROVIDED TO THIS
OPERATOR- I'M ENGAGED IN THAT
PROCESS NOW BECAUSE NOW THE-
THE LAWFUL LEGAL OPERATOR THAT
WOULD DO A GREAT JOB OPERATING
THESE WELLS WERE ABANDONED. IS
THROWING HIS HANDS UP AND GONE
LOOK I GET WITH THIS FOR TWO
YEARS I'M DONE- SO IT IS VERY
FRUSTRATING SO THE SOLUTION IS
TO FIX WHAT'S GOING ON AT CAL
JAM. AND NOT TO PUT FORTH A
BILL- AND I'M JUST BEING HONEST
WITH YOU NOT TO PUT FORTH A
BILL THAT- IN THE BEGINNING.
DID DO SOMETHING TO HELP IT
REALLY DID THE BILL YOU FOR
SUBMITTED IN THE LEGISLATURE ON
THE SENATE SIDE THAT WE VOTED
FOR AND SUPPORTED. LAST YEAR
DID DO SOMETHING TO HELP AT
LEAST IT MOVE THE BALL A LITTLE
BIT FORWARD TO WHERE RESOURCES
WILL GO BACK TO KERN COUNTY.
AND OPERATORS COULD BE PAID
EVEN IF THEY DIDN'T GET THE
PART THE PERMITS. FROM CAL JIM
OR THEY WERE DELAYED IN THE
PROCESS. IT'S JUST A BACKLOG IN
CALCIUM. AND SO. AND THEN YOU
TOOK AMENDMENTS ON THE ASSEMBLY
SIDE UNDER PRESSURE I'M SURE
WHICH REMOVED- INDUSTRY
OPPOSITION AND I VOTED NO WHEN
IT CAME BACK TO THE SENATE
FLOOR. I DIDN'T COME BACK TO
SIMPLER BUT I WOULD HAVE VOTED
NO. AND BECAUSE IT DID IT JUST
FURTHER EXACERBATED THE
PROCESS. AND SO ON. I HAVE TO
DEPRIVE TO NOT SUPPORT THE BILL
TODAY BECAUSE I THINK IT JUST
FURTHER EXACERBATES A PROCESS.
IT DOESN'T IT DOESN'T FIX THE
SITUATION THAT WE HAVE. AND IF
THE GOAL WHICH I THINK IS A
GOOD GOAL IS TO SHUT DOWN THESE
IDLE WELLS OR HAVE GOOD
OPERATORS TAKE OVER THESE IDLE
WELLS. AND PRODUCE THE ENERGY
SAFELY NUMBER EMILY FRIENDLY.
IN CALIFORNIA INSTEAD OF IN
VENEZUELA OR OTHER FOREIGN
COUNTRIES THAT HAVE DISMAL
HUMAN RIGHTS. AND POLICIES AND
HORRIBLE ENVIRONMENTAL
POLICIES. AND KEEP JOBS HERE
KEEP DOMESTIC ENERGY HERE. AS
IF THAT'S THE GOAL THAT WE HAVE
TO ADDRESS THE ISSUES AND CAL
JIM WITH THE PERMIT PROCESS
AND- ON IDOL WELL PROCESSES
WELL. BECAUSE THERE ARE GOOD
OPERATORS OUT THERE THAT WANT
TO TAKE OVER IDLE WELLS. AND
FIX THINGS- BUT THE BACKLOG IS
IN IN CAL JIM. AND- SO. I'M
SORRY BUT IT REPRESENTING KERN
COUNTY AND- RESHARE. BILL YOU
KNOW WE'RE TRYING TO BRING
MONEY BACK TO THE DISTRICT BUT-
YOU CAN BRING ALL THE MONEY IN
THE WORLD BACK TO THE DISTRICT
BUT THEY CAN'T GET A PERMIT TO
CLOSE DOWN AYE WELL IT'S NOT
GONNA HAPPEN. THE CIVIC CENTER
WOULD YOU LIKE TO DRESS AND
YOU'RE CLOSE. DISH YES
ABSOLUTELY OKAY CENTER OUR PART
I'M IN A DIFFERENT I'M JUST.
WELL UNLESS I'M
MISUNDERSTANDING SOMETHING THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE TAKEN- I
AGREE THAT IS- IN THE ORIGINAL
VERSION WHERE THEY TALKED ABOUT
BACK COLLEGE AND HAVING TO TAKE
REASONABLE EFFORTS TO FIND
THEIR LEVEL PARTY. AND DID IT
WOULD HAVE EXACERBATED THE
PROBLEM BUT YOU KNOW BUT BUT
NOW NOW- BECAUSE THAT WOULD
HAVE ALLOWED THEM TO LITIGATING
KEEP RIGHT ON THE PAN AM WELLS
OPEN LONGER AND- BUT NOW NOW
THE BILL JUST REQUIRES
REPORTING ABOUT HOW THE PROCESS
IS GOING SO I. IT WHICH OF
COURSE IT HELPS TO. KEEP THINGS
MOVING SO I GUESS I'M- I'M NOT
SEEING HOW THIS EXACERBATES THE
PROBLEM THAT YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT CENTER AT A GIVEN THE
CHANGES THAT HAVE BEEN MADE TO
THE BILL TODAY. ASKING ME THAT
QUESTION. FARMS BOB. BASHARA
FUTURE OKAY SO I'M IN A I'M
HAVE A GREAT RELATIONSHIP WITH
INDUSTRY AND TO COMMUNICATING
WITH INDUSTRY THEY SEE IT ON
THE GROUND I MEAN I DON'T
OPERATE WELL YOU DON'T OPERATE
WELL BUT INDUSTRY SEES THIS IS
AN EXACERBATIONS OF THE PROBLEM
THE PROBLEM TO ADDRESS SEASIDE
WELLS AND SOLVE CALIFORNIA'S
PROBLEM ABOUT THE IDOLS ARE
HERE IS TO GET PERMITS OUT OF-
TO PROVIDE RESOURCES FOR PEOPLE
TO COME IN AND SHUT THESE WELLS
DOWN. AND IT'S A VERY UNIQUE
SKILL THERE AREN'T VERY MANY
PEOPLE IN THE STATE HAT DO
THIS TO PROVIDE RESOURCES THAT
SHOULD BE ALLOCATED TO DOCTOR
TO SHUT THESE WELLS DOWN WHICH
WOULD ALLOCATED IN THE PAST AND
ALSO A LITTLE DARKER DARKER
PROVIDE PERMITS SO THE PROBLEM
IS THAT WE'VE AND I WORKED WITH
CAL JIM NOT DOCTOR SKIS ME CAL
JIM. OVER THE PAST FEW YEARS
WHERE OPERATORS HAVE COME INTO
SHUT DOWN THESE WELLS AND DO IT
BUT WHEN THEY GET INTO THE
GROUND THEY FIND THESE WELLS
THAT HAVE BEEN IN THE GROUND
FOR A HUNDRED YEARS THAT HAVE
METAL AND JUST ALL THE STUFF
THAT THEY USED TO PLUG THE
WELLS BEFORE WE HAD
ENVIRONMENTAL LAWS THAT DID DID
AN REGULATED THIS IN SO. THEY
CAN'T GET THE- PROCESS THROUGH.
CAL JAM IN ORDER TO GET THE
PERMIT TO ADJUST TO. TO REMOVE
THE METAL TO- YOU KNOW TO
ADJUST FOR THE WHAT THEY FIND
IN THE GROUND. AND SO ON I'M
RELYING ON INDUSTRY H<c.cyan> TRUST</c>
IN THERE THAT SAYS IT'S GOING
TO EXACERBATE THE PROBLEM. WHAT
ABOUT THIS EXACERBATES THE
PROBLEM. WHAT A PARTICULAR
ABOUT THIS BILL ADDRESSES THE
PROBLEM. SO THAT THE PREVIOUS
BILL IS WHAT IS SHE WAS WHEN
SHE TOOK THE AMENDMENTS ON THE
ASSEMBLY SIDE. AND WHAT ABOUT
THIS ONE PROCESS OF THIS BILL
IN THE PROCESS DOESN'T. BUT
WITH THE AMENDMENTS THAT WE
ANTICIPATE THIS WILL TAKE ON
THE ASSEMBLY SIDE. WHEN SHE
GIVES A WORD THAT SHE'S NOT
WE'RE STILL GONNA HAVE A
PROBLEM. BUT WHAT I'M TELLING
YOU IS IT OKAY EXACERBATIONS
FOR YOUR WARNING HER ABOUT. SO
YOU HAVE A PROBLEM OF THE BILL
NOW BUT YOU'RE WORRIED ABOUT
WHAT IT MIGHT TURN INTO LATER.
YES WORD THE SAME ISSUE THAT WE
FACE THE OPPOSITION BASED. IS
IT SHE TOOK AMENDMENTS THE
AUTHOR TOOK AMENDMENTS. AFTER
WE VOTED ON THE BILL- AND THEN
SHE RETOOK AMENDMENTS BACK ON
THE SET TO TAKE IT BACK TO THE
BILL WHICH WE HAD WHICH- EGGS.
YOU KNOW FRUSTRATED THE
OPPOSITION- WHICH WAS CLEARLY
STATED IN THE TESTIMONY. AND SO
THIS BILL AS IS. EVEN WITH THE
REPORTING PROCESS DOES NOT. FIX
THE PROBLEM. THE IT DOES FIX
THE BILL THE- WHAT WE NEED TO
SORT OF MAKE POINTS AND BE ABLE
TO MOVE ON THE SO. IS THERE ANY
FURTHER ON THIS THE GOAL IS TO
CLOSE DOWN IDLE WELLS IN THIS
BILL DOES NOT DO THAT AND IT
DOESN'T HELP MAKE IT HAPPEN
OKAY. I FACE OKAY THAT I THAT I
MISSED DROWNED IF YOU JUST HAVE
A COMMENT YOU'D LIKE TO MAKE
THAT'S NOT A QUESTION OF
SOMETIMES I JUST RESPECTFULLY
DISAGREE FIVE EXACTLY DISAGREE.
OKAY ANY OTHER QUESTION OR
COMMENTS MR TRUMP THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN I. ENJOYED THE
SPECTATOR. POSITION OF THE
DEBATE OVER THERE SO YOU ARE
ONLY SPEAKING FOR YOURSELF THAT
YEAH I'M- YES I AM ONLY
SPEAKING FOR MYSELF ACTUALLY
HOW WE DO IT HERE YEAH-
ACTUALLY THAT'S THE ONLY THAT'S
NOT UNHEALTHY THING TO HAVE
THAT YOU KNOW THAT KIND OF
CONVERSATION OUT LOUD SO THAT.
THE PUBLIC UNDERSTANDS THAT WE
ACTUALLY DO- DEBATE THESE
THINGS AND GET INTO A WOMAN AND
REALLY PAID PARTICULAR
ATTENTION TO THE DETAILS AND
STUFF SO. ACERTAR I WAS.
PREPARED TO VOTE FOR YOUR BILL
TODAY BUT- BASED ON THE-
CONVERSATION OF AMENDMENTS
COMING AND- YOU KNOW NOT I
DON'T HAVE AN ANALYSIS ON THOSE
POTENTIAL AMENDMENTS- MY
RECOMMENDATION TO THE CHAIRS
THAT WE HOLD THE BILL IN
COMMITTEE- LET THOSE AMENDMENTS
GET. PUT INTO THE BILL AND
LET'S BRING IT BACK IN A WEEK
OR TWO- OTHER THAN THAT- I'M
GONNA HAVE TO LAY OFF TODAY SO.
K. FOR THE COMMENTS. JUST
BEFORE WE CLOSE LET. R. FOUR I
APOLOGIZE SENATOR LEE MON.
TWENTY RECOGNIZE YOU. THANK YOU
CHAIR I APPRECIATE THE
CONVERSATION THAT IS TAKING
PLACE I DO SOME WORK AROUND
THIS PIECE AND I THINK I WANT.
THAT RECOGNIZE THAT AT. THE
CENTER FROM THE CENTRAL VALLEY
MENTIONED THE PROBLEM IS NOT
JUST ON THE COAST ALTHOUGH I
REPRESENT THE COAST AND WE HAVE
A NUMBER OF THE BAND DIDN'T
WORK AND WELLS I'M IN THE
DISTRICTI REPRESENT TO AYE
ABSOLUTELY IT IS NOT LIMITED OR
RESTRICTED TO A PROBLEM ON THE
COAST SO I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT. I WAS PREPARED TO ALSO
LAY OFF FOR DIFFERENT REASONS
BUT WITH THE AUTHORS THAT SHE
WILL BE. AMENDMENT I WILL BE
SUPPORTING IT I THINK WE'RE ALL
LOOKING AT AMENDMENTS LIKE. BUT
I THINK. EVEN THOUGH I MYSELF
SOMETIMES AT IN OPPOSITE
PERSPECTIVE AS SOME OF MY
COLLEAGUES TO BUY TALK TO EIGHT
DO YOU WANT TO RECOGNIZE THAT I
THINK I'VE HEARD BOTH SIDES OF
THIS PERSPECTIVE I'M SURE THERE
ONE THAT THE IMPACT OF IDLE AND
ABANDONED AND ORPHANED WELLS I
HEALTH AND ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT
AND TO THAT WE AGREE THAT THERE
IS- A BACKLOG. ADD TO ASK HOW
CHEN AND SO I WANT TO RECOGNIZE
THOSE TWO POINTS I THINK WE
OFTEN FIND OURSELVES AT
OPPOSITE SIDES OF THIS ISSUE-
AND THE PERSPECTIVE I DON'T
THINK THAT THIS IS A PARTISAN
ISSUE I THINK IT'S A
PERSPECTIVE- IT'S A LIVED
EXPERIENCE FOR ME- OF THE
DISTRICT I REPRESENT AS I KNOW
IT IS FOR COLLEAGUES I'M IN AND
THE CENTRAL VALLEY BUT I AM
GOING TO BE SUPPORTING THE
BILL- AND I HOPE THAT WE CAN
ALSO REMEMBER. THE TWO THINGS
WE FOUND IN COMMON TODAY- THAT
THERE IS AN IMPACT TO HEALTH
AND ENVIRONMENT OF THE BAND IN
AN ORPHAN WELLS THAT ARE NOT
READY TO PROPERLY- AND ALSO
THAT WE WANT TO DO MORE TO
ALLOW CALTRAIN. TO TACKLE THIS
PROBLEM AND NOT SEE THE BACKLOG
THAT WE HAVE SEEN. SO I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THIS BILL TODAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SAN BE WE
WILL GO TO A CLUB OUR TO MAKE A
COMMENT AND THAT IS IT. WHEN
CENTER GROVE SLIPPED AND USED
TO WORK DOGGART IT WAS DELAYED
POSTTRAUMATIC STRESS FOR ME.
BECAUSE I SUPERVISED ORDER FOR
EIGHT YEARS. AND THE- THE ISSUE
THAT SENATOR LA MON JUST
OUTLINED SWELL IS PROFOUND IF-
WE HAD ABANDONED AND ORPHANED
WELLS THAT WE'RE GOING TO BE
MONUMENTAL COST TO THE
TAXPAYERS. IN ADDITION TO THE
ENVIRONMENTAL THREAT THAT COMES
FROM THEM AND SO I SALUTE
SENATOR HER TADO FOR TAKING
THIS ON AND I THINK. THE
AMENDMENTS MAKE THIS BILL
BETTER WE WILL ALL BE LOOKING
AT IT AS IT MOVES ALONG TO MAKE
SURE THAT ADDRESSES THOSE
ISSUES. AND TO SENATOR GROVE
LET ME JUST TELL YOU. ONE OF
THE MOST AMUSING MOMENTS FOR ME
DURING MY TIME IN THE STATE
ASSEMBLY. WAS WHEN THEN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KEVIN MCCARTY
STOOD UP. AND AUTHORED A BILL
TO RAISE FEES IN THIS AREA. AND
IT WAS BECAUSE THERE WAS SLOWER
REGULATION THE INDUSTRY PAID
THE FEES WHEN THEY PAID THE
FEES IT WOULD MOVE THE PROCESS
ALONG. BUT I ASKED HIM IF HE
WOULD YIELD FOR A QUESTION AND
ASK THEM IF THIS WAS THE FIRST
OF MANY FEE BILLS THAT HE WAS
GOING TO PUT ON THE FLOOR OF
THE ASSEMBLY CAN. HE BLUSHED IT
DIDN'T WANT TO ANSWER BUT IT
WAS BECAUSE OF THIS PRECISE
ISSUE THAT HE HAD TO MOVE ALONG
TO FEES TO MOVE ALONG TO
REGULATION TO MAKE SURE THAT
IT. THAT IT HAPPENED AND I
THINK IT HAS TO BE NOTED THAT
IT IS THE INDUSTRY. THAT PAYS
FOR THE REGULATORY PROCESS AND
IF THEY DON'T PAY ENOUGH THEY
DON'T GET THE REGULATORY
PROCESS TO BE ALLOWED TO DO IT
AND SO ALL THOSE THINGS ARE
GOING TO BE WRAPPED UP IN THIS
BILL AND THAT'S WHY. I SAID THE
CENTER FOR BE WILLING TO TAKE
IT ON. OUR OWN IS THERE A
MOTION ON THIS BILL OUR MOTION
BY AIKMAN. OF THAN WHAT. OF THE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
FILE ITEM S. B. EIGHTY. THE
MOTION DUE AS AMENDED BUT FIRST
AMEND AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
LAYERED HI LITTERED I'D JONES
AND VOTING JONES NO ALLEN. OUT
NOT KNOWING OF. NOT VOTING
JONES NOT VOTING. ALLEN ALLEN
HI A- EGGMAN I GROWTH THROUGH
NOTE HEARD. HUESO LAMONT. HI
MON HI STERN AS FOR BILL TEN
ARE WE WILL HOLD THAT BILL
OPEN- FOR THE APPS SENATORS
THANK YOU CENTER PADA FORMALLY
WE GO AND FILE ORDER BUT WE
HAVE THE SENATOR THAT IS- BEEN
PATIENTLY WAITING IN FRONT OF
SOME OF THE MEMBERS ON THE
COMMITTEE DOES ANYBODY HAVE ANY
OBJECTION TO US. ASKING SENATOR
KABIR TO PRESENT HER BILL.
SEEING NONE. OF WILL MOVE. TO
ALL ON I'M SORRY I'M JUST LIKE
I THOUGHT SHE HAD SAID. OKAY I
JUST AFTER SORRY I BLEW THAT WE
DID NOT I DIDN'T OFFER CENTER
HER TADO CHANCE TO CLOSE IN
FROM FACETIME LATER THIS
BARBARO APOLOGIZE FOR THE RUSH
TO MOVE THE HEARING ON. WILL
RECOGNIZE SENATOR CAFIERO ITEM
FILE ITEM NUMBER TEN SB THREE
FORTY SEVEN AND SENATOR STERN
IF YOU'RE LISTENING BE IN THE
ROOM WHEN SENATOR KABIR WAS
DONE AND WE WILL TAKE UP YOUR
BILL SO A MOVE TO FIGHT ON FILE
ITEM TEN WELCOME SENATOR KABIR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS I'M PLEASED TO PRESENT
SENATE BILL THREE FORTY SEVEN
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY AND
NEIGHBORHOOD TREE FIND ONE I
THINK THE COMMITTEES
CONSULTANTS WHO WORKED WITH MY
STAFF AND STAKEHOLDERS ON
RECENT AMENDMENTS AUTHORS
AMENDMENTS AND ACCEPT. THE ONE
CLEAN UP AMENDMENT AS WELL. SB
FORTY SEVEN CREATIVE.
CONTRIBUTION TO THE STATE
INCOME TAX TO HELP PROVIDE A
CONSISTENT SOURCE OF FUNDING TO
CAL FIRE'S URBAN AND COMMUNITY
FORESTRY PROGRAM WITH A SPECIAL
FOCUS ON SMALL URBANIZED
COMMUNITIES THAT LACK.
GOVERNMENTAL INFRASTRUCTURE
NEEDED TO PROVIDE FOR THE LONG
TERM CARE AND MAINTENANCE OF
SHADE TREES THIS BECAME A- A
REAL ISSUE FOR ME IS HOW WAS
CAMPAIGNING IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY. IN THE SUMMER AND IT
GETS TO A HUNDRED AND TEN
DEGREES- I HAVE. TWENTY SEVEN
CITIES IN MY DISTRICT BUT
TWENTY FOUR OF THEM THAT ARE
SMALL. URBANIZED AREAS BUT- ARE
POOR FARMWORKERS COMMUNITIES
AND BOTTOM LINE IS THEY DON'T
HAVE THE INFRASTRUCTURE IN
PLACE. TO BE ABLE TO REQUIRE.
THE PLANTING OF TREES AS PART
OF THEIR URBAN FORESTRY- NEEDS
AND YOU CAN TELL THE DIFFERENCE
THE HEAT ISLANDS ARE JUST
INCREDIBLY INTENSE. URBAN TREES
COVER CANNOT COVER CANOPIES
VARY WIDELY ACROSS THE STATE
AND YOU HAVE A GREAT- LIST OF
THE KINDS OF. OF COVERAGE YOU
GET IN DIFFERENT COMMUNITIES
ALL OVER THE STATE AND IT'S
PRETTY CLEAR THE DISADVANTAGED
AND LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES AND
COUNTY AN INCORPORATED THERE IS
HAVE LESS CANOPY. CANOPY COVER
THAN OTHER COMMUNITIES DUE TO
THE COST OF TREE CARE IN THE
INABILITY TO MANAGE TREES AT
CIVIC INFRASTRUCTURE. THESE
COMMUNITY STRUGGLE TO FIND AND
MAINTAIN THEIR URBAN FORESTRY
PROGRAMS LEADING TO THE
INEQUITABLE DISTRIBUTION OF
ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFITS AND
SUFFER FROM GREATER URBAN HEAT
ISLAND EFFECTS AND WORST AIR
POLLUTION. CALIFORNIA'S URBAN
FORESTS FACE MULTIPLE
CHALLENGES SUCH AS INVASIVE
PEST CONTROL BUT THE ISSUE THAT
SB THREE FORTY SEVEN ADDRESSES
IS THE SIMPLE FACT. THE TREE
PLANTING PROGRAMS COME AT A
COST. IN THE COMMUNITIES IN
GREATEST NEED OF TREES HAVE
SCARCE RESOURCES TO INVEST IN
TREES AS INFRASTRUCTURE.
FORTUNATELY CALIFORNIA'S URBAN
AND CALIFORNIA FOREST PROGRAM
WORKS WITH NINE GOVERNMENTAL
ORGAN. AND THEY'RE REALLY THAT
THE- THE INDIVIDUALS THAT WE
WANT TO HELP SALAS TO HELP TO
SOLVE THIS ON THE TAX FORM-
LIKE OUR SPONSORS THE
CALIFORNIA URBAN FORESTRY
COUNCIL AND CALIFORNIA RELIEF.
I'M THEY HELP TO DELIVER
PROGRAM FUNDS TO COMMUNITIES
NEED TREES. SB THIRTY THREE
FORTY SEVEN SIX VOLUNTARY
CONTRIBUTIONS FROM INDIVIDUALS
CORPORATIONS AND FOUNDATIONS
INSTEAD OF GENERAL FUNDS BONDS
ARE GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION
FUND SOURCES. AND THE END NGOS
THAT WORK WITH. WORK CLOSELY
WITH CAL FIRE TODAY GAINED A
GREAT TOOL TO BE ABLE TO
MARKET. BOB THIS PARTICULAR
FUND TO THEIR THOUSANDS OF
SUPPORTERS. SB THREE FORTY
SEVEN GETS CALIFORNIA HOME OF
THE ORIGINAL TREE HUGGER A
CHANCE TO GIVE DIRECTLY TO THE
COMMUNITY AND NEIGHBORHOOD TREE
FIND IN ORDER TO GENERATE
DEPENDABLE. ANNUAL PROGRAM
REVENUE FOR AN EXISTING CAL FAR
PROGRAM. THANK YOU FOR YOUR-
HERE- TIME TODAY- DR VOTE AND
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT IS NANCY
HUGHES THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE CALIFORNIA URBAN
FORESTRY COUNCIL. GREAT TO JUST
BEFORE WE MOVED TO NANCY HUGHES
LET ME SAY I'M REMIND YOU THAT
YOU SAID THE HOME OF THE
ORIGINAL TREE HUGGER. AT SOME
FUTURE TIME THAT IS TOO GOOD.
THAT IS JUST JUICY SO- LET'S
MOVE TO NANCY HUGHES WHO IS THE
LEAD SUPPORT ON THE CO HOSTS
PHONE LINE. HI THIS IS NANCY
CAN YOU HEAR ME PEOPLE. YES.
OKAY GOOD MORNING YES WE CAN
HEAR YOU. PLEASE PROCEED. I AM
ASKING YOU AS YOU KNOW AND THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA URBAN FOREST COUNCIL
AND I AM PLEASED TO TESTIFIED
TODAY IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE
FORTY SEVEN. URBAN FOREST
COUNCIL IS A NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION FOUNDED IN
NINETEEN SIXTY EIGHT TO ADVANCE
SMART INVESTMENT IN GREEN
INFRASTRUCTURE. THROUGH
EDUCATION AND OUTREACH
COMMUNITY BASED ACTIVITIES AND
COLLABORATIVE ACTION. WE
ENVISION THRIVING AND
PROSPEROUS CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITIES TRANSFORM BY
HEALTHY TREES AND GREEN SPACES.
AND SCIENCE BACKS UP. AT THE
TOP POPULATIONS IN CALIFORNIA'S
TOWNS AND CITIES GROW AND
CLIMATE CHANGE IMPACTS QUALITY
OF LIFE ISSUES THROUGH DROUGHT
AND INCREASED URBAN HEAT
ISSUES. THE NEED FOR
SUSTAINABLE URBAN FORESTRY ALSO
GROWS. TREES PROVIDE NUMBER OF
VITAL BENEFITS INCLUDING A
MYRIAD OF THE BAYERN MENTAL
SERVICES AS WELL AS THE
DRAFTING DOCUMENTED PUBLIC
HEALTH OUTCOMES AND IMPROVED.
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITIES. MAKING
OF OUR LAW THAT. TWENTY FIFTEEN
THANKS TO THE CALIFORNIA
INITIATIVE AND CAL FIRES URBAN
COMMUNITY FORESTRY GRANTS
PROGRAM WE ALONG WITH OUR
PARTNERS HAVE WORK IN OVER
FIFTY CITIES. IN AGING WITH
OVER SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS. TWO
YEARS PLANTING AND CARING FOR
MORE THAN NINE THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED NO TREATING.
APPROXIMATELY 80% OF THOSE
TREES HAVE GONE INTO ALLEN BY
REINSTALLING. DETERMINED TO
MANAGE AT LEAST WHERE WE BUILD
LOCAL NEIGHBORS RELATED. I
THANK AND THEIR OWNERSHIP IN
THE- AND THE PROCESS. I'M AT
THE REPURPOSE THAT PROBLEM WHAT.
IT JUST MADE. OKAY YES WHAT IS
YOURS YOU'RE GOING IN AND OUT
BUT JUST COMPLETE YOUR
STATEMENT TO ENTER WE
APPRECIATE YOU BEING HERE AND
WE HAVE CAUGHT THE DRIFT. WHAT
SENATOR CARVALHO SAID CANNOT BE
OVERSTATED DISADVANTAGED IN LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES AND COUNTY
UNINCORPORATED AREAS. COVERED
IN A FIFTEEN YEAR. ACOSTA TREE
CARE AND TO MANAGE YOU CAN MAKE
A COULD START. THANK YOU URBAN
PROGRAMS READING TO AN.
DEPLETION OF EMPIRE BETTER.
BERMAN I WANT THERE POLICE. THE
FUNDS TARGETED APART BUT- MOST
IN NEED WELL THE PART THAT BUT
THE. WE WILL USE OUR OUT WE
EFFORTS TOWARD THE COMMUNITY
NEIGHBORHOOD TREES UPWARD WORK
IT. IT IN ORDER TO GENERATE
DEPEND OF ANNUAL FOREVER IT'S
GOING OUT FIRE PROGRAM. MAYBE
IT ORGANIZED OKAY THANK MCCARTY
CALIFORNIA WILL DO THE SAME. WE
FEEL FREE TO REACH OUT OF
FURTHER INFORMATION AND YOU FOR
THE TOPIC. YEAH AT THE- TOPICS
IF YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WITH YOUR TIME. WE WILL NOW
MOVE OTHER- TEST AND IN THE-
FOR JUST NAME ORGANISE IS THERE
ANYBODY THIS WERE THAT WAS TO
OFFERS. IS THERE ANYBODY IN
ROOM TWENTY. THE WISHES TO
OFFER SUPPORT. SEEING NONE
MODERATOR WILL GO TO ANYBODY ON
THE TELECONFERENCING LINE WHICH
IS TO OFFER SUPPORT. OUR NAME
AND ORGANIZATION. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF SB THREE FORTY SEVEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AN
OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH
YOUR LINE NUMBER IN CASE YOU
BACKING THANK YOU. ONCE AGAIN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF SB THREE FORTY SEVEN. WHEN
THE POLICE PRESS ONE THEN. ZERO
THAT IS HOW MATURE WE LOOK AT
WE HAVE THREE PEOPLE IN Q.
GREAT WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE
NAME AN ORGANIZATION AND
SUPPORT PLEASE. THE LINE NUMBER
SEVENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. IN MORNING
GONZALEZ WHEN YOUR RELEASED IN
COURT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MODERATOR. NUMBER THIRTY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO ONE OF THEM WE
DON'T KNOW WE'RE NOT ABOUT
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MODERATOR. LINE NUMBER TWENTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING TURN
MEMBERS JULIE UP ALL. APOLOGY
ARE GETTING OUR LETTER IN TIME
TO BE INCLUDED AND ALL THAT BUT
WE ARE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MODERATOR
TO SAID EXHAUST THE QUEUE.
INTERESTED SHARE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH STAND BY. OKAY WE'RE GOING
TO GO TO ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION
IS THERE ANYBODY IN THIS
HEARING OUR OWN THAT WISHES TO
OFFER OPPOSITION. SEEING NONE
IS THERE ANYBODY IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY WISHES TO OFFER
OPPOSITION. SEEING NONE
MODERATOR WILL GO TO THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE IS THERE
ANYBODY THAT WISHES TO OPT OFF
FOR PROPOSITION TWO SB THREE
FORTY SEVEN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
SB TWO FORTY SEVEN. PRESS ONE
ZERO. OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOU
WITH YOUR LINE NUMBER. BUT YOU
BACK INTO Q. ONCE AGAIN THAT'S
ONE THEN THEY WROTE. BEGIN
OPPOSITION ABOUT. FIFTY THREE
FORTY SEVEN. THOMAS THE HERE NO
ONE IS SHOWING UP THANK YOU
VERY MUCH QUESTIONS COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS. A
SENATOR JONES. THANK YOU TOM
CENTER I UNDERSTAND THIS IS A
VOLUNTARY CONTRIBUTION TO THE
INCOME TAX RETURN FORM- IN
THERE ISN'T ALREADY NINETEEN
OTHER. CHECK OFFS ON THAT FORM
ARE YOU CONCERNED THAT- THIS IS
GOING TO GET LOST IN THAT.
MORASS OF ALREADY CHECK OFFS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR THAT
QUESTION SENATOR- THAT THE WAY
THAT THE CHECK OFF SYSTEM WORKS
IS THAT IF YOU DON'T RATE IF
YOU DON'T RAISE ENOUGH MONEY-
AND I BELIEVE THAT CUT OFFICE
TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS ON AN ANNUAL BASIS YOU
LOSE YOUR PLACE IN LINE AND SO-
BY I WOULD BE WORRIED IF I
DIDN'T HAVE THE BACKING OF A
NUMBER OF TREE ORGANIZATIONS
THAT ARE WILLING TO GO OUT AND
URGE THEIR MEMBERSHIPS TO MAKE
VOLUNTARY CONTRIBUTIONS. OKAY
AND THEN JUST A FOLLOW UP OF
AYE MATE GERMAN OPERATE A
REGARDING THE FUNDING YOU KNOW
IF YOU'RE RAISES TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND AND I'M- OUR
ANALYSIS IS SHOWING MAYBE UP TO
SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND. URBAN
FORESTRY IS ALREADY RECEIVING A
LOT OF MONEY FROM. PROPOSITION
SIXTY EIGHT. FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS- FROM- IN. NINETEEN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN AND A HALF MILLION
DOLLARS. AND THEN- IN THE
PRIOR- BOND BILL THAT TIME MR
PORTANTINO IS PROPOSING-
THERE'S A TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS IN THAT- FOR URBAN
FORESTRY. AND SO- MAYBE YOU
WANT TO TALK TO YOU KNOW HOW
DOES HOW DOES TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
GRAND OR FIVE HUNDRED GRAND
MAKE A DIFFERENCE WHEN THEY'RE
ALREADY GETTING. MULTIPLE I
TENS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS A
YEAR. WELL THE THIS IS PRODUCE
SPECIFIC IT SPECIFICALLY FOR
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES IS
THE IS THE INTEREST IN THE
FOCUS. THE G. R. G. MONEY IS A
BASS LEADS- PROPOSITION SIXTY
EIGHT IS GETTING THE END. TO
THE END OF ITS USEFUL LIFE IS
WHAT I UNDERSTAND. SO NEW BOND
MONEY IS GREAT BUT IT'S-
USUALLY ONE TIME FUNDS AND ONCE
IT'S USED THE- THERE'S NO
OTHER- FUNDING SOURCE I LOOK AT
THIS AS AN OPPORTUNITY. TO HAVE
CONTINUAL FUNDING. AND IT'S NOT
A HUGE AMOUNT OF MONEY BUT IT
IS CERTAINLY SOMETHING THAT CAN
BE DEPENDED ON TO MAKE THE
COMMITMENT TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
BECAUSE- IT'S NOT JUST PLANTING
THE TREE IT'S GIVING THEM MONEY
SO THAT THEY CAN. CONTINUE THE
MAINTENANCE OF THE TREE FOR A
PERIOD OF TIME- AND SO HAVING A
AND AB. SOURCE OF REVENUE THAT
IS CONTINUING IS REALLY
IMPORTANT. IS THE ORGANIZED
ORGANIZATION TREE CITY USA ONE
OF YOUR SUPPORTERS. I DON'T
IT'S ON OUR ANALYSIS SO AND
SOMETIMES THE REPUBLICANS GET.
WE DON'T GET ALL OF THE LETTERS
IN SUPPORT BECAUSE MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THE PORTAL
DOESN'T ALWAYS- DISTRIBUTE THEM
CHRIS I JUST WANTED MY ABOUT MY
HOME TOWN JUST A TREE CITY USA
SO THAT'S THAT'S WHY IS ONE.
WOULDBE GREAT IF THEY IF THEY
WOULD I MIGHT WE'RE GETTING
LETTERS KIND OF AS WE SPEAK SO
IS MINE BUT THAT'S A NATIONAL
ORGANIZATION. MIGHT NOT BE
GETTING INVOLVED IN CALIFORNIA
BILLS. WELL THEY OUGHT TO. I
AGREE- NOTE THIS MOMENT I WAS
GONNA LAY OFF I'M GONNA SUPPORT
YOUR BILL THIS MORNING I KNOW
YOU'RE GONNA DO A GOOD JOB ON
IT AND I THINK FOR. FURTHER
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS. LET ME
JUST MAKE ONE BEFORE I ASK YOU
TO CLOSE THAT AND THAT IS THAT
FIGHT MINISTER THIS BOND PART.
IN IT IN RESPONSE TO THE
QUESTION THAT WAS RAISED IT WAS
ALWAYS OVER SUBSCRIBED. AND
THERE ARE ALWAYS MANY MANY
CITIES IN LINE THE MINUTE THE
MONEY RAN OUT. AND SO TO HAVE A
STABLE FUNDING SOURCE. TO THE
DEMAND IS THERE THIS WILL MEET
IT THEN I THINK OF HER RATE IF
IT'S IN A BOUGHT. OPERATE IF WE
STILL HAVE BOND MONEY BUT WE
WILL RUN OUT AND THIS WILL BE
SOMETHING THAT WILL BE THERE
AND BE STUDY. AND THERE IS JUST
TO DEMAND ALL ACROSS CALIFORNIA
SO I SALUTE YOU FOR DOING THIS-
DID WE HAVE A MOTION. EFFORT
CENTER EGGMAN BEAT YOU TO IT
THIS TIME BUT OPERAS SO THAT'S
A MOTION WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE ALL I'M A DOCTOR
STATEMENT AS MY CLOSING AND
JUST SAY THAT- PART OF THE
CHALLENGE FOR SOME OF THESE
REALLY SMALL COMMUNITIES IS
THEIR LAST IN LINE THEY THEY
JUST DON'T HAVE THE RESOURCES
TO DO UP A GRANT APPLICATION
IT'S A- COMPETITIVE AND SO I'M
HOPING THAT SOME OF THIS WILL
TRICKLE INTO THE COFFERS OF
THOSE. THOSECITIES THAT REALLY
NEED IT RIGHT THANK YOU ARE
WITH THE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. FILE ITEM TEN S. B.
THREE FORTY SEVEN THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED THE FIRST
AMENDED AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE. LAYARD BY LAYERED I'D
JONES. JONES HI ALLEN. ALLEN
AYE EGGMAN. EGGMAN HI GROVE.
GROOVE HI HERTZBERG WAY SO LONG.
THE MONITORING HI I GUESS I
DON'T HEAR THE SOUND LIMóN AND
STERN AYE STERN HI THAT HAVE
OKAY THAT IS ENOUGH VOTES
BEHOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR THE
END OF THE HEARING THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH
YOU SENATOR WE APPRECIATE THAT
WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER THREE. A B. C. THREE. US
SENATOR STERN WELCOME TO YOUR
OWN COMMITTEE. AND IF JOHN JUST
WAS TO BECAUSE HIM ABOUT THAT
BILL HE'LL TALK TO YOU ABOUT IT
LATER. THANK YOU MISS CHAIR
THIS IS THE- GIVE THE GAS TO
SOME KNOWS MUCH MORE- THAT
ANYONE THE BUILDING. IF I
RESOURCES I APPRECIATE I'VE
BEEN WATCHING THIS WHOLE
HEARING IN MY- OFFICE IN THE
DEBATE. IS ACTUALLY BEN
EXCELLENT I KNOW IT'S BEEN LONG
BUT REALLY THOROUGH AND SUB-
THANK YOU FOR IT. SB SIXTY
THREE. IS AN INTERESTING.
ERIDGE OF IDEAS- WHERE WE'VE
BEEN TRYING TO FIND THE SWEET
SPOT IN HOW WE DISTRIBUTE FIRE
PREVENTION FUNDING IN A WAY
THAT- ADVANCES BOTH BUILDING
SAFETY- BUT ALSO PRESERVES-
ENVIRONMENTAL INTEGRITY IN SOME
OF OUR MOST ECOLOGICALLY
SENSITIVE FIRE ZONES SO. TODAY
I'M REALLY EXCITED ABOUT THE
PARTNERSHIP WE'VE DEVELOPED
WHERE THE BUILDING INDUSTRY HAS
REALLY COME TO THE TABLE AND
STEPPED UP AND SAID YOU KNOW WE
CAN BUILD FIRE SAFE NOT JUST IN
THE VERY HIGH FIRE SEVERITY
ZONES BUT AN OPENNESS TO
EXTENDING THAT KIND OF BUILDING
STANDARD THROUGH THIS
LEGISLATION IN HIGH OR
MODERATE- FIRE ZONES BECAUSE AS
WE'VE LEARNED THROUGH THESE
FIRES. IF YOU LOOK AT- TUBS IN
COFFEE PARKER I EVEN- DOWN
THROUGH SANTA CRUZ OR BY THE
FIRES HAPPENED IN OUR BACKYARD
THEY'RE NOT JUST BURNING IN THE
VERY HIGH FIRE SEVERITY SOUNDS
SO WE'RE HOPING THAT THE NEW
HOUSING THAT WE ALL NEED TO
BECAUSE INTO THESE OTHER
COMMUNITIES IS- AS RESILIENT AS
POSSIBLE THAT IT ADOPTS EMBER
RESISTANT- PRINCIPLES AND WE
KNOW IT A LOT OF THESE FIRES
COME DOWN TO THAT ONE AMBER
ZIPPING THROUGH THAT EVENT.
WORK OR- IT ONLINE GASKET IN
YOUR GARAGE OUR RIGHT TO YOUR
FURNACE IN THAT TAKES IT ALL
DOWN IT COULD BE THAT THAT ONE
LITTLE DIFFERENCE THAT THAT
PIECE OF MASTERING EVE IT- IS
AN OPENER GUTTER THAT HASN'T
BEEN CLEANED. OR FOR THOSE SORT
OF STANDARD ELEMENTS OF HOUSING
THAT WE THINK CAN MAKE EVERYONE
SAFE SO- THAT'S PART OF THIS
BILL BUT THE OTHER PART OF IS
THE ENVIRONMENTAL COMMUNITY IS
HAS STEPPED UP AND ENJOYING
THIS IN PART AS PARTNERS HERE
IN IN TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT
OUR FIRE PREVENTION FUNDING
ALSO FOCUSES ON AREAS LIKE
RIGHT AGAINST ROADWAYS-
REMOVING INVASIVE GRASSES UP WE
KNOW A LOT OF IGNITION. OCCURS
RIGHT ALONG THE ROADSIDE PEOPLE
FLICKING A CIGARETTE OUT THE
WINDOW- THIS IS NOT JUST
LIGHTNING AND IT'S NOT JUST
UTILITIES- THERE ARE OUR A LOT
OF HUMAN. OF WILDFIRE AND WE
HAD I THINK SIX OR- IN THE LAST
TWO MONTHS IN OUR DISH IN IN MY
BACKYARD THAT HAVE THANK GOD
BEEN PUT DOWN BUT- THE WINDS OF
SORT OF SAVED US ON THOSE. MORE
COMING- SO WE THINK FOCUSING ON
AVOIDING TYPE CONVERSION
LOOKING AT ROADWAYS LOOKING AT
SOME OF THE SORT OF A CUTE
AREAS OF RISK OR CRITICAL AND
SO. WE'RE ALSO ADDING SOME OF
THOSE ELEMENTS TO HOW THE STATE
APPROACHES ITS FIRE PREVENTION
FUNDING DISTRIBUTION STRATEGY-
I COULD TALK FOREVER ABOUT THIS
I JUST APPRECIATE WITH WELFARE
WORKING GROUP IS DONE IN THE
SENATE. WHAT THE PRO TEM IS
DONE IN PUSHING EARLY ACTION
AND REALLY TRYING TO SAY WE
CAN'T WAIT TILL NEXT FIRE
SEASON TO MAKE THINGS MOVE SO
I'M HOPING THIS BILL HELPS
XCELERATED THAT EFFORT AND
BUILD FURTHER PARTNERSHIPS.
WITH THAT'LL YOU'LL TO UP TO MY
SUPPORTERS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE HAVE- TO THE FIRST ONE. IS
HERE WITH US WELCOME TO THE
COMMITTEE. YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
SENATORS I'M BOB BREMER SENIOR
ENGINEER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION.
AND STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL
AND I'VE ALSO BEEN ASKED BY THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION. AND THE CALIFORNIA
BUSINESS PROPERTIES ASSOCIATION
INDICATE THEIR STRONG SUPPORT
AS WELL- THE STATE ALREADY HAS
OF FIRE SEVERITIES MAPS. FOR
THE VERY HIGH FIRE SEVERITY
ZONES- THE SENATORSBILL WOULD
EXPAND THAT AND REQUIRE
CALIFORNIA TO FINISH THE MAPS.
FOR THE MODERATE IN THE HIGH
FIRE SEVERITY ZONES AS SOON AS
THAT GETS DONE- THE FIRE
MARSHAL AND HCD WILL MOVE TO
EXPAND APPLICATION. OF OUR FIRE
HARDENING BUILDING STANDARDS-
TO THE VERY TO THE HIGH FIRE
SEVERITY ZONES. AND ALSO
CONSIDER. ADOPTING A-
APPLICATION- TO THE MODERN
ZONES AS WELL- THE BOTTOM LINE
IS THE STANDARDS REALLY WORK-
WHEN YOU HAVE DEFENSIBLE SPACE
COMBINED WITH FIRE HARDENING
BUILDING STANDARDS. THE HOMES
HAVE ABOUT A THREE TO FOUR
TIMES SURVIVABILITY RATE- ABOVE
THOSE THAT DON'T. AND SO WITH
THAT WE STRONGLY URGE YOUR
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND THE
OTHER. LEAD SUPPORT WITNESS IS
A RICK HASELEY OF THE CHAPARRAL
INSTITUTE AND HE'S ON THE CO
HOST PHONE LINE WELCOME TO THE
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU THANK YOU
SENATORS AND- THIS IS A RECALL
THE FROM THE ALL THAT BROKE. IT
AND- I JUST WANT TO SAY
INTEREST RENT AND OWN INSURANCE
SB. SIX THREE- YOU KNOW IF
YOU'LL TAKE A MOMENT TO THINK
ABOUT IT EMPIRE. OR A FIRE IN
YOUR HEART. AND WHAT YOU
ACTUALLY DO TO PREVENT RISK I'M
GETTING TOO MUCH AND THAT IS
YOU PUT STRAINS ON YOUR HARD ON
THE SCREEN OVER YOUR CAMPFIRE.
AND YOU DO THAT BECAUSE IT
KEEPS THE EMBERS SHANKAR'S IN
EIGHTY EMISSIONS MORALES. AND
PATRICK COMPONENT WITH THIS
BILL ADDRESSES EDIT ADDRESSES
THE NEED TO REPLACE IT YOU'LL
CENTER CROTCH. IT TO THE
FARMERS REDUCTION AND ACTUALLY
LOOKS AT THE THINGS THAT
ACUALLY NINE HOMES. ACTUALLY
EVERY HOME IN THE LAST TEN
YEARS OF DEVASTATING WILDFIRES
HAS BEEN IGNITED. NEW TO EMBERS
SENATOR STERN RT SAID. THE WAY
YOU REDUCE VIRUS AND IT TAKES
AWAY FROM THE FUEL CENTRING
POSITION THAT. DOMINATES THE
CONVERSATION NOW IN TERMS OF
HAVING THAT CLARENCE LOGGING
WHEN IN FACT WHAT'S REALLY
HAPPENING- THESE NUMBERS ARE
TRAVELING A MILE OR MORE AND IF
I HAVE A FIRE FRONT AS COPY
PARK REVEALED IN THE TUBBS
FIRE. BECAUSE YOU KNOW THE
DAMAGE IN THIS PARTICULAR BILL
IS GOOD BECAUSE IT ADDRESSES
NOT JUST THAT BUT IT GIVES SOME
POTENTIAL OPPORTUNITIES. TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO ADDRESS THOSE.
ONE IT DEALS WITH. YEAH THAT
REDUCE THE FINAL OF DO AMBER'S
NEVER BEEN ADDRESSED PEOPLE IT
ALSO A PUBLIC EDUCATION-
PROGRAM OR FUNDS AT EAST. TO
HELP PEOPLE MAKE THEIR HOMES
FIRE SAFE. AND IT ALSO DOES
SOMETHING IS VERY IMPORTANT
WHICH OKAY DARGAN WHO IS A
FORMER FIRE MARSHALL HAS ALWAYS
BEEN ADVOCATING IS NOT
STANDARDIZED. FIRE RISK
REDUCTION CHECKLIST. UNITIES
WHICH INCLUDES NOT JUST
EDUCATION AND DEFENSIBLE SPACE
BUT IT TALKS ABOUT THE
FLAMMABILITY OF THE HOME ITSELF
WHICH IS WHY HOMES BURNED.
THAT'S AN IMPORTANT COMPONENT
ALSO. TERMS OF ACTIVATIONS AND
SUCH THAT HAVE REALLY BEEN
PROBLEMATIC IN A LOT OF THESE
FIRES. THIS BILL PASCAL FIRE OR
AT LEAST NOT CALIFORNIA BUT
CALTRANS RATHER TO ACTUALLY BE
PART OF THE PROCESS IN TERMS OF
REDUCING FLAMMABILITY ALONG
ROADWAYS. SOME OF THE
PLANTATION THEN TAKEN FAX
EDUCATION ACT KIND OF A THING
ACTUALLY INCREASED FIRE RISK.
SO HAVING THEM AT THE TABLE
WILL REALLY HELP- AGAIN I JUST
WANT TO EMPHASIZE IT'S ALL
ABOUT AMBER'S. IT'S NOT ABOUT
HUNDRED PLAYING LINKS AND IN
LOGGING POOREST. HABITAT IS
ABOUT MAKING OUR COMMUNITIES
SAFER MEMBERS. SO THANK YOU-
SENATORS TURNED. CAUSING US.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
BUT NOW WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO
FATHERS IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
AND IT JUST NAME AN
ORGANIZATION IS THERE ANYBODY
IN THIS COMMITTEE ROOM WISHES
TO OFFER SUPPORT. SEEING NONE.
OUR WAR ASK IF THERE'S ANYONE
IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY. SEEING NO
ONE MODERATOR WILL MOVE TO THE
PHONE LINE IF THERE'S ANYBODY
THAT WISHES TO OFFER SUPPORTED
JUST NAME AN ORGANIZATION AT
THIS POINT. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR ANOTHER REMINDER IF
YOU'RE USING A PHONE. BANTAL
FOR. THE NUMBERS BEFORE
SPEAKING. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF SB SIXTY THREE PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO. RATABLE PROVIDE YOU
WITH YOUR LINE NUMBER AND PLACE
YOU BACK INTO THE QUEUE. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB SIXTY THREE PRESS
ONE. ZERO NOW. THE MESSAGE
EITHER BUT WE HAVE FIVE
PARTICIPANTS IN Q. RIGHT
WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE THIS
IS JUST YOUR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU MY NUMBER EIGHTY LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING NATALIE BACK ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF LOCAL CONSERVATION CORPS
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MODERATOR BY NUMBER EIGHTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING SURE BRAND
ALSO YEAH FOR. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MODERATOR. MY NUMBER SIXTY
SIX YOU WANT TO GO BACK INTO IT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR TIS IS
MIKE PENCE TO MAKE- ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSPORTATION OF RESOURCE
CONSERVATION DISTRICT OF ALL
WATERSHED RICHARD TRAINING
CENTER IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MODERATOR.
NUMBER FORTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
HOW MANY YOU KNOW LEYVA CITY OF
THOUSAND OAKS AND SUPPORT
LETTER IS FORTHCOMING THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OUR MODERATOR. BY
NUMBER EIGHTY THREE THE LINE IS
OPEN SO I HAD. HELLO THIS IS
CATHY FROM PORT. CALIFORNIA AT
A PORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF
MODERATORS SAID THERE WERE FIVE
WITNESSES AND THAT WAS FIVE DID
THAT EXHAUST THE QUEUE.
YESTERDAY IT. THANK YOU ARE
WILL NOW MOVE TO ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION IS THERE ANYONE IN
THE COMMITTEE ROOM THAT WISHES
TO- REGISTRA POSITION WITH THIS
BILL. SAYING NO ONE IS THERE
ANYBODY IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
SAYING NO ONE MODERATE WERE
BACK TO YOU IS THERE ANYBODY
THAT WISHES ON THE
TELECONFERENCE ON TO REGISTER A
POSITION TO THIS BILL. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN. HELLO IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN. OPPOSITION
MSPS THREE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
IT WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH A LOT
NUMBER PLACE BACK IN YOU ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WERE SPEAKING OF
S. THREE PRESS ONE THEIR OWN.
COMMENTED HERE WE HAVE NO WAY
TO WIN A- THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MODERATOR ODDS BACK THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUICK. COMMENTS
OR ACTIONS ARE. I'M GONNA TAKE
THAT OUR MOTION GROVE AND
COMMENTS BY SENATOR JONES
SAWYER STERNUM FROM VERY AND
WITH- AMOUNT OF SOME THE- CROSS
SECTIONS. AS YOU UP- TEN ALL
THE LACK OF OPPOSITION BUT
THERE'S ONE GLARING- ELEMENT OF
THE BILL THAT I'M I'M REALLY
HAVING A HARD TIME WITH. AND SO
IF YOU MAYBE YOU CAN EXPLAIN
IT- ONE OF THE ELEMENTS AS IT
ALLOWS A HOMEOWNER TO CLEAR THE
NEIGHBORING PROPERTY. TO MEET
THE HUNDRED FOOT DEFENSIBLE
SPACE REQUIREMENT WITH OUT.
THAT NEIGHBORS PERMISSION- BACK
IN- AND MY DISTRICT. WE'VE GOT
PRETTY GOOD NEIGHBORS BUT- GOOD
FENCES MAKE FOR GOOD NEIGHBORS.
AND I CAN JUST IMAGINE THE
CHALLENGES LAW ENFORCEMENT
MIGHT HAVE IN MY DISTRICT OF
ONE NEIGHBOR GOES ON TO ANOTHER
NEIGHBOR'S PROPERTY AND START
CLEARING- BUSHES AND BRUSHES
AND TREES AND SUCH SO- CAN YOU
OR OR ONE OF YOUR- SUPPORTERS
SPEAK TO THAT. YEAH I'M NOT A
I'M LOOKING FOR THE BILL TAKES
I'M NOT FAMILIAR WITH ANY
PROVISION THAT AUTHORIZE ANYONE
TO GO ON TO ANYONE ELSE'S LAND
THIS IS MORE ABOUT SORT OF
STANDARDS DEVELOPMENT TWENTY
JUST POINT POINT POINT IS IT
AND WILL. WELL TO A LOOK. THIS
WASN'T INTENDED TO BE- SOME
BROADER. YEAH I DIDN'T THINK SO
EITHER- OKAY I'LL FOLLOW UP
WITH I DON'T HAVE THE- I DON'T
HAVE TO LOOK INTO IT. THE
INTENT WAS MORE TO BE. SAID
AMBER RESISTANCE ZONE ENTRANCE
WAS BASIS STANDARD SETTING BUT-
I'LL HAVE MY OFFICE FALTERED.
OKAY THANK YOU. DOESN'T MISS.
I'M GONNA LAY OUT FOR TODAY
MISS YOU WILL GET YOU SOME
CLARITY BUT THE FLORIDA FURTHER
FURTHER QUESTION ARE COMMON.
SENATOR STERN YOU COULD. THANK
YOU SO MUCH MISTER CHAIR AND-
LAST FRIDAY I SHOULD BE ABLE TO
GET YOU SOME CLARITY QUICKLY
BUT I'M REALLY HOPING FOR. WE
THIS WAS IT THIS WAS A HOLDOVER
FROM THE END OF SESSION LAST
YEAR HE GOT NO NO VOTES LEADING
UP TO IT WAS A CASUALTY OF ALL
THAT SO I'M HOPING WE COULD
JUST KEEP THIS MOVING AND MAKE
SOME REFORMS AND GET. GET
CALIFORNIA TO RESILIENT PLACE
SO THAT RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
I'VE- OKAY. ARE WITH THE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
YOUR MOTIONS. IT'S A GREAT THE
MOTION IS PASS THE FIRST BE RE
RE TO THE COMMITTEE ON HOUSING.
THAT'S FILE ITEM THREE SB SIXTY
THREE LAYERED HI HI. JONES
VOTING JONES NOT VOTING ALLEN.
ALLEN HI A WIN. EGGMAN AYE.
GROVE I HER. HI HIGHWAY. MON I
LIMON A STERN I STERN HI AND
THAT HAS ENOUGH BUT WE HOLD THE
OF. AND I NOTICED HERTZBERG
HASN'T THIRTY- ITEM O GO TO SO
IF WE ARE STILL GOING AT THAT
TIME I'M GONNA CALL THE ROLL ON
ALL THE OUTSTANDING WANTS TO
ALLOW HIM TO COME ON THE-
MISTER CHAIR. JUST TO CLARIFY
IF YOU DO END UP REOPENING THE
ROLE DID YOU CLOSE THE ROLE AND
THAT MEANT NO. OKAY I'M NOT
CLOSE THE ROLE IN THE SINGLE
MARKET PERFECT SO I WAS JUST
GONNA SAY IT HAS TO BE
CONSISTENT WITH LOCAL ZONING.
SO THAT SPECIFIC IN THE BILL
JUST MR STERN IF YOU WANNA TALK
TO MARK AROUND BECAUSE WE HAVE
A MILLION. YEAH TO WORK HIS
CENTER ALLEN ARE YOU READY TO
PRESENT YOUR BILL ON DOWNS.
I'LL LEAVE YOU GUYS. THE WORKER
TO MOVE THE FINAL. FIVE SB
EIGHTY THREE. FROM SENATOR.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER. AND I
MY UNDERSTAND WERE SUPPOSED TO.
STATE OUR SEATS. ALREADY HERE
THAT'S CORRECT ALL RIGHT SO. WE
HEARD THIS- THE PRO TEM BUILD
ON OUR SEA LEVEL RISE THIS
REALLY TO THE- NINE. DON'T HAVE
TO THE POINT ABOUT TIME THE
THREAT THAT THIS ARE BOTH TO
PEOPLE PROPERTIES AND OF COURSE
THE FINANCIAL THREAT- THE
ESTIMATES ARE THAT MORE THAN A
HUNDRED FIFTY BILLION DOLLARS
WORTH OF PROPERTY COULD BE AT
RISK OF FLOODING BY TWENTY BY.
TWENTY ONE HUNDRED. AND SO
THAT'S THE THAT'S THE ESTIMATE
STATEWIDE. SO ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES ONE OF THE MANY
CHALLENGES OUT THERE RIGHT NOW
IS THAT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE
ARE STRUGGLING WITH HOW TO WITH
WITH ADDRESSING THIS CRISIS.
THEY'RE TRYING TO BALANCE A
VERY LIMITED BUDGETS AND VERY
FEW GOOD OPTIONS WITH THE NEEDS
OF HOMEOWNERS. AND CLEAN AREAS
ALREADY EXPERIENCING FLOODING
BUYING OUT LOCAL RESIDENTS AND
RELOCATING THEM IS VERY VERY
CONTROVERSIAL AND IN SOME CASES
YOU KNOW COST PROHIBITIVE. BUT
SO OF COURSE IS THE EVER- AND
ULTIMATELY LOSING BATTLE
AGAINST THE C. HANSI WALLS- ARE
ARE VERY EXPENSIVE THE THEY
WILL NEVER ALTERNATELY WIND-
BUT THEY DO THEY'RE CERTAINLY A
DECENT AS- HIM. BUT VERY VERY
SHORT TERM ALTERNATIVE BUT- BUT
THEY ALSO DO COME WITH SEVERE
ENVIRONMENTAL CONSEQUENCES IN
THOSE ARE OUTLINED. IN THE
ANALYSIS. SO THE ONLY TIME THAT
A FASCINATING SERIES ON THIS
TOPIC ABOUT THE CHALLENGES THAT
CITIES ARE FACING IN TOWNS UP
AND DOWN OUR COAST. ARE VERY
TOUGH CHOICES ABOUT THEIR BUT
THE TOP OF THE CHOICES ARE
GONNA GET A WHOLE LOT HARDER-
WHEN INSURANCE COMPANIES REFUSE
TO COVER PROPERTIES BANKS WILL
PROVIDE MORTGAGES. TO A
PROPERTIES THAT ARE AT RISK OF
SEA LEVEL RISE AND SO YOU KNOW.
WE I THINK BACK ON THIS I THINK
ABOUT THIS TOPIC I THINK BACK.
TO OTHER BIG CHALLENGES WHAT
WHAT HOW MUCH YOU KNOW IN LIVES
AND TREASURE WE COULD HAVE
SAVED WE TAKE AN ACTION TWO
DECADES AGO- TO TAKE STEPS TO
LOWER THE RISK OF DEVASTATING
WILDFIRES. AND SO SIMILAR
SIMILAR TO FORWARD THINKING
IDEA HERE THE IDEA IS THAT WE
WOULD PROVIDE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
WHO ARE CURRENTLY STUCK IN THIS
VERY DIFFICULT POLITICAL
PREDICAMENT. ASSOCIATED WITH
AND WITH THE IDEA LIMITED CITY
COFFERS AND- THE CHALLENGES OF
PROTECTING PROPERTIES ON THE
COAST WE WOULD PROVIDE THEM
WITH AN INNOVATIVE FINANCING
OPTION. TO ALLEVIATE THE RISKS
OF SEA LEVEL RISE TO THE
PROPERTIES IN THEIR TOWNS.
WHILE I PROTECTING BOTH
PROPERTY OWNERS AND TAXPAYERS
THE IDEAS WE HAVE A REVOLVING
LOAN FUND FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
THROUGH THE AYE BACK. TO BRIBE
PROPERTIES THAT WOULD BE
THREATENED AND IN IT THERE WILL
BE THREATENED IN A DECADE OR
TWO OR THREE. ALLOWING THE
OWNERS TO SELL WHILE THE HOUSE
STILL HAS VALUE. AND THEN THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT CAN RENT OUT
THE PROPERTY REPAYING THE LOAN
AND PREVENTS POTENTIALLY EVEN
EARNING REVENUE. AND THEN WHEN
THE PROPERTIES AT RISK OF
FLOODING FROM RISING SEA LEVELS
THE HOUSE COULD BE DEMOLISHED
OR RELOCATED. WITHOUT LOCAL
RESIDENTS OR TAXPAYERS. DURING
THE COST. SO WE'VE WE WE'VE
BEEN ACTIVELY REACHING OUT TO
STAKEHOLDERS FOR FEEDBACK- AS
THE MOUSE'S NOTES IT'S SOMEWHAT
OF A WORK IN PROGRESS I KNOW
THAT WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO ADD
MORE SPECIFICITY ANALYSIS ASK
FOR IT WE GOT SOME GREAT
SUGGESTIONS ALREADY FROM THE
COASTAL COMMISSION- AND MANY
OTHERS. HI I ALSO WANT TO
DISCUSS THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR
ITS ENGAGEMENT ALREADY I'M I'M
CERTAINLY COMMITTED TO CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH STAFF AND
INTERESTED MEMBERS AS WE GATHER
FEEDBACK AND FURTHER WORK TO
REFINE THE BILL- BUT ANYHOW I
HAVE WITH ME TODAY JENNIFER
SAVAGE WITH SURFRIDER
FOUNDATION IS ABOUT AND SALAS
POTTER WITH THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY WHO ARE GOING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU SENATOR LET'S MOVE TO
THOSE- TWO. WITNESSES
INSUPPORTABLE FROM THE CO HOST
FROM ONE. OF THE FIRST ONE IS
JENNIFER JENNIFER SAVAGE THE
SECOND ONE IS ISABELLA GONZALEZ
POTTER AND WE'RE TRYING TO.
HAVE THREE MINUTES TOTAL
BETWEEN THE WITNESSES SO WHAT
STARK WITH JENNIFER SAVAGE
WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE. THANK
YOU AND GOOD MORNING AGAIN
TERRY COMMITTEE MEMBERS
JENNIFER SAVAGE. CALIFORNIA
POLICY MANAGER FOR THE THIRD
BETTER. IN ORDER THANK BETTER
TO TAX AND THE PRESERVATION.
STRONGLY THAT EIGHTY. AND YOU
HAVE THE CONSEQUENCE OF TODAY
THE LEVEL RIGHT COMPLETE.
DAMAGING ECONOMY THE
COMMUNITIES MARINO FIRE. AND
TAKING OUT OPENING PENSION
WITHOUT THE AND BRIAN AND LOCAL.
TO AND FROM CRACKED AT AT
STRATEGY. WILL BE ONE. MOMENT
AND BE ABLE THERE LOCKED AND
OTHER ELECTED AT THE COMING
DAYS THAT PULLED. BRIDGES THE
LAST FRIDAY. VERY WE CAN SAVE
IT CERTAINTY THAT EVEN THAT
PROACTIVE JURISDICTION ARE FAR
BEHIND WHEN THEY NEED TO BE.
LIKE A RESULT IN NOTHING
AHEAD AND WAYS. YEAH IN THE
ARKANSAS NEEDS YOUR COLOR IT'S
EASY TO SEE A ANYTHING CHINESE
LAST WEEK YOU AGREED OPTION
REGARDING HOW THE HELL THE
PROPERTY A. IF YOU HAVE A RIGHT
THE EIGHTY THREE WITH A MEDIUM
CHEN. ABOUT THE CANCELLED
FINANCE ASPECTS IS THE POINT OF
THE BILL. WHY CAN'T I DO OTHER
THINGS AS EIGHTY ALLOW LOCAL
GOVERNMENT BUY THAT AND ABILITY
STRIDE. WAYS TO CHRIS CAL THE
MONEY. AND MAINTAINING. A IN
THE FUTURE. SB WANTED TRULY
THANK DOWN TIMES MONTEREY
PLANNING AND THE END IN SHORT
SUPPLY. WE APPRECIATE SENATOR
ALAN PETER ON THE RIGHT CRISIS
AND URGED. BUT MY NAME IS A LOT
ABOUT HIGHER AND I'M WITH THE
NATURE CONSERVANCY WHO ALSO
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB EIGHTY
THREE- WITH THE PACIFIC OCEAN
PROJECTED TO RISE NINE FEET IN
SOME COASTAL AREAS OF
CALIFORNIA BY TWENTY ONE
HUNDRED. WE NEED TO TAKE ACTION
TO PROTECT THE ENTIRE CLOSELY
LEVIN DEPEND ON WHETHER
DEVELOPED OR WILD WE MUST ALSO
HELP OUR COMMUNITY LEVY AT THE
RISK OF RISING OCEAN WHILE
PROTECTING BOTH PROPERTY OWNERS
AND NATURE. IN THEORY CONSIGNED
TO COURT SHOWS 55% OF
CALIFORNIA COASTAL HABITAT IS
IN JEOPARDY ALL RIGHT WE
BELIEVE THAT SB EIGHTY THREE
WILL ALSO BE AN IMPORTANT TOOL
TO HELP ADDRESS THE CLIMATE
IMPACTS TO HABITAT AND THE-
FUNDING FROM THE AYE BANK COULD
BE PRIORITIZED TO PROPERTIES
THAT PROVIDE WILL PAY BENEFITS.
INCLUDING PROTECTING COASTAL
HABITAT PROTECT THE EXISTING
INFRASTRUCTURE OR PROTECTING
PARKS AND OTHER OPEN SPACES
CALIFORNIA'S ACT TO PROTECT
COASTAL COMMUNITIES FROM
CLIMATE CHANGE AND THAT THE
EIGHTY THREE DEMONSTRATE THE
NEW APPROACH TO ADDRESS THE
AUTHORIZED. WE THINK SENATOR
ALAN FOR HIS LEADERSHIP ON THIS
ISSUE AND WE ARE YOUR SUPPORT
TODAY THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NOW WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO. A
STATEMENTS OF SUPPORT IT'S JUST
NAME AN ORGANIZATION. IS THERE
ANYBODY IN THIS COMMITTEE ROOM.
SEEING NO ONE WAY MOVE TO ROOM
TO FORTY IS THERE ANYBODY IN
TWENTY FORTY WHICH IS TO OFFER
SUPPORT. SANGUE NON MODERATOR
IS THERE ANYBODY ON THE PHONE
LINE THAT WISHES TO OFFER
SUPPORT FOR S. B. EIGHTY THREE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB EIGHTY
THREE. PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. AN OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE
YOU WITH YOUR LINE NUMBER AND
SET YOU BACK INTO Q. ONCE AGAIN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF SB EIGHTY THREE. PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO NOW. WE
HAVE TWO PEOPLE IN THE QUEUE
OKAY ARE WELCOME TO THE
COMMITTEE NAME AN ORGANIZATION
PLEASE. THANK YOU MISTER
CAROLINA WERE EIGHTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BUT NOT HERE CALIFORNIANS. FOR
MORE SIERRA CLUB BUT I ASSUME
YOU'RE IN SUPPORT IT CUT OFF.
YES BRING ENOUGH WITH THE
ARKHAM CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT
POLICIES THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF
MODERATOR SECOND PERSON. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR LINE NUMBER
FORTY THREE THE LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
SHERRY MEMBERS OF SISTER
CHRISTY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
COASTAL COMMISSION. LAST WEEK
THE COMMISSION VOTED
UNANIMOUSLY TO SUPPORT- SB
EIGHTY THREE WITH SOME
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS TO MAKE IT
CONSISTENT WITH THE REST OF THE
CULTURAL ACT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MODERATOR TO SAID
EXHAUST THE QUEUE. NO SIR WE DO
HAVE SOMEONE CHEWING UP AT THE
MOMENT BY MOMENT MISS THE CHAIR.
STE WHY NUMBER EIGHTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
POLICE SHOT ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF SANTA MONICA IN SUPPORT
OF AN EIGHTY THREE THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- THAT'LL
TICKLE BY SENATOR ALAN. IS
THERE ANYBODY ELSE THAT
MODERATOR THAT IS QUEUING UP.
SURE THERE'S NO ONE I THINK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH JUST STAND
BY BECAUSE WE'RE GOING TO GO TO
OPPOSITION IS OR ANYBODY THAT
WISHES TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
IN THIS HEARING OR. IS THERE
ANYBODY SAYING NONE IS THERE
ANYBODY IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
WISHES TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
SAYING NINE MODERATOR WILL MOVE
TO THE PHONE LINE IS THERE
ANYBODY- ON THE TELECONFERENCE
ARVEST WISHES TO REGISTER
OPPOSITION. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB EIGHTY
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
THERE- IT WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH
YOUR LINE NUMBER IN CASE YOU
BACK INTO Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB EIGHTY THREE. PUSH PRESS ONE
THE NEW THEIR OWN NOW. AND AT
THIS TIME IS THE CHAIR WE HAVE
NO ONE TO IN UP. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MODERATOR WILL BRING THE
MATTER BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR
ACTIONS. WITH THANK THE SENATOR
FOR HIS MIND BILL AND MOVE IT.
THE MOTION BY EGGMAN COMMENTS
BY SENATOR JONES THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN JOHN I'M I'M- I
ALSO APPRECIATE THE BILL AND I
WANT TO BE KIND OF SPECIFIC ON.
ON- WHAT I PREACH ABOUT IT IT
SEEMS TO BE PRETTY REASONABLE-
YOU'RE YOU'RE NOT RAISING
TAXES- YOU'RE USING THE HIGH
BANK- WHICH I IN ANOTHER SOME
DEBATE DEBATE ABOUT THAT BUT I
THINK THAT WAS A CREATIVE- AT
ELEMENT OF YOUR BILL. AND- AND
YOU'RE NOT ALLOWING FOR EMINENT
DOMAIN SO ALL THE PURCHASES
MUST BE VOLUNTARY SO I THINK
THOSE ARE ALL GOOD THINGS AND-
I'M SUPPORT YOUR BILL. WHILE
WORKING IN. THE REBELS. WE
HARPER CENTER. M. THANK YOU
MISTER. FIVE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I TO ECHO MY COLLEAGUES'
COMMENTS FROM SAN DIEGO BECAUSE
THEM. IT IS VERY. VERY IN
INGENIOUS HOW YOU PUT THIS BILL
TOGETHER REALLY IS- THERE'S IN
THE ON. YEAH WE DO M. WE DO
HAVE A PROBLEM WITH YOU KNOW
HOUSES RIGHT DIRECTLY ON THE
COAST THAT ARE YOU KNOW HAVING
AN ISSUE AND I AM CONCERNED
ABOUT INSURANCE AND OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS AND BANKS AND
LENDING THAT WILL BE THERE AND
IF. AND IF THIS IS A WAY TO-
PURCHASES PROPERTIES WHAT
FORCING THEM TO SELL OR EMINENT
DOMAIN AND THEN USING THOSE AS
RENTAL PROPERTIES TO PAY BACK
SOME ALONE SO THAT TAXPAYERS
ARE REALLY ON THE HOOK AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS HAVE I MEAN I
THINK IT WAS REALLY GOOD BILL
THAT WE PUT IT TOGETHER SO I AM
I AM HONORED TO SUPPORT. THANK
YOU CORRECT IT DOESN'T GIVE YOU
ANY CONCERN ABOUT GOING FORWARD
WITH THAT HAVE YOU KNOW WHAT I
WHAT I AND I DO WE BOTH LIKE IT
I DO AND I DO WANT TO SAY HE'S
JUST SPEAKING FROM SELF. I DO
WANT TO SAY. IS OUR INTENTION
AT THIS IS- YOU KNOW IT SHOULD
BE REVENUE NEUTRAL RIGHT THE
IDEA IS THAT THE THAT THE THAT
THE- AT THE END THIS IS OF
COURSE GOING OUT TO YOUR TOP OF
THE ACTUARIES BUT THAT THE- THE
REVENUE GENERATED THROUGH THE
RENTAL WILL. WILL RECOUP. THE
BANKS COSTS SOMEBODY. WELL
HOPEFULLY ALL OF IT I MEAN
HOPEFULLY HOPEFULLY YOU CAN SEE
THEM IN THE END OF THE THESE
ARE VERY- VERY ATTRACTIVE
PROPERTIES ARE THESE ARE
PROBABLY LITERALLY BY
DEFINITION RIGHT ON THE BEACH
SO JUST IN THE SAME WAY THAT
THEIR VALUABLE- AS- OWNERSHIP
PROPERTIES THOUGH COURSE
VULNERABLE. THERE ALSO AND
VALUABLES RENTAL PROPERTIES.
AND SO- I MEAN I'D PASS THAT
STARTS CERTAINLY WHAT I LIKE TO
SEE WITH WITH THIS PROGRAM. IF
IT IS A MUST FOR THIS- GET THE
MONEY BACK AND THEN THE BE USED
MORE PROPERTIES RIGHT. WAS THAT
YOUR CLOTHES YES IT TAKES
BIGGER MEMBERS FOR THEIR
SUPPORT AND I RESPECT THAT
SENTIMENT WILL TAKE THAT AS A
CLOSE- WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR EGGMAN WOULD YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. FILE ITEM FIVE
S. B. EIGHTY THREE THE MOTION
IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE LAYERED
HI LITTERED ALL RIGHT JONES.
JONES JONES JONES HI ALAN THANK
ALLEN ON A EGGMAN. EGGMAN ON A
GROOVE. GROVE HI HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG ALL RIGHT AWAY SO.
LIMóN AYE. LIMóN II STERN. HE
WAS VERY GOOD US OKAY THAT HAS
ENOUGH VOTES WILL HOLD THE ROLE
OPEN- FROM AS MISTER NEWMAN
MOVES TO THE PODIUM TO PRESENT
HIS BILL. HERTZBERG CAN'T STAY
THAT IS UNSURE ABOUT BEING ABLE
TO RETURN SO LET'S OPEN OUR
WHAT'S CALLED THE ROLE OF
ABSENT MEMBERS ON EVERY BILL
THAT WE'VE HAD THUS FAR OKAY.
FILE ITEM ONE S. B. ONE THE
CURRENT VOTE IS. SIX ONE ONE.
HERTZBERG HIGH THAT SEVEN
THAT'S ENOUGH OUT. SIX IS
EVERYBODY VOTED ON THAT WE WANT
TO TURN IT ON SERVICE SEVEN TO
THAT AND THEN ON THAT ONE WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE. ITEM TO ITEM TO
SB FORTY FIVE- THE CURRENT VOTE
IS FOR TO- THAT'S SURE
HERTZBERG HI HERTZBERG HIGH.
HUESO STERN. TRIGONAL MAKES
SENSE- THANK YOU. BOB WILL HOLD
OFF ONE OF WHICH MOVE TO ITEM
NUMBER THREE SB SIX SP THREE- I
DON'T THREE SB SIXTY THREE OF
THE CURRENT WORLD IS TO. TWO
FOUR SIX SEVEN ZERO ONE- THAT
WE'VE WE'VE GOT HERTZBERG IS ON
THE WAY SO. OKAY OKAY WILL HOLD
THAT ONE OKAY NEXT IS THE
CONSENT CALENDAR THOSE ARE FILE
ITEMS FOR SEVEN AND ELEVEN.
HERTZBERG BY HERTZBERG HIGH
HUESO LOAN. HI LIMóN HI STERN.
OKAY AND THEN WE HAD THE RULES
THE MORE INNER SCHOOLS VIDEO
I'LL GET TO THE PHONE MARCH
NINTH. FILE SIX SB EIGHTY FOUR
OTHER CURRENT VOTE IS FOR A ONE
AND ONE. HERTZBERG HERTZBERG HI
HUESO STERN- WHICH NEXT WE HAVE
FILE ITEM TEN S. B. THREE FOUR
SEVEN THE CURRENT VOTE IS TO.
SIX OF SEVEN ZERO THE SERVICE
SEVEN ROADSIDE HERTZBERG ALL
RIGHT HUESO. KEEP THAT ONE OPEN
AND FINALLY THE ADOPTION OF THE
COMMITTEE RULES THE CURRENT
VOTE IS- EIGHT. HERTZBERG GUY
HE SAID EVERYBODY IS VOTED ON
THE ROOM WAS NOT AT ALL AND WE
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE ON THAT.
OKAY THEN ARE WE WILL GO BACK
TO OUR AGENDA AND WE HAVE. A WE
HAVE FILE ITEM MADE FINALIZED
OF NINE FILE ITEM TWELVE AND
THEN WE'LL OPEN THE ROLE FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS AT THE END SO
WILL BEGIN WITH ARE GOING TO
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT SB TWO SIXTY
SIX SENATOR NEWMAN. WELCOME TO
THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MISTER CHAIRMAN SENATORS.
I'M HERE BEFORE YOU TODAY IN
THIS IMPRESSIVELY CHILI
COMMITTEE ROOM. ON BEHALF OF S.
B. TWO SIXTY SIX. IT IS A
DISTRICT BILL WHICH WILL DIRECT
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
PARKS AND RECREATION. TO
INCORPORATE INTO CHINO HILLS
STATE PARK THREE PARCELS OF
LAND. THAT HAVE BEEN IDENTIFIED
FOR ACQUISITION AND
PRESERVATION TO LOCAL
CONSERVATION EFFORTS. AND FOR
WHICH FUNDING HAS ALREADY BEEN
SECURED NATURAL STATE PARK
WHICH IS LOCATED PREDOMINANTLY
IN MY DISTRICT. IS ONE OF THE
TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY STATE PARK
UNITS MANAGED BY THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PARKS AND
RECREATION. IT IS LOCATED IN
THE HILLS AROUND SANTA ANA
CANYON INTHE COUNTY OF ORANGE
RIVERSIDE AND SAN BERNARDINO
THE PARK LIES WITHIN THE DENSE
LOS ANGELES BASIN WHICH HAS A
POPULATION OF MORE THAN SEVEN
MILLION PEOPLE. WITHIN A TWENTY
FIVE MILE RADIUS AND ENJOYS
MORE THAN THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND VISITORS ANNUALLY.
THIS PIECE OF LEGISLATION WOULD
INSTRUCT PARKS TO RECEIVE AND
INCORPORATE. INTO THE STATE
PARK THREE JASON LAND PARCELS
ALL WITH WILLING SELLERS OR
DONORS THE LARGEST OF THE THREE
PARCELS IS A TWELVE HUNDRED
ACRE PARCEL KNOWN. AS THE FIRST
NATIONAL INVESTMENT PROPERTIES.
THIS OPEN SPACE PARCEL DO NOT
CURRENTLY TECHNICALLY PART OF
THE PARK FALLS WITHIN A PART OF
THE PARK. DESIGNATED BY THE
CHINO HILLS STATE PARK GENERAL
PLAN AS A CORE HABITATS KNOWN.
AS SUCH THIS OWN INCLUDE
SENSITIVE WILDLIFE HABITATS
THAT ARE CRUCIAL TO THE
MOVEMENT AND SURVIVAL OF MANY
PLANT AND ANIMAL SPECIES
INDIGENOUS TO THE REGION. BUT
PORTION OF THIS PARCELS
CHARACTERIZES WALNUT WOODLAND
ONE OF CALIFORNIA'S RARE AND
IMPERILED NATURAL COMMUNITIES.
THE SECOND OF THE THREE PARCELS
IS A THREE HUNDRED ACRE PARCEL
KNOWN AS CHINO HILLS THREE
HUNDRED. IT IS SURROUNDED ON
EITHER SIDE BY THE EXISTING
PARK AND THE FIRST NATIONAL
INVESTMENT PROPERTIES PARCEL.
THIS PARCEL IS ALSO PART OF THE
PARK'S GENERAL PLAN. THAT HAS
BEEN DESIGNATED AS NATURAL OPEN
SPACE ON. THE THIRD PARCEL IS
AN ELEVEN ACRE WALNUT WOODLAND
PARTIAL. KNOWN AS THE B.
PROPERTY THIS PARCEL BORDERS
THE PARK ON TWO SIDES AND ALSO
IS LOCATED. WITHIN THE CORE
HABITAT ZONE THE OWNER OF THIS
PARCEL HAS COMMITTED TO
CONVEYING THIS PARTIAL TO THE
STATE FOR INCLUSION IN CHINO
HILLS STATE PARK. AS A
DONATION. THE TWO LARGER
PARCELS REFERENCE YOU HAVE BEEN
SPECIFIED AS PRIORITY
ACQUISITIONS FOR DECADES AS
PART OF THE PARTS GENERAL PLAN.
IF THE OPPORTUNITY TO ACQUIRE
THESE PROPERTIES IS MISSED
THESE PARCELS WITH MORE WITH
MORE THAN LIKELY BE SOLD TO
PRIVATE DEVELOPERS.
INTERVENTIONAL DISPOSITIONAL
HAVE SUBSTANTIALLY DETRIMENTAL
IMPACTS ON THE FUTURE CHARACTER
OF THE PARK. AND THE EXPERIENCE
OF CALIFORNIANS WHO VISIT THE
PARK. FURTHERMORE ACCORDING TO
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF FISH
AND WILDLIFE CALIFORNIA HAS A
LARGER NUMBER OF THREATENED
SPECIES. THAN ANY OTHER STATE
IN THE U. S. MENTION OF THE
STATE PARK IS HOME TO MORE THAN
TWO HUNDRED SPECIES OF BIRDS
AND MAMMALS MANY REPTILES AND
AMPHIBIANS. THOUSANDS OF
SPECIES OF INSECTS AS WELL AS
ONE OF THE PLAN COMMITTEES
SEVERAL WHICH ARE DEEMED
THREATEN TO DANGER SPECIALLY
PROTECTED. ACQUISITION OF THE
THREE PARCELS OF LAND WILL
AVOID THE PROSPECT OF HABITAT
FRAGMENTATION. THE LEADING
CAUSE OF SPECIES ENDANGERMENT
OR EXTINCTION. AS I NOTICED AT
THE OUTSET NO ADDITIONAL
APPROPRIATION FROM THE STATE'S
GENERAL FUND OR OTHER PUBLIC
COUNTS. WILL BE NECESSARY FOR
THE INCORPORATION OF ANY OF
THESE PARCELS INTO THE PARK.
ONE OF THE PARCELS IS A
DONATION AN EXISTING FEDERAL
STATE AND PRIVATE FUNDING
SOURCES HAVE BEEN IDENTIFIED
FOR THE ACQUISITION. OF THE
OTHER TWO PARCELS. WITH ME
TODAY IS. SHE BACK HILLS FOR. A
LOCAL ENVIRONMENTAL
CONSERVATION ORGANIZATION.
WHICH IS PLAYED AN ESSENTIAL
ROLE IN ADVOCATING FOR THE
ACQUISITION. AND PRESERVATION
OF OPEN SPACE IN THE AREA. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE TODAY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THEN WILL MOVE TO THE LEAD
WITNESS IN SUPPORT THAT WAS
JUST MENTIONED. MELANIE
SLAUGHTER BACK CREWS ON THE CO
HOST PHONE LINE WELCOME TO THE
COMMITTEE. GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS MELANIE SLAUGHTER BACK AND I
REPRESENT HELD FOR EVERYONE.
FOUNDERS OF CHINO HILLS STATE
PARK. IN THE ABSENCE OF A
SECOND LEAD WITNESS STAND IN
THE TIME OF KOBE I WILL BE THE
ONLY WITNESS. THE LATE NINETEEN.
AND DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS
FROM THE ASSEMBLY AND SENATE I
HAVE WORKED COOPERATIVELY TO
CREATE THIS STATE PARK THAT
SITS AT THE JUNCTURE OF WAR
GROWN. EACH LOS ANGELES ORANGE
SAN BERNARDINO AND RIVERSIDE.
IT IS ONE OF THE MOST PARKS IN
THE SYSTEM AND IT'S NOT YET
COMPLETE. WE DESIGNED THE PARK
ALONG RIDGELINES BOUNDARIES SO
ONCE INSIDE VISITORS DIDN'T YOU
KNOW THAT NINETEEN MILLION
PEOPLE ARE ON THE OTHER SIDE.
THE RICHEST ALSO PROTECTS THE
WATER QUALITY FOR WILDLIFE
YEAH. THE DEPARTMENT OF PARKS
AND RECREATION. HAS ALWAYS
WANTED TO OWNERSHIP ON THE
STILL UNPROTECTED. EASTERN
RIDGE LINE. PLANS ARE. AS HIGH
PRIORITY IN THE PARKS PLAN.
AFTER FORTY YEARS WE FINALLY
HAVE WILLING SELLERS AND
FUNDING TO BUY THE LAND BUT NOW
STATE PARKS WILL TAKE BILLIONS.
SB TWO SIXTY SIX WHAT IN
CORPORATE THREE PROPERTIES INTO
STATE PARK OWNERSHIP. IN
ADDITION TO PROTECTING THE
EASTERN RIDGE LINE A THIRD
PROPERTY WOULD BE DONATED
TOGETHER THESE PROPERTIES ALSO
MEET REQUIREMENTS WE NEED TO
COMPLY WITH A COURT APPROVED
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT. BETWEEN
OUR ORGANIZATION. P. R. AND THE
METROPOLITAN WATER DISTRICT.
DESPITE STATE PARKS TO TAKE
TIME WE ARE. TO ACQUIRE THESE.
BY SECURING AVAILABLE STATE AND
FEDERAL FUNDING BY FINDING AN
INTERIM MANAGER. THANKFULLY
MOUNTAINS RECREATION AND
CONSERVATION AUTHORITY AGREED
TO TEMPORARILY MANAGED ANGEL
IN. THIS BILL PROCEEDS TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. THERE ARE
NO ACQUISITION COSTS FOR DPR
BUT BY THE END WE WILL HAVE
SECURED NEARLY ONE POINT FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS FOR LONG TERM
MANAGEMENT OF THE LANES. FUNDS
WERE OBTAINED THROUGH THE
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT EMPLOYEE
AND OWNER DONATIONS. WITH YOUR
SUPPORT S. B. TWO SIXTY SIX
WILL HELP PROTECT THE STATE
INVESTMENT ALREADY MADE IN
CHINO HILLS STATE PARK BY
STATING BEATRIZ LINES FROM
DEVELOPMENT. THIS BILL ALSO SET
UP THE SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT
PROVIDES BASED SOLUTIONS. FOR
CLIMATE ADAPTATION. AND THE
REQUEST WILDLIFE COURT SHE AND
TO MEET THE GOVERNOR'S THIRTY
BY EXECUTIVE ORDER WE ARE YOUR
YOU VOTE I AM OF A FOR
QUESTIONS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MUCH. WE WILL NOW MOVE TO OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND THIS
IS TRUST- BOB. NAME AN
ORGANIZATION IS THERE ANYBODY
IN THIS HEARING ROOM THAT
WISHES TO REGISTER SUPPORT ON
THIS BILL. SEEING NONE IS THERE
ANYONE IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
THAT WISHES TO REGISTER SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE THEN WE'LL GO TO
THE PHONE LINE. OF THE
TELECONFERENCE MODERATOR IS
REGISTER SUPPORT AND IT'S JUST
NAME AN ORGANIZATION AT THIS
POINT. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
TWO SIXTY SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. AND THE OPERATOR WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER AND PLACE YOU BACK INTO
Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB TWO
SIXTY SIX. POINT PRESS ONE.
ZERO NOW OUT. WE HAVE SEVEN
PARTICIPANTS IN Q. READ WELCOME
TO THE COMMITTEE JUST NAME AN
ORGANIZATION. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR LINE NUMBER EIGHTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI GOOD MORNING JAN
NUMBERS BADLY BACK WHEN THEY
HAVE THE CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS
FOUNDATION AND THE COURT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MODERATOR. I
NUMBER NINETY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
RECALL MARKER THAN AUTO WITH
THE TRUCK REPUBLIC LAND AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MODERATOR. Y. NUMBER THIRTY TWO
THE LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ROMERO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION VOTERS
IN SUPPORT OF THE FUTURE THANK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MODERATOR.
BY NUMBER NINETY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR CAN DON'T
KNOW REPRESENTING DEFENDERS OF
WILDLIFE AND SUPPORTED AT G.
SIX SIX THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MODERATOR. THE LINE
NUMBER NINETY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING CAL REGISTERING SUPPORT
FOR AUDUBON CALIFORNIA THANK
YOU THANK YOU OUR MODERATOR.
NUMBER EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. PRINTED
OFF THE VEHICLE CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MODERATOR. LINE NUMBER THIRTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NUMBER THIRTY SIX
MAYBE ON MUTE. GOOD MORNING
MATTHEW BAKER PLANNING
CONSERVATION LEAGUE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MODERATOR.
BUT AT THIS TIME MEDICARE WE
HAVE NO ONE ELSE COULD YOU ARE
PRECEDED VERY MUCH STAND BY
WE'LL BE BACK TO YOU IN A
SECOND THIS WOULD BE THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR ANYBODY TO
REGISTER OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL WAS THERE ANYBODY IN THIS
HEARING ROOM. SEEING NONE WERE
MOVED TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY IS
THERE ANYONE THAT WISHES TO
REPRESENT- OPPOSE THIS BILL IN
THAT ROOM. SING NON MODERATOR
WILL MOVE TO THE PHONE LINE IS
THERE ANYBODY IN THE
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE WISHES
TO OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION SB TWO SIXTY SIX
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. IT WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER COMPLETELY BACK INTO THE
QUEUE. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB
TWO SIXTY SIX. PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO NOW. THAT IS ALMOST HERE
WE HAVE NO ONE IN Q. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MODERATOR NOW WE'RE
GOING TO BRING THE MATTER BACK
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS COMMENTS MOTION.
SENATOR ALAN WELL I JUST WANTED
TO COMMEND THE AUTHOR AND FOR
THIS BILL AND I WANT TO COMMEND
ALL THE HARD WORK THAT'S GONE
BEHIND GOING INTO THIS IS THIS
HAPPENING I'VE NEVER BEEN TO
THE STATE PARK- BUT I'VE
CERTAINLY TAKEN THE OPPORTUNITY
IN. PREPARATION FOR THE MEETING
TODAY TO LEARN ABOUT IT AND SEE
SOME OF THE BEAUTIFUL
PHOTOGRAPHS AND- GO ONLINE AND
LEARN ABOUT IT I CERTAINLY HOPE-TO VISIT IN THE FUTURE. YOU
KNOW I'VE I'VE TAKE THE TIME TO
GO UP AND INTO THE STATE PARKS
NEAR MY- HOME TO PENN STATE
PARK WILL ROGERS STATE HISTORIC
PARK THE BEAUTIFUL. STATE PARKS
THE SENECA MOUNTAIN NATIONAL
RECREATION AREA AND I'LL TELL
YOU- YOU KNOW THEY ARE GETTING
CHOCK FULL OF FOLKS. WHO
ACTUALLY WAS DOWN IN YOUR NECK
OF THE WOODS CRYSTAL COVE NOT
TOO LONG AGO AND PEOPLE ARE
REALLY TURNING TO OUR STATE
PARKS NOW MORE THAN EVER. GIVEN
THE PANDEMIC IT'S ONE OF THE
FEW SAFE AND HEALTHY PLACES FOR
PEOPLE TO GO ON RECREATION-
THERE'S SUCH A NEED IN THAT THE
ABSOLUTE DEARTH OF QUALITY OPEN
SPACE OPPORTUNITIES FOR PEOPLE
FROM ALL BACKGROUNDS VERTICALLY
IN THE LOS ANGELES. ORANGE
COUNTY REGIONS. ARE THAT ARE SO
URBANIZED AND- YEAH I JUST ON
I'M I'M GLAD TO SEE STATE PARK.
FIVE THE- THEY- QUITE NEWLY DID.
LONG IT'S SUCH A RARE
OPPORTUNITY. AND YOU KNOW AND
OUR POPULATION CONTINUES TO
GROW AND GROW AND THERE'S SUCH
A DEMAND FOR THIS- FOR THE FOR
THE FOR THE RECREATIONAL- AND
WILDERNESS OPPORTUNITIES THAT
THAT STATE PARKS LIKE THIS
PROVIDE TO OUR POPULATION AND
ALSO SAY THAT YOU'RE SEEING AN
INCREASINGLY DIVERSE. GROUP OF
FOLKS OUT ON THE TRAILS FROM
EVERY BACKGROUND. FROM ALL
DIFFERENT AGES FAMILIES AT
CENTER AND SO. I WANT TO
COMMEND THE AUTHOR LIKE TO MOVE
THE BILL I ALSO LIKE TO BE
ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR IF THAT'S
POSSIBLE. AND- I LOOK FOR TO
SING THIS BILL PASS. THEN WE
HAVE A MOTION FROM US UNDER OUR
FEATHER FURTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS. DID YOU TAKE THE
AMENDMENTS GOOD MYSTERY DID
STARSHOT SHOULD NOW AND NOT WAS
INCLUDED IN SENATOR OWNS MOTION.
OKAY ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
CONCERNS. SENATOR NEWMAN YOU
MAY CLOSE A DAY TO DAY I DO
APPRECIATION ON YOUR COMMENTS-
CHEERIOS STATE PARK IS TRULY
JUL- MISHLER BACK. IN HER
MOTHER CLEAR AND A NUMBER OF A
REALLY WONDERFUL JOB WORK
LITERATURE FOR DECADES- IN THE
ACQUISITION AND FRUSTRATIONS
OPEN SPACE I'D I WOULD COMMEND
IT TO ANYBODY. GLAD TO TAKE YOU
ON A TOUR- IN TOTAL OF THREE
PROPERTIES COVERED BY SB SIXTY
SIX WILL ADD APPROXIMATELY
FIFTEEN HUNDRED ACRES. TO THE
EXISTING PARK AND S INDICATED
AS YOU NOTED DVRS FAILED TO
TAKE ACTION ON ENQUIRING AND
CORPORATE INSTITUTIONAL LAND.
FOR MORE THAN A DECADE DESPITE
THE EXISTENCE OF WILLING
SELLERS- A MANAGEMENT- THE TEAM
THAT'S BEEN IDENTIFIED SECURED-
AND IT NO COST NO ADDITIONAL
COSTS TO TAXPAYERS SO. I'M
GOING GRATEFUL OF FOR YOUR
WORDS OF SUPPORT TODAY.
BANCORPORATION THE SITUATION
PARTIALS IN THE PARK WELL CAL
CALIFORNIA IS NOTED. ON ITS WAY
TO ACHIEVING THE GOVERNOR'S
RECENTLY ANNOUNCED GOAL OF
PRESERVING 30% OF THE STATE'S
LANA COASTAL WATERS. BY THE
YEAR TWENTY THIRTY. I'M
GRATEFUL FOR THE TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT TODAY AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASTRONOMICAL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
FILE ITEM EIGHT S. B. TWO SIX
SIX. THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED THE FIRST AMENDED AND
RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS LAYERED HI
LITTERED I'D JONES. JONES ALL
RIGHT ALLEN. HI ELLEN ALL RIGHT
EGGMAN. GROVE GROVE ON HEARD.
HUESO LEMOND. SHE DID AYE
LIMóN HAI. THE HOUSING OKAY
THAT HAS ENOUGH VOTES BUT WE'RE
GOING TO HOLD THE ROLE OPEN
AND- AND CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS WHEN WE'RE DONE SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
MEMBERS LET ME JUST SAY IN A
MOMENT I'M TURNING THE GAVEL
OVER TO OUR SENATOR JONES AND
I'M GONNA PERCENT MY OWN BILL
WE HAVE TWO BILLS LEFT WE HAVE
FILE ITEM NINE. AND WE HAVE
FINALIZED- TWELVE WITH SENATOR
WILK SO I'M JUST GIVING NOTICE
TO SENATOR WELL THAT HIS NEST
NEXT UP AND WHEN WE ARE DONE
WITH THOSE TWO BILLS WE WILL
OPEN THE ROLE FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS SO THAT EVERYBODY
SHOULD BE AWARE OF. THAT THEN I
AM GOING TO PRESENT THE BILL
FROM HERE WHATEVER SENATOR
JONES RECOGNIZED RIGHTS AND
ALERT HAS FILE ITEM NINE SB
THREE TWENTY TWO. YOU MAY
PROCEED THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
I'M NOT GOING TO. GIVE AN
EXPANSIVE PRESENTATION THAT I
MIGHT OF IF WE WERE EARLIER IN
THE HEARING BUT THIS IS. SENATE
BILL THREE TWENTY TWO IT WOULD
ESTABLISH THE CALIFORNIA
CONSERVATION RANCHING INCENTIVE
PROGRAM. IT AUTHORIZES THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSERVATION TO
ENTER VOLUNTARY THREE YEAR
CONTRACTS WITH THE OWNERS AND
LESSEES OF PRODUCTIVE
RANGELANDS GRAZING LANCER
GRASSLANDS. IT OFFERS INCENTIVE
PAYMENTS AND TECHNICAL SUPPORT
FOR THE ENHANCEMENT OF A
GRASSLAND HABITAT- CALIFORNIA'S
GRASSLANDS ARE RAPIDLY
DETERIORATING TWENTY THOUSAND
ACRES OF CALIFORNIA RANGELANDS
ARE LOST EVERY YEAR. AND
SUSTAINABLE CONSERVATION IS
CRITICAL BY WORKING
COLLABORATIVELY IT CAN BOLSTER
EFFORTS TO ENHANCE THEIR
QUALITY AS WELL AS IMPROVE AND
PROTECT GRASSLAND HABITATS. FOR
POLLINATORS TWO HUNDRED PLUS
BIRD SPECIES AND OTHER CRITICAL
WILDLIFE. THIS IS A VOLUNTARY
PROGRAM IT SUBJECT TO
APPROPRIATION IT'S VERY SIMILAR
TO OTHER ONES THAT HAVE DONE.
BEEN DONE IT HAS WIDE SUPPORT
FROM AUDUBON WHICH IS THE
SPONSOR TO THE- CATTLEMEN'S
ASSOCIATION AND UNITED AIRYMEN
DEBTOR IN SUPPORT SO IT'S
ACROSS THE BOARD. TESTIFYING IS
DONE AGO MARK MARKER GUARD ON
BEHALF OF THE MARKET GUARD
FAMILY GRASS. L. L. C. AND
MATTHEW PAULS HOUSE ON BEHALF
OF THE AUDUBON CALIFORNIA.
APPRECIATE THE TIME AND
RESPECTFUL. WE WILL ASK FOR AN
IPHONE. THANK YOU CENTER LARRY
LET'S GO THE WITNESS THEM MAIN
WITNESS IS IN SUPPORT THE PHONE
LINE. MY NAME IS DONNA MARQUEE
GUARD. AND I AM A CATTLE
RANCHER WITH OUR FAMILY RANCH
MARQUEE GUARDS FAMILY GRASS
THAT. WE HAVE BEEN SELLING
CERTIFIED GRASSFED BEEF RAISED
IN SINAMA MORAN AND SAN MATEO
COUNTIES FOR OVER SIXTEEN
YEARS. WE ARE ALSO ONE OF THE
FEATURED RANCHERS IN THE
DOCUMENTARY KIDS THE GROUND.
OUR FAMILY HAS DEEP ROOTS IN
RANCHING ON THE CALIFORNIA
COAST WE FEEL BLESSED TO HAVE
ACCESS TO THE MOST BIO DIVERSE
GRASSLAND TYPE IN ALL OF NORTH
AMERICA. THE COASTAL TERRACE
PRAIRIE WHERE THERE ARE MORE
EASY PER SQUARE METER THAN ANY
OTHER GRASSLAND REGION IN THE
NATION. I AM IN STRONG SUPPORT.
OF SB THREE TWENTY TWO. BILL
WALKER BY A BRANCH LANDOWNER
AND CONSERVATION GROUPS
TECHNICAL AND ON THE GROUND
ASSISTANCE TO ENHANCE THE
HABITAT FOR GRASSLAND BIRD
SPECIES. WHEN CATTLE ARE
MANAGED UTILIZING ECOLOGICAL
AND INDIGENOUS LAND STEWARDSHIP
PRINTABLE WEEKLY GRASSLAND BIRD
SPECIES OF CONCERN SUCH AS THE
GRASSHOPPER SPARROW ACTUALLY
INCREASE IN NUMBERS. ANOTHER
SIDE BENEFIT IS CARBON
SEQUESTRATION ARE SPOILED THE
QUESTER POINT FIVE TONS OF
CARBON PER ACRE PER YEAR AND IF
10% OF CALIFORNIA'S FIFTY FOUR
MILLION ACRES OF RANGELAND WHAT
IS THE QUESTION ABOUT MUCH SOIL
CARBON IT WOULD BE EQUIVALENT
TO TAKING TWO MILLION PASSENGER
VEHICLES OFF THE ROAD FOR ONE
YEAR. I THINK WE HAVE YET TO
REALIZE THE POTENTIAL OF OUR
GRASSLAND TO HELP MEET THE
STATE REQUIREMENT CALLED. HELLO
ALSO REDUCES FUEL LOADS TO HELP
PREVENT WILDFIRES. NOW IS THE
TIME TO SUPPORT RANCHERS TO
IMPLEMENT CONSERVATION
CONSERVATION RANCHING PRACTICES
AND MAKE REGENERATIVE FOOD
PRODUCTS A LARGER PERCENTAGE OF
OUR FOOD SUPPLY. WE NEED
RANCHERS TO MAINTAIN A VIABLE
OPERATION TO PROVIDE SAFE AND
FAIR RURAL JOBS WHILE ALSO
CARING FOR OUR PRECIOUS NATURAL
RESOURCES. THIS BILL WILL
ASSIST WITH THAT GOAL AND I
STRONGLY ENCOURAGE AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS MARGARET GUARD
WILL GO TO THE SECOND- WITNESS
IN SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS MATT ALL
HOUSE ON BEHALF BOTTOM ON
CALIFORNIA I'D LIKE TO THANK
THE SENATOR FOR AUTHORING THIS
BILL AND A SPECIAL THANK YOU TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR THEIR
DETAILED WORK ON IT. SB TWENTY
TO THE CONSERVATION RANCHING
PROGRAM BILL- IN THE INTEREST
OF TIME I'LL KEEP MY TESTIMONY
BRIEF- THIS BILL IS PRETTY
STRAIGHTFORWARD INCREASE A
VOLUNTARY INCENTIVE PROGRAM.
FOR CALIFORNIA RANCHERS AND CAL
OPERATORS TO PRACTICE
SUSTAINABLE AND REGENERATIVE
MANAGEMENT ON THE LANDBAY
GRACE. RECENT STUDY IDENTIFIED
CALIFORNIA GRASSLAND AND THE
MORE RELIABLE AND RESILIENT
CARBON SINK THEN IT'S FOREST.
WE ALL KNOW THE CLIMATE CHANGE
FIRE OR INVASIVE SPECIES OR FOR
DEPLETION IMPORT GRAZING
PRACTICES HAVE DEGRADED AND
CONTINUE TO DEGRADE LARGE
PORTIONS OF CALIFORNIA'S
GRASSLAND AND RANGELAND. WHICH
INCREASES OUR ECONOMIC AND
ECOLOGIC VULNERABILITY. THERE'S
A WIDE VARIETY OF FACTORS THAT
LEAD TO THESE CORE GRADED
GRAZING PRACTICES- AND DOES
INCLUDE THE PERCEIVED IN ACT
ACTUAL COST THE TRANSITION IN
MAINTAINING REGENERATIVE
GRAZING PRACTICES. NEED FOR
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND THE
LACK OF FINANCIAL OR OTHER
INCENTIVES TO SUPPORT CHANGE
MANAGEMENT- SIMILARITY-
CONVERSION OF RANGELAND HIGHER
VALUED CROPS ARE DEVELOPMENT.
IS OFTEN DRIVEN BY MARKET
FORCES IN THE INABILITY OF
THESE RANCHERS AND LAND
MANAGERS TO KEEP THE PROPERTY
IS NATIVE RANGELAND. TO THIS
BILL PROPOSES TO ADDRESS
SEVERAL THESE FACTORS THAT LEAD
TO RANGELAND LAS OR CONVERSION
BY PROVIDING THIS TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE. IN BY PROVIDING
THESE FINANCIAL INCENTIVES TO
SUPPORT BETTER MANAGEMENT. IN
ADDITION TO PROTECTING FROM
DEVELOPMENT AND IMPROVING SOIL
HEALTH- EIGHT TRIBES CARBON
SEQUESTRATION. TO ME
CALIFORNIA'S CLIMATE GOALS.
STRAWS HOUSE UNDER EXCEED
RANGING IN ITS IF YOU CAN WRAP
IN A STAY APPRECIATED. SURE YOU
KNOW RANGERS LAND MANAGERS HAVE
AN INTRINSIC KNOWLEDGE OF THIS
LAND THAT THEY LIVE AND WORK ON
AND ARE THE STEWARDS OF THESE
NATURAL RESOURCES SO FOR ALL
THESE REASONS WE SUPPORT THE
BILL AND ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS REGARDING
THE BILL. THANK YOU HANG ON THE
LINE IF THERE'S QUESTIONS WILL
COME BACK TO ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT AND FORTY TWO OH THREE.
MR MYERS BILL. YES MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS MARK SMITH ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA WATER FELL IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN FORTY
TWO OH THREE. ANY WITNESSES IN
THE MORE RURAL EXIT AROUND.
ZERO FOUR ZERO ZERO FOUR ZERO
NO WITNESSES IN TWO ZERO FOUR
ZERO. MODERATOR OTHER ANY
WITNESSES ON THE LINE WISHING
TO REGISTER THEIR SUPPORT OF SB
THREE TWENTY TWO. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE TWENTY
TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
AND THE OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE
YOU WITH YOUR LINE NUMBER AND
PLACE IT BACK INTO Q. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. THREE TWENTY
TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN THEIR
OWN NOW. ONE MOMENT THE CHAIR.
ANALYSTS SAY MR WE HAVE SEVEN
PEOPLE IN Q. OKAY THANK YOU
HAVE FIVE THEM. HI FOLKS THINK
YOU CAN REMEMBER TO STATE THEIR
NAME AND THEIR- ORGANIZATION
AND THEIR POSITION ON THE BILL
PLEASE. THANK YOU MISTER
CAROLINUM OR EIGHTY SIX YOU
WANT IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS. WERE IT NOT JUST WITH
THE CLIMATE CENTER IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF A STATE THREE JUDGE
THANK YOU. NUMBER THIRTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MORE ROMERO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION VOTERS
IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE TEACHER.
MY NUMBER SIXTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU MISTER CLAREMONT THANK YOU
MAKERS FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF RESOURCE
CONSERVATION DISTRICT IMPORT.
BY NUMBER NINETY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY
NUMBER NINETY FIVE MAYBE I NEED.
MY NUMBER NINETY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. OVER
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CATTLEMEN'S ASSOCIATION HAS
UNDERWEAR DELUDE INJURED
INTRODUCTION CCA'S IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AT. THREE TWENTY
TWO. Y.NUMBER THIRTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MATTHEW BAKER
CLAIMING CONSERVATION THEY GET
CLIPART. ONE MOMENT MEDICARE WE
DO HAVE SOMEONE ELSE QUEUING UP.
BY NUMBER NINETY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING JAMIE GANDHI HAPPENS
WHEN VIOLENCE AND FIND AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. MY NUMBER
ONE HUNDRED YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
TAYLOR THE NUMBERS STEVEN MYERS
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
HABITAT CONSERVATION PLANNING
COALITION IN SUPPORT. AND AT
THIS TIME IF THE CHAIR WE HAVE
NO ONE ELSE IN Q. THANK YOU MY
REJECTED CHECK ONE MORE TIME
JUST IN CASE SOMEBODY. STARLINE.
THANK YOU ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
THREE TWENTY TWO PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN. ZERO ONE ZERO TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE
TWENTY TWO. WHY NUMBER NINETY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MAYBE YOUR LINE IS A
MUTE BY NUMBER NINETY FIVE. YES
CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES IF WE CAN
HEAR YOU. OKAY GREAT SORRY- CAN
HELP YOU KNOW- REPRESENTING
DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE AND
CALIFORNIA NATIVE PLANT SOCIETY
WE HAVE A SUPPORTIVE AMENDED
CONDITION AND WOULD REALLY LIKE
TO THANK CHAIRMAN LAYERED. ON
THE FOSTERS WHO ARE HAVE
ALREADY BEEN STARTED YOU AND
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH BACK
TO ADDRESS JUST SOME. MINOR
ISSUES REGARDING- CLARIFYING
PROTECTION PROVIDER BIRTH YOU
CAN'T DO MUCH. THEIR
ACCOMMODATING ARCHITECT. THANK
YOU MONTEREY ANY OTHER. IT'LL
SERVE AS A LESSON IN Q. THANK
YOU WILL GO NOW INTO- WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION MY UNDERSTANDING
IS THERE'S NO LEAD OPPOSITION
ON THE CONFERENCE LINE WILL GO
TO. WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
FORTY TWO OR THREE. NO
WITNESSES HERE IN- TWENTY
FORTY. NO WITNESSES THERE-
MODERATOR THERE ANY WITNESSES
ON THE PHONE LINE IN OPPOSITION
TO THREE TWENTY TWO. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB THREE
TWENTY TWO. PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AN OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOU
WITH YOUR LINE NUMBER AND PLACE
YOU BACK INTO Q. ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF SB THREE TWENTY TWO. PRESS
ONE ZERO NOW. THAT IS MY
MESSAGE HERE WE HAVE NO ONE
SHOWING UP. THANK YOU
MODERATOR- WILL MOVE TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR COMMENTS
QUESTIONS CONCERNS. SEEING NO
HANDS RAISED. MISTER ALAN I
JUST WANT TO ASK THE DOCTOR MAY
I HEARD THE- DO YOU FEEL
CONFIDENT YOU'RE GOING TO WORK
OUT THESE ISSUES WITH THE-
GOVERNMENT APPLIED CITING. IT
IS IMPORTANT GAUGE DIçN WERE
BOTH OPTIMISTIC OKAY THANK YOU
NUMBER HAVE BEEN MOVED ABOUT I
HAVE A MOTION ON THE BILL ANY
OTHER COMMENTS. I HAVE SELECTED
OUR VOTE THANK YOU THE SENATOR
HAS CLOSED WE CAN CALL THE ROLL.
FILE ITEM NINE S. B. THREE TWO
TWO THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT
FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
LAYERED HI THERE ALL RIGHT
JONES I JONES ON A ALLEN. ALLEN
ALL RIGHT EGGMAN. ROOF GROVE
I'D HERTZBERG HUESO LIMóN.
ENTER THE AMOUNT SB THREE
TWENTY TWO HI LIMóN HI STERN.
IT HAS. IT HAS ENOUGH BUT WE'LL
PUT IT ON CALIFORNIA SENATE ON
CALL. IT HAS ENOUGH VOTES TO
GET OUT BUT WILL PUT ON CALL
FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS. THANK
YOU THINK THAT WRAPS UP SOONER
LEARNS BILL THREE TWENTY TWO.
LAST ONE IS WILK I MOVE TO
ADJOURN. HOW LONG DID YOU THINK
YOU'RE GOING TO STAY ON IN A
RESPECTIVE. AND SENATOR WILK AS
I WELCOME YOU LET ME JUST SAY
THAT THIS IS OUR LAST BILL AND
TO THE SENATORS THAT ARE
OUTSTANDING ON ROLL CALLS I'M
GONNA LIFT THE COALS AFTER
SENATOR WILK IS DONE SO I SHOW
THAT SANDERS EGGMAN WEISS OF
STERN AND HERTZBERG ARE MISSING
FROM SOME ROLL CALLS SO WITH
THAT WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE
SENATOR WILK THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS. I'M HERE TO
PRESENT SB FIVE TWENTY WHICH
WILL REOPEN THE PUBLIC PROTESTS
PERIOD ON STATE WATER BOARD
WATER. APPROPRIATION
APPLICATIONS WHEN A DECISION
HAS NOT BEEN MADE WITHIN THIRTY
YEARS FROM THE ORIGINAL FILING
DATE PRIOR TO ANY FINAL
DETERMINATION BEING MADE. AT
FIRST LIKE TO THANK THE
CHAIRMAN THE COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS BILL AND
I ACCEPT THE TO PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS IN THE ANALYSIS
WHICH CAME AT THE
RECOMMENDATION OF THE STATE
WATER BOARD. THE FIRST
CLARIFIES THAT THIS PROVISION
ONLY APPLIES TO APPLICATIONS
FOR QUOTE A BENEFICIAL USES
THAT INCLUDES MINING USE AND
QUOTE. THE SECOND ALLOWS THE
BOARD TO NOT RE OPEN THE WHOLE
PROCESS IF IT HOLDS A HEARING.
OR CONDUCTS PROCEEDINGS AFTER
FORTY FIVE DAYS OF WRITTEN
NOTICE. THIS WILL ALLOW ANY
PERSON REQUESTING NOTICES THE
HEARING OR PROCEEDINGS. TO
PARTICIPATE AS A PARTY IN THE
HEARING OR PROCEEDINGS
INCLUDING IN THE PRESENTATION
OF EVIDENCE WITHOUT HAVING TO
FILE PROTESTS. THE VITAL LOCAL
ISSUE AFFECTING MY COMMUNITY IS
SUPPOSED TO MAKE A MINE IN THE
SOLID THAT CANYON. THE WATER-
APPROPRIATION APPLICATION WAS
FILED IN NINETEEN NINETY ONE
WITH THE STATE WATER BOARD WITH
NO HEARING BEING HELD. DURING
THIS THIRTY YEAR APPLICATION
POCESS A SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF
ISSUES HAVE ARISEN THAT AND
THAT'S WHY MY BILL COMES INTO
PLAY. SENATE APPROVED A BALLY
BACK THEN THIRTY YEARS AGO WAS-
RURAL SLASH SUBURBAN AND NOW IS
TRANSITIONING INTO SUBURBAN
SLASH URBAN. ADDITIONALLY WE
HAVE THE SANTA CLARA RIVER
WHICH IS UNDERGROUND REVERSAL
LAST WILD SCENIC RIVER IN ALSO
IN CALIFORNIA. IT IS- IN
IMPACTED SO SB FIVE TWENTY
ALLOWS COMMITTEE MEMBERS
OPPORTUNITY TO FORMALLY WEIGH
IN AT PERCENT EVIDENCE BEFORE
THE BOARD MAKES A FINAL
DETERMINATION ON APPLICATIONS
OF BEEN AGAIN PENDING FOR OVER
THIRTY YEARS. AS DYNAMICS OF
WATER AVAILABILITY COULD CHANGE
SIGNIFICANTLY SIGNIFICANTLY FOR
THE STATE AS A WHOLE DURING THE
LAST THREE DECADES DUE TO
CLIMATE CHANGE. SUCKS SUCH
ACTIONS WILL ALLOW COMMUNITY
MEMBERS THE OPPORTUNITY PROVIDE
CURRENT HYDROLOGICAL DATA TO
THE BOARD AS TO THE IMPACT OF
SUCH PROJECTS ON THEIR WATER
SUPPLY. THIS WILL HELP PROTECT
THE ENVIRONMENT ENSURE THAT THE
APPLICANTS APPROPRIATIONS ARE
INDEED IN THE PUBLIC INTEREST.
WITH ME THIS MORNING HOPEFULLY
ON THE PHONE IS OUR WITNESS
TESTIMONY FROM THE MAYOR PRO
TEM OF THE CITY OF. SANTA
CLARITA LOREEN WEST. WELCOME TO
THE CA- MAYOR PRO TEM.
GREETINGS CAROL AIRD VICE CHAIR
JAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I AM THEIR PER CAPITA
REQUESTED FROM THE CITY OF
SANTA CLARITA AND I AM VERY
HONORED TO SPEAK TO YOU TODAY
I'LL BE HAPPY SANTA CRUZ CITY
COUNCIL. EARNERS YOUR
CONFERENCE WILL END IN FIVE
MINUTES. THANK YOU THAT THAT
WAS NOT AN EDITORIAL COMMENT ON
THE LENGTH OF YOUR TESTIMONY SO
PLEASE CONTINUE. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR COURTESY SANTA CRUZ CITY
COUNCIL AND TO URGE YOUR
SUPPORT SENATE BILL FIVE TWENTY
IT IS CRITICAL THAT THE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD TAKE
INTO CONSIDERATION THE MOST UP
TO DATE ENVIRONMENTAL
CONDITIONS AND PUBLIC REVIEW.
WHEN CONSIDERING A WATER
APPROPRIATIONS APPLICATION. AS
IS THE CASE FOR THE MANY
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE
GREAT STATE DATA CREATED HAS
EXPECTED. AND STATE SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF GROWTH IN THE LAST
THIRTY YEARS MORE THAN DOUBLING
IN POPULATION TO OVER TWO
HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND RESIDENTS. IN AN
EFFORT TO ENSURE RESPONSIBLE
GROWTH THE CITY HAS PRIORITIZED
THE PROTECTION OF CRITICAL
NATURAL RESOURCES AND WILDLIFE
CORRIDORS INCLUDING THE
PRESERVATION OF MORE TAN
ELEVEN THOUSAND ACRES OF OPEN
SPACE AND DEVELOPMENT OF OVER
EIGHTY MILES OF MULTI PURPOSE
TRAILS. THIS EFFORT HAS
ENHANCED RECREATIONAL
ACCESSIBILITY PROTECTED SOME OF
THE STATE'S MOST ICONIC
WILDLIFE AND NATURAL HABITATS
IN THE CENTRE CRIVELLI. IN
ADDITION TO SIGNIFICANT GROWTH
WE HAVE ALSO EXPERIENCED
ENVIRONMENTAL CHANGES INCLUDING
CONSECUTIVE YEARS OF BELOW
AVERAGE RAINFALL IS EXTENSIVE
ENVIRONMENTAL AND COMMUNITY
CHANGES MAKES IT MORE CRITICAL
THAT THE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD ISSUE A NEW
PUBLIC HEARINGS AND PROTESTS ON
LONG PENDING WATER
APPROPRIATION APPLICATIONS. AS
THOROUGHLY DESIGNED BILL ONLY
APPLIES TO APPLICATIONS THAT
HAVE BEEN PENDING FOR MORE THAN
THIRTY YEARS. SENATE BILL FIVE
TWENTY WILL ONLY IMPACT
APPLICATIONS THAT ARE SEVERELY
OUTDATED AND LACKED THE TRUE
IMPACT OF WATER SUPPLY HABITAT
SPECIES AIR QUALITY AND OTHER
ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES.
ADDITIONALLY IT IS CRITICAL
THAT THIS PROCESS SECURITY
OPPORTUNITY FOR INTERESTED
STAKEHOLDERS AND MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
BOARD'S PROTEST PROCEEDINGS AND
ENSURE THAT THE BOARD CONSIDER
PUBLIC COMMENTS REGARDING
CURRENT POTENTIAL IMPACTS.
RELATED TO WATER PREPARATION.
TWO WATER PEPPER OUTPUT PARDON
ME JONATHAN IF YOU COULD BEGIN
TO WRAP UP. WITH DEPRESSION.
LASTLY AS I UNDERSTAND THERE
MAY BE AMENDMENTS MADE TO THIS
LEGISLATION TO REFINE THE SCOPE
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH HER TO
WELCOME AND OTHER STATE
AGENCIES COMMITTEES AND OFFICES
ENSURING THIS BILL IMPROVES THE
BOARD'S REVIEW PROCESS AND
ALLOW SUFFICIENT TIME FOR
INTERESTED PARTIES TO
ADEQUATELY PARTICIPATE. IN THE
HEARING PROCESS WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION OF MY
COMMENTS ABOUT BE HAPPY SANTA
CRUZ CITY COUNCIL I
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR AYE VOTE
ON SENATE BILL FIVE TWENTY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY. THIS
WOULD BE THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
ANYBODY TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL BUT MORE TO THE
POINT IT JUST NAME AN
ORGANIZATION IS THERE ANYBODY
IN THIS COMMITTEE ROOM THAT
WISHES TO OFFER SUPPORT. SEEING
NONE IS THERE ANYBODY IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY THAT WISHES TO
OFFER SUPPORT. SEEING NONE
MODERATOR WILL GO TO THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE IS THERE
ANYONE THAT WISHES TO OFFER
SUPPORT JUST NAME AN
ORGANIZATION. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT. SB THREE SIXTY NINE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AN
OPERATOR WILL TAKE YOUR LINE
NUMBER AND TAKE YOU BACK IN THE
QUEUE ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE THAN THEIR- NOW. ANOTHER
THOMAS IS HERE WE HAVE NO
MONITORING YOUR CONFERENCE WILL
END IN ONE MINUTE. LET ME JUST
ASK BEFORE S. PEOPLE IN THE
ROOM MODERATORS ANYBODY QUEUED
UP IN OPPOSITION. HELLO SIR
OKAY THEN LET ME- WE APPRECIATE
YOUR SERVICE TODAY MODERATOR.
LET ME ASK IS THERE ANYBODY IN
THIS ROOM THAT WISHES TO OPPOSE.
THERE ANYBODY IN ROOM TWENTY
FIVE FORTY THAT WISHES TO OFFER
OPPOSITION. THEN WILL BRING THE
MATTER BACK BEFORE THE-
COMMITTEE AND LET ME JUST LET
EVERYONE KNOW WHEN WE ARE ACT
ON THIS BILL WILL BE LIFTING
THE CALLS SO. IF SENATOR HUESO
OR STERN- WITHIN HEARING
DISTANCE ARE WILL BE LIFTING
THE CALLS AFTER THIS BILL BACK
IN FRONT OF THE COMMITTEE.
SENATOR ALAN. I KNOW THIS IS
THE SIZE BEEN A LONG AND DRAWN
OUT PROCESS AND I'M FROM YOU
KNOW. BUT IT WORKS KIND OF THIS
LIKE. I WANT TO- WHICH THE
SENATE VERY HAPPY BIRTHDAY
TODAY. AND AS A BIRTHDAY
PRESENT I'D LIKE TO MOVE HIS
BILL. NO I THINK THE REAL
BIRTHDAY PRESENT WOULD BE
VOTING FOR. THEM YOU KNOW.
THAT'S AN IMPLIED YES OKAY ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION. WOULD YOU
ARE TOO CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE BANK YOU
WOULD THE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. FILE ITEM TWELVE S.
B. NOW TO FIVE TWO ZERO THE
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED THE
FIRST AMENDED RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
BLARED. HI LAYERED I'D JONES
JONES A ALLEN. ALLEN HI EGGMAN.
EGGMAN ON A GROOVE. GROVE HI
HERTZBERG. HI WHERE. LOAN AND
INTERNALLY MON I S. B. TWO FIVE
TWENTY MONNING HI STERN. THAT
THAT HAS ENOUGH VOTES BUT WILL
HOLD THE ROLE OPEN AND THANK
YOU I THOUGHT I WAS DONE THE
SECRETARY WAS GOING TO BE DONE
WITH THIS ISSUE. STILL GOING TO
TAKE YOU SIR THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. OKAY IF OUR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS HAVE VOTED PLEASE
RETURN TO THE COMMITTEE ROOM
BECAUSE WE ARE GOING TO LIFT
CALLS ON THE ONE SENATOR STERN
SENATOR HUESO WERE MISSING YOU.
SENATOR STERN WAS GOING TO COME
IN A FEW DOES WITH THIS LIST OF
CALLS THE MINUTE HE WALKS IN
THE ROOM RIGHT. AND TO THE
SENATORS THAT VOTED ON
EVERYTHING THANK YOU. THANKS
MIKE. FIVE THOUSAND- WON'T YEAH
DO YOU WANT TO LIST THE CALL ON
OF THE THAT THE LAST THREE
DIGITS. HERE SENATORS. SO WHAT
LEFT OVER CALLS. CALL ABSENT
MEMBERS OF ITEM TO SB FORTY
FIVE THE CURRENT VOTE IS FIVE
TWO TWO. HUESO I HUESO ARI
STERN STERN HI THAT'S SEVEN TWO
WILL CLOSE THE ROLAND TALLY
THAT VOTERS BILL WAS OUT FILE
THREE FILE ITEM THREE SB SIXTY
THREE THE CURRENT PHONE IS.
SEVEN ZERO ONE. OKAY SO. QUICK
SO HI AS GOES OUT THE CONSENT
CALENDAR THE CURRENT VOTE IS
SEVEN ZERO HUESO. HUESO EYES
STERN ALL RIGHT STERN HI
ELIZABETH WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
FILE ITEM FIVE S. B. EIGHTY
THREE THE CURRENT VOTE IS SEVEN
ZERO HUESO. HUESO ARE YOU STERN
STERN HI IT WAS OUT WILL CLOSE
ROLE FILE ITEM SIX SB EIGHTY
FOR THE CURRENT VOTE IS FIVE
ONE AND ONE HUESO THREE SO ARI
STERN STERN ALL RIGHT. THEN
THAT WILL COVER PHONE BILL WAS
OUT WILL CLOSE TO ME- FILE ITEM
EIGHT S. B. TWO SIX SIX THE
CURRENT VOTE IS FIVE ZERO
EGGMAN. EGGMAN ON HERTZBERG. HI
HUESO HUESO EYES STERN ALL
RIGHT THE BILL IS OUT FILE ITEM
NINE SB THREE TWENTY TO THE
CURRENT VOTE IS FIVE TWO ZERO
EGGMAN EGGMAN RIAA HERTZBERG
HERTZBERG HIGHWAY SO WE SO ON
EASTERN STERN HI IT WAS OUT
FILE ITEM TEN SB THREE FORTY
SEVEN THE CURRENT VOTE IS EIGHT
ZERO HUESO HUESO HI. BILLS WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE BUT BUT WAS OUT
OF FILE ITEM TWELVE SB FIVE TWO
ZERO THE CURRENT VOTE IS SEVEN
ZERO HUESO HUESO EYES. STERN
ALL RIGHT THE COMPLETE OKAY
THAT THAT BILL WITHOUT AND SO
NO OUTSTANDING VOTES RIGHT. MR
SECRETARY. I KICKING THE LAST
OF THOSE ON ALL THE- OKAY THEN
LET ME THANK EVERY THAT UPPER
TO. TODAY IF YOU WERE UNABLE TO
TEST PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR
COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE COMMITTEE OR
VISIT THE WEBSITE WE APPRECIATE
YOUR PARTICIPATION THANKS TO
EVERYBODY FOR THEIR ENDLESS
PATIENCE AND COOPERATION WE'VE
CONCLUDED THE AGENDA WE STAND
ADJOURNED. THANK YOU.